alors petite information donc ce matin
nous avons examiné 58 amendements donc
pour la matinée
il ne nous reste plus que
55003 amendement à examiné très bien
alors nous poursuivons avec l'article 1
et je passe la parole à Monsieur juvain
monsieur viry-laissis en l'absence de
Philippe juvas en ce début d'après-midi
Philippe juin dépose un amendement qui
traite effectivement des régimes
spéciaux de retraite et une des raisons
du débat sur les régimes spéciaux de
retraite c'est l'équilibre de ces
régimes particuliers spécifiques avec du
financement public c'est-à-dire avec
l'argent des contribuables et avec des
modalités de liquidation de retraite
différent du droit commun Philippe juin
par cet amendement il demande à ce que
le régime spécial de retraite de la
Banque de France ne soit pas clôturée et
sont des déjà exprimés ce matin car
c'est un financement singulier et
autosuffisant assurément suffisant avec
des provisions pour payer les pensions
sans avoir à recourir aux contribuables
infinés c'est la raison pour lequel
puisque ce régime s'autofinance avec des
gains liés au placement c'est
véritablement un régime spécifique il
considère que l'analyse doit être
différente de celle des régimes spéciaux
pour lequel nous sommes très favorables
à la clôture
celui-ci mérite effectivement débat
très bien amendement suivant puisque
nous sommes sur des amendements
identiques monsieur dareville
merci madame la Présidente
tout simplement comme vous l'avez
compris nous demandons le retrait de ce
texte de tout ce texte en réalité
de tout ce texte dont effectivement
cette amendement cet article qui
concerne les régimes spéciaux et la
particulièrement l'origine spéciaux de
social pardon de la Banque de France
nous sommes opposés à la fois à ce
projet puis à la méthode utilisée pour
opérer un certain nombre de
modifications il y a des réformes à
faire de notre régime de retraite mais
celle que vous proposez est la manière
que vous employez pour le faire nous
semble tout à fait inacceptables je
notais les propos de madame la Première
ministre ce week-end devant des
journalistes qui expliquaient que le
report de l'âge légal n'était plus
négociable et je me suis demandé à quel
moment il avait été et en fait en
cherchant j'ai pas trouvé parce que je
pense qu'il l'a jamais été c'est le cœur
de votre projet et c'est ce qu'ils font
de finalement c'est ce qui c'est la
raison d'être de ce projet donc voilà
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
demandons la suppression de cette de cet
article et je le rappelle le trait de ce
texte
très bien monsieur Ruffin pour
l'amendement suivant monsieur Clouet pas
de problème
merci madame la Présidente donc toujours
disponible évidemment pour défendre la
grande banque ou plutôt ici c'est
salarié puisque nous le savons tout et
tous le régime de la Banque de France ne
tombe pas du ciel il a un peu plus de
200 ans il a été créé par le citoyen
Benjamin delessertes dont on notera que
à l'époque il a commis une erreur sur le
calcul des taux de cotisations grâce à
laquelle il y a beaucoup d'argent qui
était accumulés par le régime comme quoi
mieux vaut les erreurs de
révolutionnaire que les bons calculs
d'un macroniste pour équilibrer les
comptes mais ce régime spécifique de la
Banque de France a déjà été l'objet
d'attaque assez virulente puisque les
majorations de bénévolans sont été
supprimés et en dépit de vos attaques
les projections du corps sont sans appel
le régime va de mieux en mieux et chaque
projection de 2012 a aujourd'hui montre
que les ressources propres ne font que
augmenter c'est donc un régime qui se
finance tout seul sur 30 ans un régime
qui est rentable et si il est rentable
c'est aussi grâce à l'auto
administration des assurés puisque je
rappelle que ce sont elles et eux qui
pilotent
la collecte des fonds qui l'évolution
parallèle des salaires et des pensions
et donc qui ont permis de maintenir un
système qui fonctionne il vaut donc
mieux là aussi avoir des assurés qui
gèrent leur compte plutôt que d'avoir
des experts comptables du gouvernement
qui viennent les plumer on le voit donc
l'équilibre d'un budget c'est une
question de démocratie et aucune caisse
n'a plus de sécurité que la surveillance
des fonds par les assurés eux-mêmes et
elles-mêmes d'ailleurs cette caisse ne
reçoit pas d'argent de l'État ne reçoit
pas de subvention pour son budget de
fonctionnement donc on se rend compte
que même lorsque vous proclamez vouloir
récupérer de l'argent vous parvenez à en
perdre c'est assez exceptionnel enfin
cette caisse est profitable puisqu'elle
verse des excédents lorsqu'elle en
constitue au budget général donc on a un
intérêt à son existence bref pour nos
finances publiques pour les droits des
salariés et notamment celles et ceux de
la Banque de France avec lesquels nous
marcherons demain nous proposons la
suppression de ce passage du texte
très bien Madame sebahi ou madame
Rousseau défendu à merveille par nos
collègues très bien Madame la rapporteur
général
merci
sur je vais commencer par la forme parce
que c'est jamais très convaincant comme
argument mais c'est quand même important
parce qu'on écrit la loi si on adopte
cette amendement comme je l'ai dit j'ai
pu le dire tout à l'heure vous affilié
par votre amendement toutes les
personnes actuellement à la Banque de
France au régime général c'est un
argument de forme passons au fond je
note du côté de la nuque en défendant
cet amendement vous défendez un système
par capitalisation
ça ce système qui se rapproche à
certains égards du régime de la fonction
publique n'en reste pas moins un régime
spécial les cotisations par exemple ne
sont pas prélevées uniquement sur le
traitement nominal mais aussi sur un
certain nombre de primes tandis que les
bonifications sur le calcul du montant
de la retraite divergent encore de celle
de la fonction publique aussi de ce
point de vue la fermeture de ce régime
est cohérente avec notre objectif comme
je l'ai rappelé tout à l'heure de
lisibilité de justice et d'équité le
système de retraite donc avis
défavorable
très bien donc j'ai monsieur decourson
qui souhaite s'exprimer oui mes chers
collègues je crois être le seul
magistrat à la Cour des comptes de cette
noble assemblée avoir contrôlé pour la
première fois le régime de retraite de
la Banque de France il y a un tiers de
siècle
en fait ce qui est indiqué dans l'exposé
des motifs n'est pas tout à fait exact
c'est pas un régime en capitalisation
c'est un régime en semi qui
capitalisation c'est à dire qu'on
capitalise les cotisations salariées et
sur les revenus du capital qui ne
couvraient pas à l'époque le montant des
prestations la Banque de France faisait
une subvention d'équilibre voilà donc
c'est pour ça que c'est pas un vrai
régime de capitalisation c'est en semi
capitalisation
et c'est Napoléon
Bonaparte comme on disait qui a créé
cela et notre collègue l'a évoqué
c'était pas une pension de retraite
c'était des indemnités de bénévolence
voilà ce régime a été réformé donc on ne
parle plus d'indemnités de bénévolant il
y a 15-20 ans à peu près notamment suite
au rapport de la Cour des comptes qui
montrait le caractère complètement
archaïque mais mes chers collègues la
Banque de France elle vit de quoi elle
vit d'un monopole de l'émission ce qui
fait qu'elle fait des bénéfices
considérables qu'elle reverse
partiellement d'ailleurs
au budget de l'État mais je pense que
c'est assez savoureux de voir des
groupes politiques qui ont toujours
défendu la capitalisation est combattue
la capitalisation
défendre un régime de capitalisation
c'est vrai que vous êtes innovant par
contre
par contre mes chers collègues il y a un
problème de fond qui n'est pas traité
par ce texte c'est que les réserves sont
de 15,4 milliards afin décembre 2021
confère le rapport du corps qui est
propriétaire madame le rapporteur de ses
15,4 milliards la réponse est simple
puisque c'est la capitalisation des
cotisations des salariés c'est les
salariés donc si on met en extinction
est-ce qu'il faut pas reverser au
personnel une partie du fond de
capitalisation c'est une petite question
je vous rappelle que ce sont des fonds
privés ce sont pas des fonds publics
confère d'ailleurs la précédente échec
de la réforme dans lequel on voulait
disposer de ces fonds et que le Conseil
exceptionnel aurait certainement annulé
puisque ce sont des fonds privés donc
faut indemniser c'est la Constitution
alors est-ce que pourriez nous éclairer
madame la rapporteur très général
puisque c'est l'expression utilisée par
d'autres présidentes sur ces délicates
questions
très bien la parole est à Monsieur Paul
Christophe
oui merci ma Présidente c'est vrai qu'on
a l'impression de revenir un peu les
débats qu'on avait vu à l'époque du
système universel de retraite ou on
avait pointé du doigt effectivement
cette c'est ce régime par répartition
non pas déguisé mais effectivement un
régime par semi capitalisation tel que
le précise et bien notre Émile en
collègue alors vous voyez effectivement
défendre un régime par capitalisation
surprenant au moment où on défend la
retraite par répartition mais cela dit
juste une petite précision parce que à
l'époque la CGT donc il défendait
puisqu'elle est associée à ce régime et
bien ce dispositif très particulier
faisait état dans une cotisation de
7,85% des rémunérations qui alimentent
finalement un capital qui est lui-même
finalement et jouer en bourse pour et
bien générer des excédents alors cela
dit comme le disait aussi Charles des
excédents qui sont insuffisants
aujourd'hui on a 17000 bénéficiaires de
la retraite pour 10000 cotisants vous
voyez déjà le déséquilibre démographique
qui est pas tant et puis pour préciser
et rappeler qu'en 2018 le Sénat avait un
rapport sur ce sujet et il se met à 428
millions d'euros annuel le déficit
proposé donc si on voit bien que il y
avait besoin là aussi quand même d'avoir
le contribuable pour venir à la
rescousse de ce de ce système en
lui-même donc c'est pense une précision
qui est intéressante à partager avec
vous
très bien Monsieur Marc Ferracci
oui merci madame la Présidente sur ce
sur ce sujet j'avoue que j'ai entendu
quelques arguments dont j'ai un petit
peu de mal à saisir à saisir le sens et
la cohérence pour commencer il s'agit
évidemment pas ici de toucher aux
réserves qui ont été accueillis qui ont
été accumulés et qui vont rester
intégralement dans le régime il s'agit
de faire converger la protection sociale
et je veux aussi rappeler ce qui est la
finalité politique de la suppression des
régimes spéciaux qui est contenue dans
ce projet de loi retraite c'est bien une
logique d'égalisation des conditions et
de convergence de la protection sociale
c'est très important parce que
s'agissant de la Banque de France ça a
été dit elle dispose d'un modèle
économique qui lui permet de générer des
réserves il est fondé il est on est
fondé à se demander si ces réserves et
bien doivent permettre de laisser
perdurer et bien des différences de
traitement entre ces salariés et les
salariés
du régime général ensuite il y a un
argument qui a été évoqué que je trouve
également assez surprenant
qu'il faudrait préserver ce régime parce
qu'il est en excédent alors là j'ai
envie de vous dire chers collègues si
c'est l'argument que vous employez et
bien il faut revoir votre argumentaire
sur les jus spéciaux qui eux sont en
déficit et dont nous avons parlé lors de
leur lors de la discussion précédente ça
n'est pas un argument totalement
recevable et je veux ici insister sur le
fait que l'État contribue aujourd'hui à
hauteur de 6 milliards d'euros au régime
spéciaux et c'est la raison aussi pour
laquelle nous souhaitons les supprimer
en tout cas les éteindre enfin il y a un
autre argument qui n'a pour le coup pas
été évoqué mais qui a été évoqué dans la
discussion précédente c'est l'argument
de la pénibilité les régimes spéciaux
gagneraient être préservés parce que les
métiers
occupés par leurs salariés sont des
métiers pénibles
je ne veux pas évidemment jeter de
quelques manières que ce soit le propre
sur les salariés de la Banque de France
mais je pense que la pénibilité de leur
métier ne se compare pas à celle
d'autres métiers et en particulier ceux
qui vont faire l'objet dans le cas de
son projet de loi de mesure
d'accompagnement très ambitieuse je vous
remercie
très bien monsieur
oui merci madame la présidente des
débats notamment de l'intervention de
Charles de Courson
comment
va se mettre en oeuvre l'extinction de
ce régime et le traitement par la
gouvernance de ce régime du traitement
des réserves
est-ce que il n'y a pas une période
transitoire à prévoir avant la
suppression totale du régime spécial de
retraite de la Banque de France de
manière à ce qu'ils puissent traiter les
réserves
qui appartiennent aux salariés avec ce
fond privé on l'a vu dans d'autres
situations
où
l'idée qui est seulement six mois peut
poser question parce qu'il y a aussi des
instances de concertation pour pouvoir
traiter ça et donc c'est à se demander
si on devrait pas corriger cet article
là en prévoyant une période de
transition pour le traitement prévu à
cet effet
bien monsieur Guedj
merci madame la Présidente juste un
point parce que vous savez depuis le
début on nous dit tout ça a été le fruit
je parle de la réforme dans son ensemble
d'une grande concertation une grande
association des acteurs moi je veux
juste collectivement attirer notre
attention sur l'interpellation café le
conseiller général à la Banque de France
c'est le nom du représentant du
personnel
que ce soit la direction de la Banque de
France où les organisations syndicales
tout comme les agents ils ont découvert
par voie de presse la suppression du
régime dans la réforme des retraites et
donc quand on a un représentant du
personnel en l'occurrence ce conseiller
général qui a saisi le 9 décembre 2022
le ministre du Travail du plein emploi
et de l'insertion pour pouvoir avoir un
échange avec
le ministère porteur de cette réforme et
qu'à date d'aujourd'hui le 25 en tous
les cas ils nous disent au 25 janvier
donc j'imagine que ce n'est pas arrivé
entre le 25 janvier aujourd'hui qui a eu
aucune réponse du ministre pour avoir un
échange avec les organisations
syndicales au moment où leur régime
spécial envisage d'être supprimé je
trouve qu'on a la l'illustration un
petit peu de la pseudo-concertation qui
a présidé à la mise en place de cette de
cette réforme
et que le seul rendez-vous qui a eu il a
eu lieu début décembre entre la
direction de la Banque de France et le
cabinet d'Olivier du soft et que là
singulièrement les organisations
syndicales n'étaient pas associés voilà
un argument supplémentaire pour
expliquer que on ne peut souscrire à la
suppression de ce régime très bien
Madame la rapporteur général oui merci
je voudrais tout d'abord répondre à
monsieur de Courson monsieur Bazin
marque Ferracci a déjà en partie répondu
mais je crois que c'est une question que
vous pourrez reposer bien évidemment en
séance pour confirmer mais l'idée n'est
pas de de modifier ici le régime de
propriété des réserves le traitement
monsieur Bazin des réserves est
décorrélés à la mise en place des de la
mesure au 1er septembre pour les
nouveaux contrats
enfin Monsieur Guedj je vous propose de
redonner ces arguments quand tu auras le
ministre ici moi je suis rapporteur on a
auditionné la Banque de France et et il
n'y avait pas
beaucoup de députés à cette audition je
voudrais finir par un dernier argument
sur la Banque de France puisque il me
semblait intéressant de d'ailleurs c'est
dans l'étude d'impact pour revenir sur
le fait qu'il s'agit là d'une mesure de
justice que la durée de vie à la
retraite des femmes à la Banque de
France c'est 35 ans pour comparer à la
durée de vie des femmes dans la
population générale à la retraite de 24
ans donc on voit bien ici que il s'agit
d'une mesure de justice
très bien
on va pas repartir monsieur Clouet c'est
par rapport à votre amendement monsieur
cloué oui très bien
jamais je ne ferai de hors sujets ma
dernière présidente mais c'est pour
rebondir sur deux dés arguments qui ont
été avancés d'abord vous nous dites les
femmes bénéficiaires du régime la Banque
de France vivent 35 ans de pension une
fois qu'elles ont pris leur retraite par
rapport à des femmes du régime général
ordinaire qui devraient 24 ans et moi
lorsqu'on me donne ce chiffre j'ai
plutôt envie qu'elle se passe tous à 35
plutôt que c'est la 35 parce que la 24
premièrement deuxièmement monsieur
Ferracci nous parler des conditions de
travail la Banque de France mais moi je
pense qu'à manutentionnaire qu'il
travaille dans un hangar ou sous des
dorures est un manutentionnaire et donc
à partir de là son métier n'en est pas
moins pénible et finalement la question
plus générale qui est posée par
l'ensemble des régimes qui sont ici en
discussion c'est évidemment le sujet de
la diversion lorsque 80% des gens sont
contre le projet et bien la solution la
plus simple et de réussir à trouver des
boucs émissaires et d'essayer de moules
de lever les pensionnés les cotisants et
les actifs les uns et les unes contre
les autres puisque vous nous parlez
d'ailleurs assez souvent de
22 régimes différents mais en disant les
42 vous comptez tous les régimes 10
spéciaux complémentaires et généraux ce
qui aboutit la conclusion que
effectivement 100% des salariés sont
dans un des 42 régimes qui ne veut pas
dire grand chose
très bien donc sur ce je rappelle je
rappelle et je réponds à monsieur de
Courson en même temps qu'on a dit une
intervention par groupe je redonne la
parole parce que effectivement ils sont
l'auteur les personnes sur l'auteur de
l'amendement donc les auteurs de
l'amendement donc c'est pour ça donc je
mets aux voix ces amendements donc
identiques qui ont reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur
général qui est pour
qui est contre ils sont rejetés
amendement suivant monsieur desker
monsieur Bonnier monsieur Brun pala non
pas défendu amendement identique
monsieur Guedj pour le 882
monsieur le député
merci madame la Présidente je suppose
que vous n'avez pas non plus consulté
les syndicats de Claire de notaire ni le
syndicat des notaires pour faire cette
suppression de régime spécial de la même
manière que nous vous opposons nous nous
opposons à cette méthode sur le principe
sur la non concertation sur le caractère
brutal de la manière dont vous agissez
s'il vous plaît nous pensons que il
aurait fallu avant toute réforme se
concerter et faire en l'accord des
organisations qui gèrent les différents
régimes et c'est pourquoi évidemment
nous soutenons cet amendement de
suppression très bien monsieur le député
monsieur Monet un moment identique
merci madame la Présidente
on est contre la suppression des régimes
spéciaux et Monsieur Ferracci a dit
quelque chose de totalement juste
vous avez dit les pénibilités ne se
comparent pas c'est pour ça qu'on est
contre la suppression des régimes
spéciaux parce que les régimes sociaux
correspondent à des métiers à des
natures de métiers et ils ont été créés
parce que les salariés de ces métiers
laissez-moi finir laissez-moi finir ne
vous énervez pas je vous écouterai après
si vous avez quelque chose à dire à
chaque métier correspond c'est
particularités et s'il y a des régimes
spéciaux calmes mais vous monsieur vous
aurez la parole après
qui ont conquis des droits justement par
rapport à leur métier c'est parce qu'il
y a des particularités à ces métiers et
nous on est contre la suppression des
régimes sociaux parce que c'est ne pas
prendre en compte la spécificité de
chaque métier en matière de pénibilité
mais c'est vrai que vous la pénibilité
c'est pas trop votre affaire puisque en
2017 vous avez supprimé 4 critères de
pénibilité notamment la manutention je
rappelle donc c'est pour ça qu'on est
contre parce que chacun ses regroupé
dans son métier pour faire connaître
pour faire valoir ses spécificités très
bien Madame panot
enfin qui défend madame abo Mongolie
monsieur Clouet allez-y merci madame la
Présidente donc c'est amendement
effectivement vise aussi à empêcher la
suppression du régime associé à la
caisse de retraite et de prévoyance des
clercs et employé de notaire donc cette
caisse je pense que tout le monde là à
l'esprit c'est une caisse qui a une
spécificité c'est qu'elle traite un
risque vieillesse et un risque de
maladies en un seul coup ce qui permet
un équilibre puisque l'excédent d'une
des entre guillemets branches de la
caisse finance les besoins de
financement de l'autre alors les raisons
pour lesquelles nous sommes en faveur du
maintien de cette caisse sont les
suivantes d'abord elle est intégralement
autofinancée et notamment elle est là
aussi par le paritarisme c'est-à-dire
lorsque les assurés gèrent eux-mêmes le
niveau des cotisations et les modes de
mutualisation de pour couvrir leur
risque une fois arrivé le moment de la
vieillesse et bien on constate que les
besoins de financement sont couverts car
ils mettent les recettes là où il y a
besoin en termes de dépenses et enfin
parce que cette caisse est intéressante
en ce qu'elle a pris une certaine nombre
d'initiative qui nous mérite devoir
inspirer la sécurité sociale plutôt que
de venir liquider cette caisse dans ce
cas-là d'original d'abord puisque cette
caisse fonctionne sur la base de comité
de retraité ça fait 40 ans qu'il y a des
dizaines et des dizaines de bénévoles
dans tout le pays qui accompagne les
pensionnés d'exercice de leurs droits
notamment en étant eux-mêmes formés par
les équipes de la caisse c'est quelque
chose dont la sécurité sociale pourrait
s'inspirer plutôt que de voir le
liquider lorsque ça existe ailleurs
c'est une caisse ou l'assuré le cotisant
le retraiter le malade sont une seule et
même personne ce qui favorise des
parcours d'accès aux droits qui sont
bien plus favorables et ne laissent tout
le monde ne laisse pardon personne
tomber lors de l'exercice de ses droits
et liquidation des pensions enfin c'est
un régime qui a eu des avancées
importantes sur la pension de réversion
avec un droit d'option qui mériterait
lui aussi d'être considéré pour élever
le niveau d'indemnisation des personnes
face aux risques que peu incarner la
vieillesse lorsqu'on est dans une
situation où on est menacé de
paupérisation pour toutes ces raisons on
ferait mieux de s'inspirer de cette
caisse plutôt que de vouloir la liquider
très bien Madame La Valette pour
l'abondement suivant allez-y s'il vous
plaît merci madame la Présidente il faut
préserver le régime spécial des clercs
et employés de notaire nous l'avons dit
un régime spécial ne se justifie si les
dépourvus d'intérêt pour la sauvegarde
d'une profession majeure nous parlons
ici de 76000 claires et employés de
notaire qui cotisent à une caisse
excédentaire dans une activité soutenue
et organisée notre commission à
auditionné la caisse de retraite et de
prévenance des clercs et employés de
notaire qui nous a très clairement
indiqué n'avoir jamais demandé de
participation à la collectivité et nous
a même assuré avoir toujours pu puiser
dans ses réserves propres lors des
années de déficit de l'orchestre la
suppression de ce régime viendrait qu'à
porter des problématiques de recrutement
et supplémentaire à la profession aussi
chers collègues je vous appelle à
empêcher le gouvernement de fermer ce
régime spécial de retraite
bien Madame la rapporteur général merci
madame la Présidente encore une fois il
s'agit d'un amélioration de la
lisibilité
bien sûr j'ai auditionnée la caisse
correspondante je suis d'accord avec
vous sur un point le régime d'éclairs et
des employés de notaire et sans doute
aujourd'hui le plus proche du régime
général et celui dans le financement
également le plus autonome le moins
demandeur de subventions complémentaires
pour autant c'est également l'un des
régimes qui comprend l'une des parts les
plus importantes de personnes
polypensionnées et on a expliqué tout à
l'heure que dans l'idée de simplifier il
était important de fermer ces régimes
spéciaux
voilà donc pour ses avis je suis
défavorable pour ces amendements
très bien Madame la rapporteur donc j'ai
plusieurs demandes de paroles monsieur
de Courson qui piétine assis mais il
piétine
je me réjouis de ce débat madame le
rapporteur général je voudrais vous
poser deux questions
la première vous l'avez dit vous-même ce
régime ne pose aucun problème
d'équilibre aucun
donc vous ne pouvez pas justifier cela
par
un déficit structurel et vous avez dit
que il est fort peu aidé par l'État il
est pas du tout aidé par l'État il y a
pas un sou qui vient du budget de l'État
vers ce régime
deuxième observation est-ce que pourriez
nous dire combien ils ont de réserves
donc vous ne pouvez justifier de la
suppression que dans la mesure vous
considérez que la justice entre tous les
Français c'est que tout le monde soit
progressivement régime général position
d'ailleurs que qui est ma position
depuis un tiers de siècle donc moi je
n'ai pas changé je n'ai pas changé
mais est-ce que vous pourriez nous
expliquer quel est le montant des
réserves et comme vous n'avez pas
répondu à ma question sur le régime
précédent il y a que 15,4 milliards pour
la Banque de France de réserve est-ce
que nous rappeler combien il y a de
réserves dans ce régime et là encore
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
très bien Monsieur Marc Ferracci
oui deux choses d'abord redire que
l'argument selon lequel un régime parce
qu'il serait en équilibre en excédent et
bien n'a pas besoin de converger avec le
reste de notre protection sociale me
semble être un argument difficile à
entendre de la part de ceux qui ont
demandé que ce soit préservé des régimes
en déficit c'était le cas pour les
régimes de la RATP qui ont été évoqués
tout à l'heure donc il faut avoir quand
même un minimum de cohérence sur ce
sujet si vous utilisez cet argument il
faut l'appliquer et bien à tous les
régimes l'autre élément je veux
reprendre la discussion que nous avons
eu avec Monsieur Monet et avec Monsieur
Clouet monsieur Monet votre collègue
Adrien Cloé vous a vous a démenti tout à
l'heure quand vous dites que la
pénibilité ne se compare pas nous sommes
évidemment d'accord mais au sein d'un
même régime spécial des métiers de
pénibilité différente
peuvent se retrouver et Monsieur cloué
vous a donné l'exemple du
manitentionnaire de la Banque de France
qui à l'évidence à certainement un
métier plus pénible qu'un banquier ou
qu'un analyse économique au sein de la
Banque de France c'est assez différent
que veut répondre la réforme en
individualisant le diagnostic à travers
des visites médicales à 45 à 61 ans qui
permettra aux gens qui ont effectivement
été en situation de pénibilité de partir
plus tôt de bénéficier de fonds de
reconversion et de bénéficier aussi d'un
investissement en termes de prévention
dont on a dit qu'il était totalement
inédit puisque c'est un milliard d'euros
qui vont être dépensés sur cinq ans
voilà
merci bien monsieur bassin
et merci Madame la présente mes chers
collègues c'est plus l'exploser des
motifs qui me qui m'interpellait parce
que on parlait du régime spécial de
retraite des notaires éclaire de notaire
or il me semble que le régime des de
retraite des notaires et celui qui
dépend de la Caisse de prévoyance et de
retrait des notaires la CP RN qui est
pas à confondre avec la
CRPCEN qui concerne en fait les salariés
en plus il y a une deuxième subtilité
c'est que ceux d'Alsace Moselle ne sont
pas concernés
par ce régime spécifique je pense que
c'est important pour la clarté de nos
débats d'avoir ce serait de précision
parce que l'exposé des motifs correspond
pas aux dispositif
merci monsieur le député pour cette
précision monsieur dareville
oui merci madame la Présidente d'abord à
l'instant notre notre collègue Marc
ferrachi expliqué la volonté de ce
projet d'aller vers plus
d'individualisation et c'est d'ailleurs
une des reproches que nous formulons à
l'égard de ce texte dire la volonté
finalement de briser un certain nombre
de garanties collective pour aller vers
une individualisation une
responsabilisation individuelle qui a
été logique poursuivie par par le
gouvernement à travers différents
projets de loi et là on est en train
encore une fois d'attaquer un certain
nombre de garanties collective
cela étant dit concernant les les
régimes en question des clercs de
notaire
la part des cotisations
des personnes concernées et plus
importantes que dans le régime général
il y a un financement supérieur apporté
par les par les cotisants voilà donc je
le signale à chaque fois comme tout à
l'heure notre collègue Elsa faussillon
l'avait fait pour le régime de la de la
RATP parce que les droits
supplémentaires sont financés par une
cotisation supplémentaire voilà y
compris de l'employeur je crois voilà
mériterait vérification mais je crois
donc voilà je voulais souligner ça et
signaler également que ce régime
spécial il concerne la retraite mais il
concerne aussi la maladie la maternité
le décès la validité et que ça a priori
vous n'y touchez pas
donc je sais pas quel est véritablement
la cohérence que je comprends moi en
réalité c'est qu'il y a deux régimes qui
étaient moins dans votre viseur cette
fois-ci celui de la RATP celui des IEG
et puis pour décorer un peu vous en avez
rajouté quelques autres pour que ça soit
pas trop voilà
très bien monsieur turquois
oui merci madame la Présidente oui je
voulais d'abord m'associer aux propos de
notre collègue Bazin il y avait l'exposé
des sommaires ça ne concerne que
l'éclair de notaire et pas les notaires
qui relèvent d'une autre d'un autre
régime c'est un premier point et
deuxième point dans la présentation qui
en est faite une fois encore ça ça
renvoie une vision des métiers où on
gardait le plus souvent un métier pour
la vie entière on était clair de nos
terres à la sortie des études on allait
être clair de notaire jusqu'à la fin
aujourd'hui c'était dit par la
rapporteur les la durée de vie s'est
allongée les métiers on en change et
c'est d'ailleurs un critère aussi qui
pourrait faire peur un certain nombre de
jeunes de s'engager pour toute une
carrière donc on a de plus en plus de
polype pensionnés avec des règles et
notamment sur les droits familiaux en
termes de réversion ça a été cité en
termes de prise en compte des enfants
par exemple qui ne sont pas cohérentes
entre régime quand quelqu'un est poli
pensionné donc je crois que ça ça relève
d'une démarche cohérente que tous les
salariés en tous les cas dans un premier
temps
le chef du même du même régime
très bien monsieur Delaporte oui merci
je pense que mes collègues ont souligné
mon collègue d'arriville le point
essentiel
vous faites des réformes de régime
spéciaux qui sont excédentaires vous
faites semblant que ces régimes spéciaux
sont finalement pour des personnes
privilégiées mais là on voit bien qu'il
y a pas de véritables privilèges pour
les claires de notaire ils partent en
moyenne à 62 ans ils n'ont pas vraiment
plus de droits que la moyenne des
retraités leur régime est excellentaire
et il permet de financer aussi des
prestations sociales donc finalement
vous allez avec ce régime faire non
seulement des espèces d'économie de bout
de chandelle parce qu'on va derrière
appauvrir les caisses sociales si c'est
le cas en tout cas j'aimerais bien que
vous répondiez à cette question qui a
été soulevée par mon collègue de Courson
donc que vont devenir comment va-t-on
compenser cette éventuel déficit pour
ce système donc de prestation de maladie
et puis sur la question de la retraite
est excédent ira donc au régime général
mais on va avoir du coup un alignement
du taux des cotisations patronales
notamment qui est de l'ordre donc de la
part la part patronale c'est 28,95 % de
la rémunération versée donc qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire est-ce que ça veut dire
que on va avoir une baisse des
cotisations patronales sur l'éclair de
notaire enfin voilà j'aimerais bien
qu'on soit un petit peu précis parce que
là je vous avoue que on utilise ça pour
habiller des ensembles de d'autres
régimes spéciaux qu'on considère comme
privilégié mais en l'occurrence voilà
quelle nécessité à faire cela quel coût
induit pour les finances publiques et
puis quelles conséquence pour les
employeurs de Claire de notaire est-ce
que vous êtes finalement pas en train de
faire un cadeau au notaire tout
simplement avec cette réforme
très bien monsieur Ruffin
quand dans les TER on a supprimé les
premières classes moi j'ai trouvé ça
dommage j'aurais préféré qu'on supprime
les deuxièmes et que tout le monde
puisse monter en première
et c'est la même chose que vous faites
aujourd'hui avec les régimes de retraite
au fond ce qui était qui avaient
davantage d'acquis de conquis qui
pouvait partir un peu plus tôt qu'est-ce
que vous vouliez de vouloir dire bah non
vous aurez plus droit mais est-ce que ça
va améliorer le sort des suivants non
pas du tout les amendements qu'on avait
proposé et qui ont été jugés ils
recevables dans cette partie c'était de
demander que tous les travailleurs de la
deuxième ligne les auxiliaires de vie
les assistantes maternelles les
charismes les ouvriers du bâtiment de la
grande distribution les chefs de rayons
et compagnie et des avantages
puissent partir à la retraite plutôt
qu'on
connaisse pleinement leur pénibilité ces
jeunes amendements n'ont pas été jugés
recevables mais depuis que le Président
a pu République a déclaré à la
télévision il faudra se rappeler que
notre pays tout entier repose
aujourd'hui sur ces femmes et ses hommes
que nous économies reconnaissent ces
rémunèrent si mal qu'est-ce que vous
avez fait pour tous ces métiers
vous n'avez rien fait qu'est-ce qui
alors qu'on a des salaires qui sont pas
indexés sur l'inflation qui voit le plus
son petit pouvoir d'achat érodé ce sont
ces métiers là première peine à la place
de la récompense et là aujourd'hui la
deuxième peine c'est sur eux vous la
faites peser le plus c'est sur eux parce
que évidemment les truites et les années
supplémentaires quand on est dans le
bâtiment quand on est auxiliaire de vie
sociale et ainsi de suite et donc le
minimum aurait été que on crée qu'on
permette dans cette retraite de
d'entendre des amendements qui
permettent de discuter que il doit y
avoir des régimes particuliers pour des
gens gens qui dans leur corps ou dans
leur cœur souffre particulièrement du
travail ce que vous n'avez pas permis
très bien je vais passer la parole à la
notre rapporteur merci madame la
Présidente à monsieur de Courson je vous
répond mais je l'avais déjà fait sur les
déjà les réserves pour les clercs de
hauteur c'est 800 millions d'euros en
dans les chiffres que j'ai l'idée elle
n'est pas de modifier le régime de
propriété des réserves et dans les
suites les relations financières avec le
régime général reste le même je voulais
rajouter que comme Nicolas turquoise l'a
dit il y a beaucoup de polypensionnés
dans ce régime même lors de l'audition
de la caisse ils nous ont bien exprimé
que il restait en moyenne 10 ans à
cotiser dans cette caisse les personnes
donc c'est une mesure aussi de de
simplification
dans l'avenir avec toutes ces caisses
différentes donc voilà donc la vie la
vie
ne change pas
malgré l'intervention de nos députés
donc je vais mettre au vois ces
amendements donc
identiques qui ont reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur qui
est pour
je rappelle que seul vote les membres de
la commission des affaires sociales
qui est contre
ils sont rejetés
amendement suivant pas défendu
amendement identique monsieur Guedj
oui madame la Présidente je sais plus
qui a dit à l'instant
que on avait le sentiment que
c'était la RATP et les industries
électriques et gazières qui motivaient
je crois que c'est Pierre d'arriville
voilà je rends toujours à Pierre ce qui
est à Pierre
et que il y avait quelques autres
régimes qui passaient
qui passaient sous vos fourches codines
de manière un petit peu
pour habiller tout ça mais là on touche
en effet un régime
dont l'histoire même et la situation
actuelle ne justifie pas ça suppression
telle que vous l'envisagez le premier
argument parce que c'est celui de la
situation financière du régime de
retrait des industries électriques et
gazières parce qu'on est aussi un peu
dans la même situation on est sur un
régime spécial qui ne coûte rien à
l'état il y a pas un euro de subvention
et le surcoût qui est lié à la situation
démographique du régime depuis son
adossement régime général s'il est
directement compensé par par
par les employeurs on est sur un régime
spécial qui tient compte là aussi des
situations de pénibilité pour lesquelles
nous nous souhaitons et là aussi je
m'inscris dans les propos qui ont été
mentionnés qu'on aille plutôt vers un
alignement par le haut parce que quand
ce régime spécial est créé en 1945
c'était d'une certaine manière dans
l'attente qui pouvait être légitimement
formulé que
ceux des régimes qui avaient des
garanties supérieures au régime général
en cours de création on les maintenait
mais dans la perspective que le régime
général améliore lui ses prestations
pour s'aligner vers le haut ça n'a pas
été le cas et vous nous proposez à
nouveau cette alignement par par le bas
pour un régime où là pas de problème
d'équilibre financier et des enjeux de
pénibilité qui justifient qu'on puisse
le maintenir en l'état très bien
monsieur le député monsieur ou bien
monsieur Monet je ne sais pas
oui merci madame la Présidente bien donc
là on en vient à la situation des
électriciens et gaziers je rappelle que
ce régime a été profondément lié à
l'importance que notre pays a accordé
dans sa reconstruction à la question
énergétique la volonté de construire des
entreprises publiques puissantes qui
soient capables de nous aider à relever
les défis et puis qu'au fil du temps
bien ce régime c'est consolidés
permettant aux électriciens au gazier de
de garantir un haut niveau de droit
correspondant à ce qu'il donne dans leur
travail au cours de leur carrière avec
une caisse qui effectivement est tout à
fait excédentaire et qui a largement
contribué à aux comptes du régime
général ces dernières années avec donc
une solidarité qui s'est qui s'est
exprimée on ne peut pas faire le procès
à ce régime d'être un régime qui est
tourné vers lui-même et qui
refusent de contribuer à la solidarité
c'est tout à fait l'inverse on lui a pas
toujours demandé son avis au passage je
le dis en la matière et donc voilà nous
avons ici là encore des électriciens des
gaziers qui cotisent à un niveau
supérieur et qui donc se constitue
mutuellement un des droits à la retraite
qui correspondent à leur situation donc
je crois que c'est plutôt effectivement
un modèle vers lequel il faudrait se
tourner son nom pas des régimes spéciaux
à nos yeux mais des régimes pionniers et
nous sommes attachés nous aussi à la
défense de ses droits à qui de ses
conquis sociaux en réalité comme le
disait Ambroise Croizat et donc nous
demandons la suppression de de cet
article
très bien Madame panot ou Monsieur
Clouet monsieur legave oui alors
plusieurs choses d'abord à travers le
système du service actif le régime des
IEG prend en compte les métiers dans la
pénibilité les plus et la plus
importante beaucoup a été dit à ce sujet
ce matin notamment et décidément on
n'arrive pas à avoir en quoi la
suppression de ce régime spécial répond
à un objectif de justice et d'équité
parce que la justice ce serait au
contraire de permettre aux salariés qui
en sont privés de bénéficier des droits
qui sont acquis et qui sont fixés dans
ce régime spécial et puis par ailleurs
il y a une aberration cela a été dit
mais je me permets d'insister le régime
des industries
électriques et gazières et largement
excédentaire il a même servi à financer
notamment le régime des agriculteurs et
des artisans et contrairement à ce que
disait tout à l'heure Marc Ferracci
c'est un argument
surtout s'agissant d'une réforme pour
laquelle l'argument en permanence
avancée et qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment
d'argent donc c'est quand même
particulièrement intéressant de savoir
que le régime dont il est question ici
est un régime qui est largement
excédentaire enfin il y a un fait sur
lequel il faut quand même insister c'est
que le fait de fermer le régime spécial
des IEG aux nouveaux entrants tout en
tout en maintenant et c'est heureux le
niveau des dépenses pour ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont affiliés tout ça va
faire perdre 100 millions d'euros au
régime en question donc dans les faits
on s'abote ce régime spécial
pour mieux justifier ce qui est une ce
qui infinie et le but de votre réforme
c'est-à-dire baisser les retraites une
réforme pour payer moins et pour
conclure juste une chose il serait bon
d'entendre je pense
les personnels de ces secteurs et
notamment les salariés d'EDF qui je le
rappelle se sont mis très massivement en
grève le 19 janvier dernier et qui j'en
suis sûr vont renouveler ça demain et
probablement les jours qui suivent
ensuite la parole est à Monsieur Ruffin
j'ai été appelé chez moi dans mon lit à
1h du matin je suis rentré qu'à 9h du
matin chez moi ça inquiète la famille ça
inquiète tout le monde et c'est nous qui
sommes sur le terrain c'est un gazier
Farid qui m'expliquait ça et qui
m'expliquait comment était dans un
logement d'abstreinte comment il était
lavé une permanence et comment cette
année il a eu zéro trois pour cent
d'augmentation de salaire
la question c'est quel mal vous faites
au service public en permanence regardez
dans quel état il est notre pays on va à
l'hôpital c'est les personnes qui
peuvent à 30 pendant 44 heures dans un
couloir
les enseignants c'est du recrutement job
dating le rail c'est le train qui
circule plus et là vous avez éliminé le
service le régime spécial du rail très
bien il nous manque des milliers de
conducteurs dans le pays moi dans mon
coin il y a des tracks qui circulent pas
par absent du conducteur l'électricité
est-ce que vous voulez que ça soit la
même chose qui arrive pour le gaz
électricité à force de peser sur le
travail à force de faire que le travail
dans notre pays soit par rémunéré comme
il faut en indexant pas les salaires sur
l'inflation mais en l'indexant par
exemple sur les dividendes on aurait du
monde dans tous ces secteurs là sans
difficulté
mais là ce que vous faites c'est que un
à un vous êtes en train d'éroder les
piliers du pays piliers de la République
l'école pilier de l'État social
l'hôpital se porte mal après cinq ans de
vos bons et très déloyaux services à
leur égard et là vous faites la même
chose sur l'électricité c'est la même
chose qui risque de se produire dans
quelques années on va se retrouver vous
nous direz qu'on n'arrive pas à recruter
pour dans les institutrices
d'électricité gazières bah oui parce
qu'il y a une compensation à l'astreinte
il y a une compensation des salaires qui
sont pas énormes
très bien Madame kéké
merci madame la Présidente par ce
commandement nous souhaitons que les
régimes spéciaux des industries
électriques et gaziens et de la RATP
soit maintenue pour rappel ce régime ne
sont pas des privilégies des privilèges
c'est faux ce sont le résultat de lutte
dur pour faire reconnaître la pénibilité
de ces métiers essentiels pour la
société le gouvernement parle de
privilèges mais lesquels travailler à
des horaires décalés d'un jour comme de
nuit où travailler les jours fériés ou
les weekends le gouvernement cherche par
ses disposition à une formisée par le
bas il cherche à prendre à ceux qui
galèrent le peu de choses qu'ils ont
gagné grâce à des luttes ils veulent
généraliser à tout le monde la
pénibilité qui ne reconnaît pas les
principaux syndicats représentatifs de
ces branches sont contre la suppression
des régimes mais le gouvernement refuse
de les écouter par mépris comme
d'habitude il est bien si possible de
maintenir ses régimes mais c'est une
question de choix politique et de choix
de société d'autres régimes n'ont pas
été touché ceux des véritables
privilégiés n'ont pas été touchés
faisons le choix du bon sens supplément
les alias 9 à 11
très bien la parole oui c'est bon
monsieur cloué pour l'amendement
identique 4829 oui merci madame la
Présidente donc un amendement lui aussi
qui vise à maintenir les caisses de
retraite qui sont sur la sellette avec
vous puisque ces caisses de retraite on
le sait on l'a dit existe pour donner un
horizon plus général au monde du travail
le principe d'avoir des caisses de
retraite spécifique des régimes
pionniers c'est de tester des choses
d'inventer des manières de se protéger
de mutualiser l'argent qui peuvent
ensuite inspirer le régime général pour
avancer et en l'occurrence on parle
seulement de quelques milliers d'agents
d'exploitation des personnes on le sait
tout et tous ici qui ont des horaires
décalés qui bossent la nuit qui bossent
le week-end qui sont
d'astreinte qui ont de l'usure physique
qui sont responsables de la sécurité de
personnes qui sont prises en charge ou
qui sont accompagnés et souvent des
personnes qui une fois à la retraite
continuent de bosser parce que par
exemple un électricien à la retraite
généralement continue à gérer les pannes
dans tout le voisinage à exercer son
même s'il exerce avec la pension de
retraite comme seul salaire et vous
oubliez que la possibilité du départ
anticipé va souvent perdre avec une
pension incomplète parce que on a d'un
côté des corps usés abîmés de l'autre un
manque d'année de service actif et donc
on a une réduction du niveau de la
pension qui est effectivement perçu
d'ailleurs on ne sait pas quelle est
l'appareil de départ à 57 ans tout le
monde en parle il y a pas de chiffres on
n'en sait rien on ne sait pas non plus
combien ces régimes ont reversé à la
caisse de solidarité enfin pardon à la
Caisse générale puisque vous le savez
bien il y a la compensation vieillesse
généralisée depuis 74 qui fait que les
séries régimes dispe spéciaux
contribuent au régime général combien
ont-ils apporté et donc dit différemment
combien est-ce qu'on leur doit et si
jamais vous vous en prenez assez régimes
c'est évidemment parce que ça continue
votre offensive contre la pénibilité au
travail vous avez supprimé on s'en
rappelle bien les quatre facteurs de
pénibilité charge lourdes agents
chimique vibration mécanique et posture
pénible apparemment macronie de
marteau-piqueur c'est bon pour la santé
et plutôt que de supprimer un régime de
compensation de la pénibilité il faut
plus que jamais l'étendre à l'ensemble
des agents d'exploitation des industries
lourdes électriques gazières des
transports en commun de Paris à Vierzon
en passant par Toulouse et pour notre
part nous n'oublions pas que les régimes
pionniers sont des régimes qui doivent
nous inspirer
Madame La Valette vous avez la parole
merci vous le
savez pas dans des industries
électriques et gazières revêt évidemment
une signification particulière les
entreprises qui exercent en France des
activités de production transport
distribution commercialisation et de
fournitures d'électricité de gaz font
fausses à de fortes disparités en termes
de salaire qu'en termes de prix mais il
se trouve que le régime spécial
aujourd'hui en vigueur permet non
seulement de gommer les inégalités
induite par les différences de
rémunération mais aussi de prendre en
compte la pénibilité de ceux qui
occupent les postes en service insalubre
la conjoncture nous rappelle également à
la retenue je pense quant aux statut des
prés de 136 000 futurs actifs attachés à
la branche alors n'ajoutons pas à la
crise matérielle de l'énergie grande
oubliée d'Emmanuel Macron c'est 6 ou 7
dernières années n'ajoutons pas cette
crise matérielle une crise future de
ressources humaines si le gouvernement
comptait sur la suppression de ce régime
pour faire baisser la contribution
tarifaire d'acheminement nous avons une
idée pour vous nous vous suggérons
plutôt d'agir sur la TICE et la TVA
comme nous le recommandons maintenant
depuis bien trop nombreuses années je
vous remercie
très bien Madame sebahi ce sera un amour
Rousseau qui veut défendra à l'heure où
les infrastructures vieillissent et
particulièrement les infrastructures
gazières et électriques à l'heure où les
métiers se transforment et notamment
avec le développement du travail de en
grande hauteur mais aussi à un moment où
vous voulez à tout prix développer le
nucléaire et nous sommes en opposition
là-dessus vous êtes en train de vous
êtes en train de changer vous êtes en
train de changer les conditions du
métier et les conditions d'accès à la
retraite alors même qui vous allez
aggraver les conditions de travail et la
difficulté de ces conditions de travail
et vraiment en fait là c'est quelque
chose qui est un conquis social
essentiel parce que précisément en
récompense d'une mission de service
public ces agents peuvent être
disponibles en tout lieu et en toute
heure et on l'a vu d'ailleurs pendant le
covid il faisait partie de ses premières
lignes qui étaient sur le front quand il
a fallu tenir les infrastructures au
moment des confinements donc il n'y a
aucune espèce de raison ni
conjoncturelle ni structurel de vouloir
a changé ce régime de retraite est
vraiment encore une fois nous nous
n'aurions à le garder
très bien donc je vais passer la parole
à Madame la rapporteur général pour
avoir son avis sur ses rendements et
ensuite je vous passerai la parole
merci madame la Présidente
je vais essayer de répondre aux
différents arguments des différents
amendements qui qui ont le même sujet
mais avec des arguments différents en
premier lieu s'agissant de l'âge de
départ moyen pour les agents des
industries électriques et gazières il
est effectivement de 60 ans aujourd'hui
soit deux ans et demi de moins que le
régime général toutefois rien indique
que cet âge effectif actuel sera de 62
ans en 2024 ce sera uniquement le moment
de l'application aux salariés des IEG de
la montée en charge de l'augmentation de
l'âge légal s'agissant de la situation
financière des IEG elle maintient de
l'équilibre de ce régime passe par un
mécanisme
d'adossements qui sépare deux catégories
de droits les droits équivalents aux
droits communs des salariés qui font
l'objet de la doucement régime général
et les droits dit spécifiques profs au
financement du régime des IEG et ceux-ci
sont financés pour ce qui concerne
notamment les activités d'acheminement
d'énergie par une contribution tarifaire
spécifique payée par les clients les
industries électriques et gazières sur
les factures finançant les droits acquis
avant 2005 et par une cotisation des
entreprises pour les droits acquis après
l'adossement en 2004 ce n'est que grâce
à ce mécanisme appuyez notamment sur une
taxe affectée que le régime est
équilibré financièrement
enfin vous avez
argumenter sur la pénibilité je crois
que nous avons eu le débat ce matin et
surtout nous l'aurons à l'article 9 je
l'espère nous renforçons dans ce texte
les mesures sur la pénibilité
et Monsieur Ruffin c'est vrai que vous
vous portez toutes les misères de notre
société
sur la fin de ce régime spécial je peux
pas trop trop vous suivre là-dessus il y
a des sujets d'attractivité à la RATP
personne dit le contraire mais ils
existent déjà alors qu'il y a le régime
spécial
très bien donc j'ai une demande
d'intervention et Manon de plusieurs
députés donc déjà monsieur de Courson
oui madame le rapporteur général vous
avez rappelé que dans la réforme de 2004
on a découpé le régime de retraite des
électriciens gaziers en 3 et pas en deux
en trois le régime de base régime
général complémentaire et le régime
chapeau
voilà et le régime chapeau lui est
financé par un impôt qui est une un
élément de la CSPE que vous payez chacun
d'entre nous paye dans sa facture
d'électricité alors ma question est la
suivante
quelle est la portée de ces deux alinéas
enfin trois alinéas 10 et 11 3 alinéas
en d'autres termes est-ce que ça veut
dire que le c'est le régime chapeau qui
disparaît le reste est maintenu la
doucement au régime général et à des
complémentaires donc c'est la
disparition du régime chapeau pour les
nouveaux
recrutés dans les IEG est-ce que c'est
bien ça la portée de ce que propose le
texte du Gouvernement est-ce que vous
pourriez nous éclairer sur cette
délicate question très bien monsieur
monsieur Vigier et ensuite monsieur
Jumet merci madame la Présidente
sur ce régime spécial il y a un sujet
qui n'a pas été évoqué c'est le fait que
à l'heure actuelle c'est 6 milliards
d'euros de pension qui sont versées par
an sur le dernier signe dont on dispose
de 2021
mes chers collègues il y a une
contribution qui a été mise en place en
2005 personne n'en parle c'est la CTA la
CTA c'est la contribution tarifaire
d'acheminement et cette contribution LPS
2 milliards d'euros à l'heure où je vous
parle elle est payée par qui et les pays
non
je ne donnerai tout à l'heure en tout
cas les temps contestable il est là et
elle est payée par qui par tout les
foyers qui utilisent cette électricité
donc en clair comme elle est payée par
tout le monde ce régime est équilibré
que parce qu'il y a cette fameuse
contribution d'acheminement qui a été
mise en place
et que les contributions je suis désolé
mais les contributions des salariés
c'est 68% des retraites qui sont
inversées il y a une deuxième chose et
donc la question pour la rapporteur
général est la suivante c'est salarié là
où vous saviez des avantages tarifaires
substantiels
[Musique]
sera supprimée une fois que le régime
n'existera plus reviendra au JM général
ou pas parce que sinon on continue notre
pénaliser naturellement l'ensemble des
usagers merci très bien la parole est à
Monsieur jumelle
bon François Ruffin raison vous n'aimez
pas l'école et vous avez inoculé le
virus de la rage à l'école vous n'avez
pas l'hôpital et vous avez inoculé les
règles comptables qui ont abîmé
l'hôpital et vous n'avez pas les agents
du service public et vous donc vous
apprêtez à grosse seringue alors inoculé
le virus de la rage vous oubliez une
chose je pense aux électriciens gaziers
contrairement à ce qu'a dit mon collègue
Vigier d'abord le système est
excédentaire la CTA amène 800 millions
d'euros de cumulés sur le dos d'ailleurs
des usagers et ponctionner par l'État
chaque année mais pour les électriciens
gaziers 6 paires de pairs vont être en
construction une fois le débat public
terminé nous avons besoin de robinetier
deux greniers soudeur d'agents de
conduite d'agents de maintenance nous
proposons d'ailleurs d'élargir au
nomades du nucléaire le statut des
électriciens gaziers et on est juger
pour les corrosion sous contrainte sur
nos centrales de faire appel à des
soudeurs qui viennent des États-Unis il
y a donc un problème de recrutement il y
a donc un problème d'attractivité et
vous choisissez ce moment pour inoculer
le virus de la rage sur le statut des
électriciens alors après si on vous
coupe le jus de 3 heures dans vos
permanences je ne veux pas vous entendre
pleurer si on vient toquer à vous porte
pour vous expliquer la mauvaise réforme
vous ne viendrez pas pleurer moi
j'invite l'ensemble des salariés qui
sont victimes de ça à venir discuter
avec les parlementaires à venir dans nos
permanence et à venir dans vos
permanence expliquer ce qui se passe ici
en commission et le faire dans une forme
de démocratie sociale active dynamique
interactive de le faire droit dans les
yeux et vous coupez les jus deux heures
par jour
de l'énergie
ne provoquez pas s'il vous plaît
c'est insupportable ce genre de vraiment
écouter je sais pas mais je vais
remettre l'église au milieu du village
si vous me le permettez avec une pointe
d'humour je dirais même je vais remettre
la mosquée au milieu du bled ou au
milieu du doigt mais franchement quand
on a ce genre d'intervention on est
provocateur et nous faire la leçon sur
vous n'aimez pas le service public non
vous faites les questions et vous faites
les réponses franchement c'est
insupportable très bien la parole est à
Madame Beretti et elle seule à la parole
est au milieu du village
allez-y madame merci madame la
Présidente chers collègues moi je crois
qu'il faut aussi faire confiance à
l'avenir on est enfin on n'est pas là
aujourd'hui pour parler des salaires
nous savons que il y a certainement des
choses je peux parler monsieur Ruffin je
vais d'ailleurs vous citer
on n'est pas là pour parler
spécifiquement des salaires ou de
l'attractivité d'un travail par rapport
à un autre on est là pour parler des
régimes sociaux et les régimes sociaux
aux époques qui ont été citées on était
là pour reconnaître une différence
reconnaître la pénibilité d'un emploi ou
d'un métier par rapport à un autre
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire que dans
ces secteurs là la pénibilité ou la
manière de travailler la manière de
faire les tâches et la même il y a des
choses qui se sont améliorées que vous
le que vous le reconnaissez ou pas
laissez-la parler plaît comme Monsieur
Ruffin j'ai déposé des amendements qui
ont été refusés sur les thèmes et
effectivement ce n'est pas forcément le
bon véhicule législatif mais encore une
fois nous on propose un traitement
individuel individuel avec cette visite
et il me semble qu'il est important de
la rappeler à 45 ans cette visite à 61
ans avec cette perspective que quatre
Français sur dix partiront de toute
manière à 62 ans avec ce système je vais
vous citer l'exemple de ma mère qui a
été couturière toute sa carrière et qui
a dû terminer sa carrière en étant fan
de ménage elle serait sortie
effectivement à 61 ans plutôt qu'à 64
ans ce qu'elle a dû faire pour avoir sa
retraite à temps plein et concernant
spécifiquement le régime des gaziers il
y a 1,6 milliards d'euros qui est qui
sont affectés par l'État chaque année
pour
le régime là dont vous ne pouvez pas
dire qu'il est excédentaire il y a quand
même une contribution de l'État
très bien la parole est à Madame panot
madame panot merci madame la Présidente
déjà pour répondre à la collection on
parle des salaires parce que c'est même
ceux-là qui finance le système de
retraite donc on est en train de parler
justement du fait qu'on augmente pas les
salaires et donc les cotisations
première des choses deuxième chose sur
les électriciens et les gaz madame
panneau à la parole sur les électriciens
et les gaziers je voudrais apporter tout
mon soutien à aux électriciens au gazier
qui justement pour combattre votre
réforme des retraites sont en train de
rétablir le courant chez les personnes à
qui on l'a coupé c'est 300000 personnes
dans notre pays et bascule en heures
creuse les boulangers notamment à
Marseille qui sont aujourd'hui étranglés
par le prix de l'énergie la troisième
chose mes collègues ont très bien
expliqué ce que ça crée le fait de
supprimer le régime de retraite spéciale
pour pionnier pour les IEG ils ont très
bien expliqué ce que ça faisait sur le
service public mais on sait déjà ce que
ça crée sur la suite et notamment il y a
des gens aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas ce
statut dioge et qui c'est les
travailleurs sous-traitants du nucléaire
80% de la maintenance nucléaire est
faite par des travailleurs
sous-traitants qui reçoivent 80% de la
deuxième radioactive je rappelle que les
rayonnements ionisants ne font pas
partie des critères de pénibilité et
vous avez par exemple Patrice Girardier
qui est en 2016 dit nous sous-traitants
nucléaires nous sommes de la chair à
canon il a développé un cancer de la
thyroïde qui n'a pas été reconnu comme
maladie professionnelle et pire il a été
licencié parce que Orano a expliqué
qu'il ne pouvait pas le recaser donc on
sait ce que ça crée d'avoir des gens qui
ne sont pas sous statut d'IOG donc avec
des régimes spéciaux ça crée des gens
qui vont devoir travailler très
longtemps et ça pose des questions de
sûreté et de sécurité nucléaire qui sont
évidents comme le disait les
sous-traitants nucléaires de
Romans-sur-Isère on assemble le
combustible nucléaire il me disait nous
on ne fait pas de la raviole et donc
quand il y a des problèmes de conditions
de travail et puis avec des gens qui
vont devoir travailler très longtemps
dans de mauvaises conditions et avec des
mauvaises payes il y en a un qui me
disaient moi j'ai 39 ans de nucléaires
je suis payé 1300 euros alors avec
quelques prix mais 1300 euros donc c'est
ça qu'on est en train de faire en
supprimant ce régime pionnier et c'est à
dire qu'on est en train de s'opposer il
faut élargir de la parole oui petite
tentative de fact checking de
l'intervention de ma collègue béreté on
n'est pas là pour parler du salaire
c'est ce que vous avez dit et ben
figurez-vous que si vous faites une
réforme des retraites aujourd'hui c'est
parce que vous avez prévu de geler des
salaires des fonctionnaires demain qui
ne cotiseront plus et qui ne pourront
plus financer le système de retraite ça
c'est la motivation et l'un des facteurs
de votre réforme des retraites donc oui
si vous gelez les salaires derrière vous
gelez les cotisations et vous mettez en
péril le système de retrait donc oui il
faut parler salaire pour financer les
retraites premier point madame berettet
deuxièmement vous dites il faut pas
aller quand même faire un régime spécial
pour les travailleurs des industries
électriques et gazières parce que
dites-vous dans ces secteurs là en gros
la manière de travailler à changer
alors madame Beretti
quand vous serez allé de nuit grimper
dans la tempête sur des poteaux vous
m'expliquerez en quoi ça a changé par
rapport à aujourd'hui où il y a 10 ans
ben non je suis désolé quand vous serez
quand vous serez grimpé à ces poteaux
quand vous serez aller dans les réseaux
d'électricité en montagne quand vous
aurez été dans des conduites réparées
des fuites ça vous pourrez expliquer que
ça a changé par rapport à il y a 20 ans
je suis désolé madame je suis désolé
madame Beretti la pénibilité du travail
dans ses métiers elle est réelle et vous
ne pouvez pas dire que circuler il y a
rien à voir parce que bien au contraire
il faudrait aller voir réellement sur le
terrain ou dans les industries
nucléaires parce que ces travailleurs
ils sont sous pression littéralement ils
sont sous pression ils ont besoin de
nous
très bien monsieur ménager merci Madame
présidente alors c'est vraiment dommage
je me suis jumelle parce que tout ce qui
est excessif est insignifiant et c'est
dommage parce que j'étais d'accord avec
vous mais en prêchant pour pour que les
pour que les électriciens en fait coupe
l'électricité vous appelez en fait en
tant que législateur à bafouer la loi
c'est quand même incroyable d'être un
législateur et de demander à ce qu'on ne
respecte pas la loi et c'est vraiment
triste et vous donner une mauvaise image
et je pense que vous électeurs seront
vous le dire mais je tiens juste à vous
rappeler que je suis d'accord avec vous
et je suis d'accord et je tiens à dire à
la majorité qui souhaite à la majorité
qui souhaite relancer nucléaire qu'à un
moment on peut pas être en difficulté et
de voir appeler à la rescousse des
soudeurs canadiens américains pour
sauver notre nucléaire parce que vous
avez souvent été tenu aussi par les
écolos pendant le précédent quinquennat
aujourd'hui vouloir relancer le
nucléaire et nous nous y sommes
favorables et à la fois refuser à ce qui
est quelque chose qui attire ces
soudeurs parce qu'ils viendront pas ils
ne viendront pas seulement pour faire
plaisir pour faire plaisir à Emmanuel
Macron il viendront parce qu'ils auront
un intérêt un système qui les protège
donc aujourd'hui ça vous dérange
peut-être madame panot qu'on parle de
nucléaire parce que voilà je sais que
vous n'êtes pas favorable mais laissez
quand même nous exprimer je sais que
vous êtes dans l'obstruction et vous
essayez de couper la parole à vos
opposants mais mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous nous rassemblements
national très clairement même si on
soutient ce régime spécial on appelle
pas à faire du chantage à faire de la
pression sur les élus parce qu'on donne
une image déplorable on est une image
déplorable notamment aux jeunes
notamment à nos électeurs qui nous ont
fait confiance donc monsieur jumelles je
vous invite à retirer vos propos je vous
invite à confirmer à confirmer votre
soutien à ce régime spécial parce qu'il
en intérêt mais à revenir en arrière
parce que vous ne pouvez pas soutenir ce
chantage cette pression parce que c'est
totalement antidémocratique
la parole à présent est à Madame
Chatelain
merci Madame la président
je crois que tout d'abord je soutiens à
la fois les propos de ma collègue pano
et de Monsieur jumelles je pense à la
fois que les salariés du nucléaire était
un très bon exemple un exemple de ce qui
finalement nous oppose vous nous parlez
de mesure individuelles vous nous parlez
de musique médicale c'est important mais
nous vous parlons de protection
collective parce qu'effectivement on
connaît la dureté de ces métiers on sait
que les causes et les conditions dans
lesquelles les gens sont soumis vont les
amener à développer soit pendant leur
carrière soit après leur carrière des
problèmes de santé et c'est ça en fait
dont on est en train de parler c'est de
l'avenir de ces personnes et de leur
capacité à de profiter de la retraite et
notre désaccord sur l'ensemble de ces
régimes spéciaux mais plus globalement
sur cette réforme c'est qu'on n'a pas
besoin d'un médecin qui voit une
personne à 55 ans pour savoir quand elle
a porté des charges mais même 45 ans
c'est qu'on a pas besoin d'aide pour
savoir que qu'on a porté des charges
lourdes toute sa vie et ben en fait on
aura des problèmes de dos en retraite on
n'a pas besoin de nous savoir que quand
on était soumis à des petit toxique on
va avoir des problèmes de santé quand on
sera à la retraite et donc pour ça nous
devons avoir des protections collectives
c'est pour ça que nous défendons les
régimes spéciaux et c'est pour ça que
nous défendons le système un système des
retraites juste et je voudrais souligner
que ce n'est pas la première réforme
même si j'ai l'impression que vos
prédécesseurs n'avaient pas eu besoin
d'avoir de stratagèmes du type PLFSS
rectificatif pour les passer mais suite
à ces assez réformes le l'âge de départ
à la retraite a déjà augmenté depuis
2010 c'est plus de plus de 1 an et neuf
mois d'âge de départ à la retraite qui
ont été faits et là il faut savoir que
les personnes la manière dont c'est
augmentation des gelée par la retraite
c'est plus d'un quart de la hausse
s'explique par la diminution des départs
à la retraite avant 60 ans dire que
c'est principalement les gens qui ont
commencé à travailler très tôt qui ont
travaillé plus longtemps et c'est
exactement cette logique là que vous
voulez mettre en place avec cette avec
cette réforme que ça soit par
l'augmentation de l'âge de départ ou que
ça soit par la fin des régimes spéciaux
c'est pour ça que nous soutenons les
amendements pour préserver l'ensemble de
ces régimes
très bien monsieur Bazin est ensuite on
passe au vote oui merci madame la
Présidente
moi je voudrais aller sur des questions
techniques liées à cette suppression
du régime spécial des retraites or la
kniegère non seulement le risque
vieillesse mais aussi accident du
travail maladie professionnelle
invalidité et décès on voit bien je le
dis devant l'ancien rapporteur de la
branche ATMP qu'on voit bien que on a un
certain nombre d'éléments sur la
pénibilité sur la prévention comment on
tient les choses là aussi il y a la
question sur le système d'information
puisque on va devoir continuer à ouvrir
des droits sur les autres branches pour
le coup
puisqu'il y aura pas le la vieillesse
sera donc séparé vous avez une autre
caisse qui s'appelle la camieg qui
s'occupe de l'Assurance Maladie
d'ailleurs la loi de financement pour la
sécurité sociale pour 2014 avait impacté
il y avait eu un transfert des excédents
avec une des modifications à la fois
entre les prestations et les montants
concrètement comment ça va s'articuler
est-ce que le système d'information de
la CNAV va continuer à ouvrir des droits
sur l'assurance maladie de la camieg
comment les deux puisque on va continuer
à avoir les deux les deux caisses qui
continuent sauf le risque vieille est-ce
que les deux vont tenir
ensemble et sur l'articulation qui est
qui est imaginé moi j'avais une question
sur les nouveaux entrants est-ce que ça
concerne aussi ceux qui sont en
apprentissage
en cours d'année
et bien Madame la rapporteur pour
répondre tout de suite à Monsieur Bazin
oui les le système reste le même pour
les autres
parties et les autres branches de cette
caisse ce qu'elle fait déjà la CNAV les
relations avec la Cnaps font avec le
régime général se fait déjà donc ça ne
change pas pour monsieur de Courson oui
je l'avais dit mais je me suis peut-être
mal exprimée le stock reste en droit
commun et en droit spécifique et les
nouveaux les nouveaux entrants eux sont
au régime au régime général pour
Monsieur Viger Vigier le le CTA c'est un
progressivement à mesure que c'est un
Dron les droits ouverts avant 2020 avant
Madame panot et Monsieur Delaporte vous
dites on n'est pas on est là pour parler
des salaires mais bien volontiers on a
parlé ce matin sur le sujet des
fonctionnaires sur sur la partie des
salariés c'est important effectivement
puisque on a tout à fait tout intérêt à
en parler dans une réforme de retraite
surtout on a intérêt à ce que les
salaires augmentent puisque la masse
salariale représente 75% des ressources
du système de retraite et vous voulez en
parler donc on va en parler si on
regarde ces dernières années cette masse
salariale elle a augmenté de 3,5% en
2018 il y avait une inflation à 1,6%.
elle a augmenté de 8,6 pour cent en 2022
alors qu'il y avait une inflation à 5,4%
donc oui on peut en parler enfin Madame
châtelain on ne pense pas que individuel
dans le
ce qui est proposé dans ce texte dans le
cadre de la pénibilité mais bien
individuel avec ses visites de suivi et
il est très important puisque notamment
tous ces troubles musculoos que
l'éthique sont
vont être intéressants à suivre et à
faire de la prévention à titre
individuel mais aussi collective
notamment par le rôle des branches dans
le fond d'investissement de prévention
et de l'usure qui est de 1 milliard je
le rappelle sur le quinquennat
très bien Madame la rapporteur général
donc je vais mettre aux voix ces tous
ces amendements identiques qui ont reçu
un avis défavorable de Madame la
rapporteur qui est pour
qui contre
ils sont rejetés
amendement pouvant être mis en
discussion commune monsieur Guedj
oui madame la Présidente toujours dans
un souci de pouvoir avancer parce que
nous voulons avancer dans le texte donc
je vous propose de faire une discussion
commune sur l'amendement 829 jusqu'au
817 là on en fait une petite dizaine
voilà d'un seul coup c'est la même
philosophie que celle que avait présidée
sur la RATP
vous ne voulez pas vous venez à
l'instant maintenir ce régime nous vous
proposons
de différer la mort annoncée que vous
lui proposez tout simplement pour
confirmer l'attachement que nous avons à
ce régime à ce régime spécial pour les
raisons que j'évoquais tout à l'heure et
ça me permet c'est dommage le collègue
Philippe Vigier est parti parce que on
peut pas laisser entendre des choses la
contribution tarifaire d'acheminement
dont il a parlé tout à l'heure ce n'est
pas une subvention
elle ne vient pas en plus des
financements par les entreprises mais
elle remplace une partie de ce
financement celle-ci qui ont moins de
charges leur tarifs ont baissé d'autant
lors de la mise en place de la CTA les
usagers ont donc payé la même chose mais
avec une part tarif plus faible et une
part taxe plus forte donc
ne pas laisser entendre que quand je
disais que ce régime était à l'équilibre
sans subvention il y aurait une
subvention détournée qui était la
contribution tarifaire d'acheminement
voilà ce que je voulais préciser et en
insistant vraiment sur le la pertinence
de cette de ce régime de ce régime
spécial dont il faut rappeler qu'il a
connu et qu'il n'a pas échappé déjà un
certain nombre de réformes celle des
régimes spéciaux en 2008 la réforme
verte en 2010 ou la réforme Touraine en
2014 loin impactée et que donc il y a
déjà eu un mouvement de convergence pour
lequel nous vous proposons de ne pas
aller plus loin
très bien donc Madame la rapporteur
alors j'apprécie votre décision monsieur
le député très bien Madame la rapporteur
pour la RATP avec cette incertitude dans
la date de détermination de la fermeture
donc ça sera un avis défavorable très
bien monsieur Delaporte oui je vais
défendre donc les amendements 816 815
814 813 812 811 8110 809 806 805 pour
montrer notre volonté de faire avancer
au 817 donc voilà on fait des paquets
des amendements parce que voilà on est
on veut faire avancer les débats mais je
peux pas vous laisser dire Madame la
rapporteur comme vous l'avez dit que le
problème
des salaires c'est compenser par une
évolution de la masse salariale
ce que vous avez dit vous avez dit on a
une hausse de la base salariale de 8,3%
mais ça c'est lié finalement à
l'évolution de la démographie et
notamment de la démographie de l'emploi
donc c'est pas parce qu'on a une
inflation à 3% et une hausse de la masse
salariale à 8 % que on a augmenté les
salaires je peux pas vous laisser dire
ça parce que les salaires aujourd'hui la
réalité c'est qu'il ne suivent pas
l'inflation c'est que le niveau le
niveau des salaires et l'évolution des
cotisations à l'échelle de l'individu
qui sont versés elle ne permet pas de
financer décemment le système de
retraite et que quand on a gelé le point
d'indice on a en effet je l'ai et quand
on a gelé les différents salaires on a
réduit le financement du système de
retraite et vous avez par ailleurs
menacé l'équilibre puisque vous avez
réduit les cotisations patronales donc
voilà c'était juste pour répondre sur ce
point précis parce que je pense qu'il
faut aussi qu'on soit rigoureux
collectivement dans notre expression
comme nous sommes rigoureux nous dans
notre défense d'amendement pour
préserver des droits des salariés
très bien Madame la rapporteur vous avez
raison monsieur de la porte vous êtes
précis donc la Commission des contes de
la sécurité sociale de j'ai tiré ces
chiffres montrent que les salaires
tirent la masse salariale vers le haut
avec une augmentation de 1,9 en ce qui
concerne les salaires de plus 1,9 en
2018 et de plus 5,3 % en 2022
très bien la parole est à Monsieur
Coulomme
oui madame la Présidente chers collègue
avant d'aller plus loin moi j'aimerais
faire un petit peu revenir un petit peu
sur un peu d'histoire sur EDF GDF quand
même en 1946 après à la fin de la guerre
alors que l'ensemble des industries
électriques et gazières avaient
largement collaboré avec le régime
vichiste Marcel Paul la nationalisé
après les avoir regroupés toutes les
tous les producteurs d'électricité et de
gaz donc ils ont ensuite participé à la
construction tous ces salariés de
l'infrastructure des transports de
l'énergie et cette profession a payé un
lourd tribu en vie humaine à cause des
accidents du travail lorsqu'il a fallu
construire ses lourdes infrastructures
alors on s'étonne quand même de votre
contre-réforme qui abolit l'héritage du
monde du travail là où finalement vous
êtes plus que complaisant à sacraliser
l'héritage des rentiers nous aimerions
tant que vous dénonciez le manque de
pénibilité des héritiers de la finance
enrichi par leur monopole et par la
spéculation de crise ne vous en prenez
pas aux conquêtes sociales mais
rétablissez un peu de justice sociale en
mettant à cont la Bourse aux fleurs
financière de notre pays cessez votre
fanatisme à déshériter les travailleurs
et les classes populaires et nous
invitons tous les électriciens les
gaziers à défendre leur rythme véritable
qui est légitime celui-là et nous à la
nuque on sera à leur côté pour défendre
cet héritage social de ce secteur à qui
nous devons tant
très bien monsieur turquois vous avez la
parole
oui madame la Présidente
moi je voudrais avant de m'exprimer sur
cet amendement m'exprimer sur la prise
de parole de notre collègue jumelle tout
à l'heure moi je le vois comme une forme
de menace à l'égard de nos permanences à
l'égard de nos collaborateurs et je
trouve qu'on essaie
je trouve qu'on essaie de s'engager
chacun avec nos convictions jusque là
jusque là j'entends qu'elle soit très
différente mais la menace physique
quelle qu'elle soit est totalement
condamnable et je tenais à le dire
très bien ce sont des méthodes qui ne
sont pas des méthodes acceptables
donc je voudrais quand même exprimer sur
l'amendement je croyais que vous avez
fini sur l'amendement sur les i.e.g on
parle on parle d'excédent des Ig en fait
quand on regarde les les régimes qui
sont excédentaires ce sont les régimes
qui sont plutôt en croissance
démographique par rapport au régime qui
sont en décroissance où il y a plus il y
a plus de retraités que d'actifs et donc
a été comparé la question par rapport à
l'agriculture ben oui l'agriculture
était nombreuse dans les années 60 elle
l'est beaucoup moins aujourd'hui donc il
y a beaucoup plus de retraités à
financer que d'actifs qui cotisent les
IEG c'est exactement le contraire et
donc il faut aussi mesurer ça quel est
l'intérêt de d'avoir un seul régime de
retraite pour les salariés c'est que les
démographies des métiers comme je l'ai
déjà dit tout à l'heure évolue et
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas garantir ce
que seront les métiers de demain d'où
l'intérêt d'avoir un seul et unique
régime de retraite
très bien la parole est à Monsieur
jumelles
je vous en prie présidente merci cher
député monsieur Bazin vous avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente en
lisant les différentes dates proposées
dans les amendements je me dis que
finalement le régime spécial va être
fermé nous entrons mais en fait il va
être fermé enfin il va perdurer ce
régime bien au-delà du 1er janvier 2050
on avait fait même la présidente une un
travail ici vous m'aviez confié avec une
autre collègue de votre groupe une
mission sur le régime de sécurité
sociale des mines et on avait qui était
en qui est en extinction depuis 2011 et
en fait on avait constaté qu'il y aurait
des ayants droits jusqu'en 2100 et que
et ça pose la question madame le
rapporteur de la transition la
transition va être longue de la
fermeture de ces régimes il faut qu'on
puisse l'assurer il ne s'occupe pas que
du risque vieillesse on le voit bien
d'ailleurs parce que il y a tous les
sujets je sais que vous y êtes attentif
sur la maladie professionnelle et avec
des spécificités accident du travail
maladie professionnelle parfois des
maladies professionnels qui ont besoin
des expertises longues d'accueil de
suivi d'expertise or sur les régimes qui
ont été fermés par le passé on a un
problème de perte de la connaissance des
spécificités de ces régimes et des
emplois liés et on a une perte de
guichets unique puisque quand on appelle
on a un problème de suivi qualitatif des
personnes et je pense qu'il serait
nécessaire qui a un engagement alors
peut-être au bas mais de manière à ce
que sur cette période de transition vous
puissiez tirer des leçons des erreurs du
passé notamment en termes de gestion des
transitions de manière à ce que on
puisse garantir un suivi qualitatif
notamment sur cet enjeu de la prévention
et des maladies professionnelles sur le
risque lié qui n'est pas le risque
vieillesse mais le risque lié par
rapport à ces spécificités
très bien monsieur jumelles oui j'ai
senti que mon propos tout à l'heure
avait perturbé la commission je veux
donc préciser ma pensée il y a des
choses qui m'empêchent de dormir et
d'autres un peu moins
lorsqu'on coupe le courant chez des gens
qui n'ont plus les moyens de faire face
aux dépenses d'énergie ça m'empêche de
dormir lorsque les boulangers de chez
moi sont confrontés et n'explosion du
coup de l'énergie et au marchand de
soleil qui se font du beurre sur leur
dos ça m'empêche de dormir lorsqu'il y a
des industries chez moi sont fragilisés
y compris dans leur souveraineté
industrielle parce que vous êtes
incapable de prendre soin de l'économie
réelle en régulant les tarifs de
l'énergie ça m'empêche de dormir je vous
confirme que je vous confirme que je
suis moins empêché de dormir à l'idée de
savoir que ceux qui ont des manteaux de
fourrure pourraient priver de deux ou
trois heures de deux ou trois heures de
cours dans la journée enfin il y a une
réalité objective si la grève la baisse
de la la grève il y a baisse de la
production et si abaisse de la
production il faudra choisir entre
chauffer l'hôpital chauffer les EHPAD ou
chauffer le permanence ou les éclairer
même et bien je préfère qu'on chauffe
les EHPAD qu'on les éclaire et qu'on
redonne de la lumière aux hôpitaux
plutôt que que les permanents je vous
confirme que j'assume pleinement les
propos qui sont les miens pleinement
très bien Madame La Valette vous avez la
parole
mes chers collègues s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît seul madame est à la parole
mais mes chers collègues quand même vous
vous manquez pas d'air et c'est pas mal
parce que c'est c'est débats pointe du
doigt vos incohérences et Monsieur
jumelles au premier chef par contre ça
vous
vous avez un truc à dire Madame panot
peut-être
ça vous a pas empêché de dormir quand
vous n'avez pas voté notre loi dans la
niche sur l'augmentation de 10% des
salaires ça vous a pas ça vous a pas ça
vous a pas empêché de dormir ça ne vous
a pas empêché de dormir de pas voter nos
deux amendements sur la taxation des
super profits merci et ça vous a pas
empêché de faire élire leur Miller c'est
fou ça quand même qui va voter des deux
mains cette réforme contre laquelle vous
faites semblant contre laquelle vous
faites semblant de vous
alors un peu de cohérence s'il vous
plaît
la part s'il vous plaît madame panot je
vous entends jusqu'ici madame panot
s'il vous plaît
alors la parole est à Madame Parmentier
le coq s'il vous plaît oui merci Madame
la présence je pense que c'est vraiment
inadmissible et vraiment scandaleux les
propos qui sont tenus par notre collègue
jumelles qui continuent la provocation
on s'offusque j'ai entendu Sophus quai
la nupes les propos du mini Gérald
Darmanin mais on a vraiment la
démonstration de ce qui essaie de faire
la nups de chauffer à blanc l'opinion
publique de de
de valoriser d'appeler à couper
l'électricité en permanence a été hyper
ma collègue à la raison c'est nos
salariés c'est nos ce sont nos
collaborateurs qui travaillent dans nos
permanences est-ce que c'est ça que vous
voulez est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut
admettre ça est-ce qu'il faut
transformer l'Assemblée nationale en Z
comme le propose la news
très bien
mes chers collègues on ouvre à nouveau
les chakras on va passer au vote
allez je mets je mets aux voix tous ces
amendements
identiques
s'il vous plaît qui ont été non ils sont
pas identiques pardon ah non je peux que
je les mette un par un voilà qui ont en
tous les cas reçus un avis défavorable
pour tous les amendements je mets aux
voiles 829 qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
828 même à vie même vote même à 827 même
avis même vote 826 même à vie même vote
825 même avis même vote
824 même avis même vote 823 même à vie
même vote 822 même avis même vote
821 même avis même vote oui
819 même à vie même vote
818 même a vu même vote
817 même avis même vote 816 même avis
même vote 815 même avis même vote
814 même avis même vote 813 même avis
même vote 812 même avis même vote 811
même avis même vote 810 même à vie même
vote 89 même à vie même vote 806 même
avis même vote 805 même avis même vote
et ben je vous remercie mes chers
collègues et nous passons tout de suite
au
3793 et je donne la parole à Monsieur
Monet ou à Monsieur dareville non madame
le bon très bien maintenant que les
chakras sont bien ouverts alors
nous sommes opposés à la suppression des
régimes spéciaux et la première ministre
a dit que c'était cette suppression
c'était une question d'équité et bien
précisément non parce que vous confondez
équité égalité pour rappel l'égalité
c'est je donne la même chose à tout le
monde l'équité en revanche c'est donner
à chacun en fonction des spécificités
c'est un principe de justice
distributive alors que l'égalité est un
principe de justice commutat de nos
diaristes certains métiers sont plus
pénibles que d'autres certains métiers
ont des spécificités qui justifient ces
régimes spéciaux les régimes spéciaux en
réalité ils étaient précurseurs d'une
juste appréhension du travail et de ses
effets sur les travailleurs ce que vous
présentez comme une avancée mais c'est
un recul des droits sociaux ce que les
régimes spéciaux ou en plus
effectivement c'est une véritable
compensation de la pénibilité qui se
traduit de la seule manière possible un
départ véritablement anticipé comparé
avec le régime général dont les droits
collectifs à la reconnaissance et la
compensation de la pénibilité ont été
réduits jusqu'à l'insignifiance c'est
pas sérieux
ces régimes spéciaux doivent nous
inspirer en réalité leur histoire est
celle de conquête sociale liées
d'ailleurs aux besoins de développement
du pays à la nécessité de fidéliser de
qualifier ses salariés et on ne dit pas
autre chose aujourd'hui quand on parle
de redonner du sens au travail de
rémunérer correctement les emplois de
reconnaître les qualifications alors non
à la suppression des régimes spéciaux
cette suppression représente un
nivellement par le bas des droits de
tous à la retraite
madame la rapporteur général votre avis
en fait vous supprimez dans cet
amendement une disposition
rédactionnelle du code en fait sur un
article qui n'existe plus donc c'est un
avis défavorable très bien monsieur
Ruffin vous souhaitiez intervenir
madame la rapporteur tout à l'heure vous
disiez que je vous parlais des misères
de notre société mais en fait ce dont je
parlais ce sont celles et ceux qui ont
été une île pays de boue pendant la
crise covid et ce sont celles et ceux
qui continuent de tenir le pays debout
et qu'est-ce qu'on attendait après par
écrites on attendait une loi de
valorisation du travail de
reconnaissance du travail de
rémunération du travail et oui où on
parle salaire mais pas seulement et à la
place qu'est-ce qu'on a on a pour
celle là pour tout cela on a une loi de
punition une loi de punition avec des
trimestres des années qui va falloir
porter en plus pour aller jusqu'au bout
alors que bien souvent on termine en
inaptitude avant d'arriver au bout et
qu'est-ce que vous instillez dans la
société en faisant ça vous installez
deux choses vous instituez du dégoût du
dégoût du travail du dégoût du travail
quand il faut le porter de cette manière
là et qu'il est pas reconnu et qu'il est
pas rémunéré et d'où les difficultés à
recruter dans plein de secteurs et vous
instincter du dégoût de la démocratie
parce que si quand cette Français sur
dix vous disent non si quand huit
salariés sur 10 vous disent non si quand
des millions de Français des instants de
la rue dans la rue vous vous disent non
si quand tous les syndicats Unis
viennent vous dire non et que vous
faites comme si tout ça n'existait pas
vous continuez sur votre petit bonhomme
de chemin à faire les sourds et bien
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est introduit
la tension dans la société et le
problème il va se déliter en
ressentiment et en tension
supplémentaire dans la société vous en
serez la cause vous en serez vous en
êtes la cause par votre surdité quand
quand le quand le président de la
République prend l'unité de la station à
6 rue prises dans ses vœux c'est lui
c'est vous qui venez briser l'unité de
la nation en menant mettant en place une
loi de cette nature à ce moment si notre
histoire on aurait besoin donc au
contraire une grande loi de
réconciliation avec le travail
depuis ce matin je suis un petit peu
gêné par cette petite musique il y
aurait dans la salle les les députés du
peuple et les députés du grand capital
nous sommes tous les députés du peuple
et j'aimerais que les débats portent sur
le fond parce que je peux vous dire
qu'hier soir encore j'ai fait une
rencontre citoyenne y compris où il y
avait des militants nupaisses de membres
issus des gilets jaunes et les débats
étaient beaucoup plus précis et beaucoup
plus sur le fond alors revenons-y s'il
vous plaît pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait
une réforme des régimes spéciaux c'est
un sujet d'équité on est tous et tout
attachés ici à ce que la solidarité les
retraites financent les retraites et que
la solidarité nationale finance la
solidarité nationale or aujourd'hui ce
qui se passe c'est que 11 milliards
d'euros des impôts des Français vont à
la consommation à la compensation pardon
des régimes spéciaux en plus des 30
milliards d'euros de compensation des
régimes publics donc ça c'est un sujet
quand même pour nos finances publiques
et en termes d'équité avec la colosse du
grand-père je rappelle qu'il y a
personne n'est pris en traître et que le
contrat des salariés embauchés et bel et
bien respecté merci
merci
simplement pour revenir très rapidement
sur les régimes spiraux dans ce cas moi
je propose qu'on crée évidemment un
régime spécial pour les commerçants et
les artisans dont la nuit pèse ne parle
absolument jamais des gens qui
travaillent dur qui ont commencé tôt qui
travaillent 7 jours sur 7 qui ont cotisé
pour tout le monde et notamment pour les
fonctionnaires il n'y a plus de raison
de maintenir les régimes spéciaux parce
que c'est évidemment aujourd'hui une
question d'équité et les Français ne
supportent plus l'inéquité qu'il y a sur
les mêmes types d'activités de
pénibilité à avoir des régimes
différents ou alors il faut créer des
régimes spéciaux pour chacun des métiers
et puis je reviens sur ce que disait
monsieur Rufin sur l'unité de la nation
je suis d'accord avec lui la
réconciliation du travail et moi je
voudrais dénoncer la lourde
responsabilité que la gauche porte dans
la dévalorisation et dans le dévoiement
du rapport des Français au travail avec
les 35 heures avec les 35 heures vous
vous avez abîmé le rapport des Français
au travail le fait qu'on voit le travail
comme une source d'épanouissement et
d'avoir fait du travail ce que le
travail a fait de notre pays
c'est-à-dire un grand pays et quand je
vous entends très honnêtement je suis
très très inquiète puisque vous
continuez sur cette tendance on écoute
terrible qui affaiblit notre pays parce
que elle fait croire aux Français qu'ils
peuvent avoir le même type de droit le
même type de solidarité sans travailler
très bien et s'il vous plaît
la parole est à Monsieur Delaporte oui
séance de fac checking numéro 2 madame
Bonnivard je pense que vous avez réussi
à accumuler en l'espace de deux minutes
un certain nombre de poncifs qui
contribuent à détourner finalement et
votre collègue disait qu'on ne parlait
pas du fond moi je pense que il y a pas
d'un côté en effet les députés du peuple
et de l'autre ceux du grand capital mais
c'est ce que c'est ce que vous disiez je
pense qu'il faut sortir
il faut sortir des accusations
caricaturales mais nous sommes en
revanche pour ceux qui s'opposent à
cette réforme les défenseurs des
travailleurs bah oui vous dites faut
protéger le travail vous dites il faut
croire à la valeur du travail ben nous
on défend les travailleurs parce que on
veut qu'ils puissent qu'ils puissent
travailler en bonne santé on veut qu'ils
puissent travailler longtemps mais on
veut surtout qu'ils puissent profiter
des fruits de leur travail et donc quand
vous êtes sur cette espèce de discours
caricatural en disant que les 35 heures
ont conduit à détruire les valeurs du
travail mais en fait ils ont juste
conduit à faire du travail avec un
vecteur d'émancipation et un vecteur
aussi d'être libre de profiter du temps
libre tout simplement c'est ça notre
philosophie quand on gagne de l'argent
quand on a un nombre d'heures qu'on
respecte le temps de travail derrière on
a aussi du temps de repos du temps de
loisirs et que la loi la retraite c'est
un droit ouvert aussi par son travail le
travail donne de la valeur et donne
notamment de la valeur à la retraite et
je suis désolé mais je ne comprends pas
toute philosophie qui serait autre qui
dirait que le travail est un absolu dans
la vie parce que c'est ce raisonnement
là qui conduit au pire horreurs qui
conduit à l'exploitation et qui conduit
finalement au discours que vous tenez
aujourd'hui très bien s'il vous plaît je
passe la parole à Madame taillée
polluant s'il vous plaît
merci madame la Présidente le travail
c'est vrai il peut être émancipateur
mais pour cela il y a besoin de
plusieurs choses il y a bord il y a
besoin du respect pour les salariés et
notamment en respectant des conditions
de travail et notamment en respectant la
santé et en mettant en place des
politiques de prévention vous avez nuit
à la santé des travailleurs en
supprimant les CHSCT le travail il peut
être émancipateur quand il a un sens
quand on sait pourquoi on se lève le
matin pourquoi faire en mettant à mal
les services publics vous avez abîmé le
sens du travail pour nombre de
fonctionnaires en leur disant vous
pouvez faire mieux avec moins de
personnes
vous avez donc abîmé le travail
le travail il peut être émancipateur
quand on a les moyens de faire les
choses bien vous savez c'est la belle
ouvrage et aujourd'hui et on l'observe à
travers le monde
l'intensification du travail
l'absence totale ou de plus en plus
importante du quelconque autonomie des
salariés on réduit cette capacité
d'émancipation alors je vous le dis dans
ce moment où le travail
n'est de moins en moins émancipateur
vous mettez de plus en plus les salariés
en situation très difficile au regard de
leur santé et c'est pourquoi cette
volonté que vous avez de prolonger la
durée du travail est totalement
totalement en opposition avec ce que
nous portons nous portons le partage du
temps de travail pour un travail qui
soit émancipateur mais qui permettent
aussi à toutes celles et ceux qui vivent
dans notre pays d'avoir une vie
familiale d'avoir une vie personnelle
d'avoir aussi le temps de se cultiver le
temps de se divertir
le temps de partager avec d'autres le
temps de militer le temps de manifester
très bien alors pour répondre
mais je rappelle la règle c'est une
prise de parole par groupe et donc je ne
pourrai pas donner la parole à Monsieur
Corbière dans la mesure où Monsieur
Ruffin s'est exprimé pour votre groupe
voilà ça vous convient parfait donc nous
allons passer je vais mettre au voie cet
amendement 3793 car je suis un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur
général qui est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté amendement suivant
monsieur dare
oui madame la Présidente je dis ça après
avoir un peu enfin réveiller le débat
tout à l'heure
électriser j'allais dire le débat tout à
l'heure je pense vraiment que les crises
successives que nous traversons aurait
milité pour une république apaisée
réconcilier avec elle-même pour se
donner le temps de réarmer l'hôpital
pour se donner le temps
de réparer l'ascenseur social de l'école
de la République pour se donner le temps
de réaffirmer la présence de la
République partout et pour tous au lieu
de cela le président qui a l'itinéraire
d'un enfant gâté a choisi de cliver le
pays de bousculer le pays de violenter
le pays alors face à cela alors
j'entends on est tous députés oui on est
tous députés de nous représente pas les
mêmes
on ne représente pas les mêmes ne croyez
pas que on va laisser les Français sans
prendre plein la tronche et ronronner
comme des chats sur des grands fauteuils
rouges non nous allons faire rentrer la
colère ici en commission nous allons
faire rentrer la colère dans l'hémicycle
et nous espérons bien que la colère en
dans la rue dans les usines dans les
services publics pour bousculer cette
mauvaise réforme on a envie de vous
bousculer jusqu'au point de retirer
cette réforme donc faites-vous à cette
idée là vous avez choisi de ne pas
apaiser les choses vous avez choisi de
ne pas réconcilier la République avec
elle-même admettez qui est des actes de
résistance alors j'entends que la
résistance ça n'emballe pas tout le
monde mais nous assumons le fait d'être
en résistance face à des projets comme
cela parce que la résistance c'est notre
ADN
bien vous avez défendu votre amendement
monsieur d'arriville donc je passe la
parole à Madame la rapporteur oui madame
la Présidente c'est des amendements de
prétexte de prise de parole puisqu'il
supprime des alinéa rédactionnelles donc
c'est un avis défavorable sur tes
amendements
très bien donc j'ai une demande de
parole de Madame IBA
merci madame la Présidente
au-delà des considérations
philosophiques et quelquefois faut bien
le dire délirante que nous entendons cet
après-midi je voudrais qu'on revienne
qu'on revienne à des choses un peu plus
concrètes
éloignons-nous du rapport pendant un
instant du rapport du corps puis
manifestement selon celui qui le lit
satisfait beaucoup de monde
il trouva chacun y trouva finalement ce
qu'il cherche par contre regardons
autour de nous
nous voyons de plus en plus de personnes
centenaires vous pouvez pas l'ignorer
on peut s'en réjouir
il
vous plaît enfin quand vous n'êtes on
n'est pas d'accord avec vous tout de
suite il y a le brouhaha s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît
madame la députée elle seule elle a la
parole
s'il vous plaît
il n'empêche que si on regarde de plus
près nous pouvons trouver des personnes
qui passent presque autant de temps à la
retraite qu'au travail et demain
sûrement plus alors je sais bien que
vous en rêvez que vous voulez vous
réclamer le droit à la paresse
mais oui mais oui
mais pouvez-vous sans rire mais
pouvez-vous sans rire convaincre nos
concitoyens que si nous n'avons pas un
problème démographique important si nous
voulons garder notre régime de
solidarité vous ne pouvez pas leur faire
croire ce que vous voulez leur faire
croire d'ailleurs ils ne le croient pas
et donc seriez-vous par hasard
seriez-vous par hasard c'est ton jamais
c'est en jamais pour un régime par
capitalisation
s'il vous plaît
non mais s'il vous plaît vous êtes en
nombre effectivement la nupesse mais
infini vous parlez entre vous dès que
quelqu'un n'est pas d'accord avec vous
c'est le brouhaha madame panot madame
panot madame panot vous avez un bel
organe comme moi je vous entends son
micro jusqu'ici je vous entends
jusqu'ici sans micro je vous entends je
vous entends
voilà
monsieur Corbière à la parole et lui
seul à la parole madame madame panot
madame la Présidente panot s'il vous
plaît je passe la parole à Monsieur
Corbière et lui seul à la parole
est-ce que j'ai pas de micro il marche
vous l'avez ça c'est réservé c'est privé
je voudrais
je voudrais dans ce débat qui est
intéressant depuis tout à l'heure
beaucoup de collègues
évoque le fait que la famille politique
dont je fais partie aurait insufflé une
espèce de culture de la paresse
et je voudrais vous rappeler qu'il y a
quand même
l'histoire qui nous surplombe et qui
devrait faire que certains gardent en
mémoire que lorsque le Front Populaire a
mis en place un sous secrétariat aux
loisirs incarné par Léo Lagrange
l'extrême droite Action française a mené
une campagne de calomnies qui le
considérait comme le ministre de la
paresse qu'en 1940 le maréchal Pétain
a été institué des pleins pouvoirs il a
considéré les responsables de la défaite
le gouvernement de Front populaire et la
gauche parce qu'elle avait insufflé dans
le pays je le cite un esprit de
jouissance donc j'aimerais Carette ce
vocabulaire qui a servi au pire moment
notre histoire de la République et qui
constitue un ensemble de stupidités
enfin pour terminer
quand il s'agit de l'ouvrage de Paul
Lafargue écrit en 1883 je rappelle qu'à
l'époque les ouvriers travaillaient 12
heures par jour que les enfants
travaillaient qu'il n'y avait pas droit
à la retraite et que pour la première
femme penseur socialiste dont je ne
partage pas totalement la pensée mais à
l'occasion de son enterrement il avait
toutes les grandes figures à commencer
par Jean Jaurès pour vous dire que
c'était pas n'importe qui mais a
commencé à penser une société où le
travailleur n'était pas là que pour
travailler ça n'est pas une ode à rien
mais c'était pour la première
fois une dignité de l'être humain qui
disait qu'il n'était pas sur terre
uniquement pour souffrir donc j'aimerais
qu'arrête les sottises et qu'on discute
sérieusement
[Applaudissements]
très bien
la parole est à Madame Rousseau
elle va justement sur le droit à la
paresse parce que je sens bien que ça
vous a quand même un tout petit peu
perturbé voire traumatisé cette affaire
que nous ayons droit à l'appareil je
rappelle quand même que le temps libre
et ça fait partie du progrès social ça
fait même partie de nos conquis sociaux
essentiels ça n'est pas uniquement de la
reconstitution de notre force de travail
mais c'est du loisir c'est du temps pour
nous que ça s'appelle les congés payés
que ça s'appelle la diminution du temps
de travail qu'en 1950 nous travaillons
1900 heures par an quand aujourd'hui
nous en travaillons 1400 en moyenne et
que c'est ça le sens du progrès et que
par ailleurs plus nous travaillons plus
nous produisons dans une dans une
économie qui n'est pas décarbonée plus
nous allons dans le mur climatique donc
maintenant il faut vraiment ouvrir les
yeux sur notre système économique et
social oui à la paresse et oui à la
réduction du temps de travail
très bien monsieur Bazin vous avez la
parole
monsieur Bazin et lui seul à la parole
madame la
Présidente Monsieur Bazas s'il vous
plaît attendez monsieur le député s'il
vous plaît
ça y est
monsieur Bazin oui merci madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues je
trouverai important qu'on en reste au
texte or là on fait une grande
discussion générale c'est pas
inintéressant quoi que il y a quelques
excès parfois dans les alors tout le
monde veut réécrire l'histoire c'est
c'est pas forcément
oui mais faut savoir la respecter ce qui
est sûr c'est que le sujet de la paresse
n'est pas venu de ses bancs il est venu
ce matin lorsqu'on a voulu poser un
certain nombre de d'éléments principiels
à cette réforme notamment la
valorisation du travail d'avoir une
ambition sur le renouvellement des
générations de manière à assurer
l'équilibre du système
et on nous a répondu oh là là surtout
pas la valorisation du travail il y a un
droit à la paresse et mais si et
d'ailleurs même Rousseau et laissez-moi
parler madame Rousseau et et on a on est
en désaccord là-dessus mais elle a au
moins l'honnêteté de pouvoir expliquer
je pense qu'il faut pas confondre
paraissent et repos parce que le repos
suit le travail
alors que la paresse c'est une forme de
goût pour loisiveté et si on veut à un
moment apporter une protection sociale
il faut s'en donner les moyens et les
moyens bien ça passe par le travail tous
ceux qui sont en capacité en âge de
travailler et qui ont droit à un repos
une fois qu'ils ont travaillé ils
peuvent le faire mais ils seraient très
dangereux dans notre société notamment
pour la nouvelle génération qui doute de
la transmission de ce patrimoine qui est
la sécurité sociale à un moment mais
c'est la pensée on est là aussi pour
débattre et je vous ai écouté monsieur
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai tout le
monde
l'important c'est de pouvoir recréer
contre il faut réinstaurer de la
confiance dans notre système ça passe
par la revalorisation du travail et
aujourd'hui il y a des injustices envers
ceux qui ont beaucoup bossé sans compter
leurs heures et aujourd'hui le message
qu'on envoie c'est ne pas ne pas
travailler ça donnerait des droits
demain c'est pas possible
s'il vous plaît très bien alors avant
monsieur Corbière s'il vous plaît
personne ne méprise personne dans cette
commission s'il vous plaît pas de
provocation il y a un débat un contre
des bas mais personne ne méprise
personne
très bien alors je vais passer
oui monsieur sans Sud pardon
juste un petit mot sur ce débat fort
intéressant
que notre collègue Corbières a remis à
remis dans la perspective historique oui
le la retraite c'est le droit au repos
des vieux travailleurs c'est le droit au
repos des vieux travailleurs et ça et
les vieilles travailleuses aussi vous
avez raison un collègue mais non c'est
comme ça que c'était inscrit au moment
où la retraite a été dans le Conseil
National de la Résistance dans le
programme c'est comme ça que c'est écrit
c'est pas moi qui l'invente alors après
que l'on critique le la paresse
peut-être alors la paresse peut-être un
moment du temps de repos quand même on a
le droit mais que l'on critique la
paresse peut-être peut-on critiquer
aussi ceux qui s'enrichissent en dormant
parce que dans ce pays on nous explique
dans ce pays on les explique qu'il n'y a
pas d'argent jamais le Produit Intérieur
Brut par habitant n'a été aussi élevé
jamais il n'a été aussi élevé et donc à
un moment si vous voulez qu'on parle de
tout on parle de tout y compris de ceux
qui s'enrichissent en dormant et qui
permettent à un système d'être grippé
aujourd'hui et j'espère que les Français
vont réussir à le dégripper demain
madame la rapporteur avant de passer au
vote je passe la parole à Madame la
rapporteur oui je voudrais pas avoir
l'air de faire une synthèse mais je
crois que nos concitoyens attendent de
nous cette équilibre entre le temps de
repos le temps de de travail mais aussi
et surtout l'équilibre de nos comptes
sociaux et à mon avis l'un va pas sans
l'autre donc avançons dans ce texte très
bien l'équilibre donc après ce débat et
se contredat je mets aux voix cet
amendement 3802 qui reçoit un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur qui
est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant monsieur Monet ou monsieur
derrière je ne sais pas non c'est bien
moi juste
cet amendement donc et l'expression de
notre volonté de ne pas supprimer le
régime social mais je vais vous faire
une confidence
j'aurais été prêt moi discuter de la
suppression des régimes spéciaux
si on avait gardé l'esprit d'Ambroise
Croizat
qui disait simplement qu'il voulait le
faire de la retraite non pas
l'antichambre de la mort mais une
nouvelle étape de la vie
donc l'idée de la retraite c'est de
construire des choses positives qui
protègent les gens
aujourd'hui dans ce que vous nous
demandez de faire en supprimant les
registres spéciaux en quoi vous faites
progresser la vie des retraitée
c'est une vraie question
aujourd'hui vous reculez la protection
et j'ai même le sentiment que dès lors
qu'on défend un peu de bonheur auprès
des retraités ça vous aurait pile
mais c'est pas vrai parce que mais vous
dites n'importe quoi vous dites
n'importe quoi parce que amener le sujet
des retraites sur une logique comptable
c'est nier l'importance d'avoir une
vraie protection aujourd'hui si on a une
nouvelle recette on peut avoir un
système de retraite qui protège tout le
monde et correctement et vous le savez
et ben par exemple quand on augmente les
salaires ce qu'on vous a proposé vous
faites rentrer des cotisations
supplémentaires par exemple quand vous
réglez la question de la différence à
l'arrière entre les hommes et les femmes
c'est 6 milliards d'euros qui rentrent
supplémentaires si vous Cotis si vous
faites si vous faites cotiser si vous
faites cotiser si vous faites cotiser
des rentiers c'est 8 milliards d'euros
qui rentrent supplémentaires c'est pas
un problème d'argent c'est un problème
de choix de société et on partage pas le
même
très bien Madame la rapporteur votre
avis sur cet amendement 3803 juste une
petite remarque pour pour rebondir on a
quand même un sujet de démographie votre
raisonnement tient s'il y a pas un sujet
de démographie et on sait tous qu'on a
pu assez de cotisants pour le nombre de
personnes à la retraite
défavorable toujours un amendement très
bien monsieur Ferracci vous souhaitiez
intervenir
oui pour agir à ce qui a été dit par
Monsieur Monet
il y a quand même un principe sur lequel
on doit tous on devrait tous converger
c'est le principe de solidarité
nationale notre système par répartition
c'est un socle de la solidarité
nationale l'idée selon laquelle les
cotisations équilibres les pensions on y
est tous très attachés je sais que vous
l'êtes et ce principe il était inscrit
aux frontispices de la réforme de 1945
lorsque on commence comme c'est le cas
avec les régimes spéciaux je suis désolé
de vous le rappeler à financer notre
système par répartition en faisant appel
au budget de l'État on l'a dit c'est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui et bien on est
plus dans un système de répartition et
puisque vous citez Ambroise Croizat j'ai
envie moi aussi
et bien de retrouver ces mots je le cite
faire appel au budget des contribuables
serait subordonné l'efficacité de la
politique sociale à des considérations
purement financières ce que nous
refusons et bien nous aussi nous
refusons de remettre en question
l'intégrité de notre système par
répartition parce que c'est un socle de
la solidarité nationale et parce que
lorsque des déficits perdurent comme
c'est le cas pour un certain nombre de
régimes spéciaux dont nous discutons et
bien nous remettons en question cette
intégrité nous ne souhaitons pas enterré
ce projet-là et votre cohérence devrait
vous amener votre cohérence politique et
historique parce que je veux rappeler
qu'Ambroise Croizat était communiste
lui-même et je le rappelle et je lui
rend hommage à ce titre là aussi mais je
veux vous dire je veux vous dire que
votre cohérence historique devrait aussi
vous amener à reconsidérer vos positions
à l'égard de ce principe de solidarité
nationale qui est attaché à la
répartition
très bien monsieur monsieur Daredevil
à propos de ce que vient de dire notre
collègue Marc Ferracci la première c'est
que si vous êtes si attaché que cela
à ne pas faire appel au contribuable
pour financer la protection sociale il
faut arrêter la foire aux exonérations
que vous faites chaque année chaque
année avec des milliards 75 milliards
d'euros par an qui sont financés par le
contribuable ça c'est pas des décisions
nous avons pris ça monsieur ferrati bien
sûr elles sont compensées par l'impôt
par le contribuable et oui c'est
exactement ce que vous critiquez à
l'instant et que je critique aussi on
devrait pouvoir se rejoindre sur cet
aspect des choses le deuxième le
deuxième élément c'est qu'il y a un
certain nombre de contributions de
l'État et c'est le cas par exemple pour
la SNCF aujourd'hui pour équilibrer ce
régime qui résulte de choix qui ont été
faits par l'État lui-même de modifier un
certain nombre de structures d'empêcher
par exemple aujourd'hui que des gens
puissent continuer d'adhérer à ce régime
qui était celui de la SNCF et donc il y
a effectivement des choses qu'il faut
regarder de plus près et où l'État doit
rentrer en jeu pour faire jouer lui-même
la solidarité nationale lorsqu'il y a
besoin voilà ce que nous considérons
voilà notre cohérence
très bien Madame La Valette
oui madame ma présidente vous ne pouvez
pas comme ça vous cacher derrière
derrière la démographie c'est pas
possible c'est un des grands absents
encore de votre réforme je vous rappelle
que le corps est habillé l'équilibre
d'ici à 2070 au regard des évolutions
démographiques et pourtant on enregistre
a priori un taux de un taux de fécondité
pratiquement le plus bas depuis
l'entre-deux-guerres donc tant que vous
n'aurez pas une politique nataliste
forte évidemment j'étais vous n'avez pas
droit à au chapitre de la démographie je
vous rappelle qu'on avait même déposé
nous on a un moment qui était symbolique
mais qui voulait octroyer une part
pleine dès le deuxième enfant pour
justement que la France ait encore des
bébés on l'a dit tout à l'heure ce sont
les bébés de 2023 qui paieront les
retraits de 2043 donc que faites-vous
pour la démographie
très bien monsieur Delaporte oui je
remercie le collègue Ferracci d'avoir
rendu hommage au père fondateur de notre
système social aujourd'hui
c'est malheureusement ce que vous
détricotez patiemment depuis 2017 et
rendre hommage c'est aussi respecter les
défis de la construction sociale et le
fait que quand on acquiert des droits
nouveaux on ne les nie pas le lendemain
vous évoquez les questions du
financement nous aussi on est pour un
financement pérenne le problème c'est
qu'on est en train de débattre ici dans
le vide sur des projections qui sont non
fondées ou dans nos contestons et dont
même le corps conteste les hypothèses
que vous retenez pour arriver au calcul
du déficit bien sûr que si et on pourra
y revenir si vous le souhaitez on est
tout à fait pris en débattre mais quand
on regarde les
les on va dire
milliards d'économies les 17,7 milliards
d'économies que vous entendez faire avec
cette réforme sur qui pèse-t-il à 100%
sur les salariés qui vont devoir
différer leur départ
sur les précédentes réformes
c'est
économies elles étaient pas enfin
prélevées sur la vie des salariés elles
étaient prises en partie sur des
cotisations salariales sur des
cotisations patronales sur les retraités
actuels ou sur des parts différé donc là
vous êtes vraiment allé chercher des
économies sur la vie des gens pour
essayer d'équilibrer le système et c'est
ça que nous contestons profondément il y
avait d'autres manières de financer et
nous en reparlerons demain un déficit
ponctuel mais là vous êtes en train de
faire quelque chose qui est irrévocable
c'est à dire que vous allez faire payer
une réforme sur le prix de la vie des
gens
très bien Madame panot
oui parce que là depuis plusieurs
argumentaires on entend le fameux
principe démographique la question de la
natalité qui est portée par le RN alors
le principe démocratique vous nous
l'expliquez 25 fois c'est à dire que il
y avait avant 3 actifs pour un retraité
maintenant il n'y a plus que 1,7 actif
pour 3 pour un retraité pardon donc vous
vous rendez compte forcément il y a un
déficit sur les retraites sauf que sauf
que là on prend par rapport aux années
70 un actif et aujourd'hui trois fois
plus productif qu'un actif dans les
années 70 et que si on regarde le 20e
siècle vous aviez 3000 heures de travail
au début du 20e siècle 1500 heures de
travail à la fin du 20e siècle donc une
division par deux et une productivité
qui a été multipliée par 40 donc la
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait de
l'augmentation de la productivité est-ce
que on la verse pour gaver des
actionnaires ou est-ce que on permet au
grand nombre d'en bénéficier de libérer
du temps de travail dans la semaine dans
l'année ou dans la vie quant à la
fameuse natalité dont parlera semblement
national je les ai entendus prendre pour
exemple la Hongrie là Hongrie c'est
intéressant parce que c'est un pays où
l'avortement quasi interdit et où on
oblige aux femmes d'écouter le cœur du
foetus avant de pouvoir avorter et
disposer librement de son corps vous
pourriez aussi parler de la Pologne où
Isabelle et agnieschka sont mortes
puisque l'avortement y est là aussi
quasi interdit et puis je voudrais dire
au rassemblement national que peut-être
vous ne le savez pas mais savez-vous
qu'elle est le département en hexagone
ou qui reçoit le moins de prestation
sociale et bien c'est la
Seine-Saint-Denis et je crois que je
n'ai jamais entendu Jean-Marie Le Pen se
plaindre que sa retraite soit payé par
des jeunes de quartier populaire parce
que c'est exactement ce qui se passe
dans notre pays
très bien
monsieur Vigier
oui merci madame la Présidente
je voudrais simplement
rebondir sur ce que disait notre
collègue de la porte tout à l'heure en
disant dans les précédentes très fortes
on a vu agi sur le cotisations salariale
et sur les cotisations patronales dont
acte mais d'accord chers collègue si on
agit sur le cotisations salariale
quelque part la retraite pas définition
elle diminue sur le sur les cotisations
patronales naturellement c'est autre
chose c'est une entreprise qui sont
mises à contribution le choix n'a pas
été fait mais en revanche je vais
corriger son propos et il le sait très
bien la loi Touraine prévoyait quand
même qu'en 2035 tout le monde est cotisé
43 ans donc l'effort de travailler
depuis longtemps a bien été demandé par
la gauche lorsqu'elle était en
responsabilité on est loin de la réforme
de François Mitterrand qui nous a
expliqué qu'il y a 60 ans tout le monde
partait avec une retraite à taux plein
et d'ailleurs j'observe que à aucun
moment j'ai vu des propulsions de loi ou
des résolutions arrivées ici en disant
on revient à 60 ans en tout cas de la
part du Parti socialiste je rappelle
également si il est vrai il y a eu des
exonérations salariales majeures à
hauteur 75 milliards d'euros c'est la
vérité je suis d'accord mais pour autant
vous vous souvenez que le fameux cice
qui avait été mis en place qui était
l'alpha et l'oméga qu'est-ce que j'ai
pas entendu dans la salle d'à côté avec
Charles de Courson qui sont de finance
vous expliquer que le plein emploi que
la compétitivité était là et tous les
jours quelqu'un nous disait je regarde
l'inversion de la coupe du chômage mais
je la vois pas venir moi j'ai quand même
on sait comment tout ça c'est terminé
donc si je veux dire c'est que il y a me
semble-t-il un peu de modestie par une
autre ça semble bien une phrase qui m'a
un peu troublé c'est lorsqu'un collègue
a dit tout à l'heure l'affaire du
retraites échappe à toute logique
comptable mais pardonnez-moi ça n'est
pas vrai malheureusement la somme versée
des 346 milliards il y en a 79% qui sont
payés par les cotisations sociales où
est-ce qu'on trouve la différence c'est
là où il y a un vrai sujet donc là
chacun peut avoir des avis différents et
c'est normal et les propositions
différentes mais ne disons pas qu'à
l'heure actuelle tout est compensé à
l'Europe ça n'est pas vrai on est à moi
de 80% de couverture donc c'est 20% il
faut aller chercher d'une façon d'une
autre enfin Madame la Présidente se
termine en reprise dans mon propos de
tout à l'heure j'ai donc fait faire une
vérification des chiffres pour la
fameuse CTA pour les EIG c'est bien un
milliard 7 d'euros qu'on va chercher
dans les feuilles de tous les citoyens
français très heureux par famille pour
une facture de 800 euros par an donc
tout le monde participe à ses retraites
je pense pas que cette affaire de la
rustine soit la meilleure facture très
bien monsieur Bazin oui merci madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues il y a
quand même des constats qui ont quand
même changé depuis 1970 je suis pas sûr
que la productivité est augmentée autant
que ce qui a été annoncé elle va même si
elle a augmenté mais on a aussi amélioré
un certain nombre de couverture sociale
de protection qui font l'honneur de
notre pays je pense à la prise en compte
guillotine du handicap on a des enjeux
sur la branche autonomie on a le défi et
c'est une réalité on a un vieillissement
de la population l'espérance de vie a
augmenté on a aussi le souhait de
vieillir en bonne santé tout ça c'est
possible que si on a des personnes qui
travaillent et donc cotisent pour
pouvoir financer ces risques découvrir
et de l'autre côté sur le système par
répartition il ne tient que si un
renouvellement des générations et donc
il y a quand même un une équation
démographique qui n'est pas négligeable
et l'UNAF qui rassemble les associations
familiales à effet un colloque ici même
il y a près d'un an le désir de
maternité était de 2,3 enfants par femme
on est à 1,8 enfants il y a des réalités
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on ne soutient pas
assez la femme qui travaille et qui veut
avoir des enfants et donc je pense qu'il
y a une équation à trouver aujourd'hui
pour favoriser la conciliation entre
professionnels et vie familiale de
revenir sur les rabots successifs
l'abaissement du quotient familial la
mise sous condition des allocations
familiales alors que on a contrevenu au
principe d'universalité des allocations
familiales on a aussi le sujet de la
l'indemnité journalière en cas de
maladie pour les maires de trois enfants
ou plus tous ces éléments là ont
contribué aussi à pénaliser le pouvoir
d'achat des maires qui travaillent et
c'est ça qu'il faut pouvoir corriger je
crois qu'il faut qu'on soit très concret
madame le rapporteur vous êtes
rapporteur du pfss il y a une branche
famille elle est excédentaire elle a été
ponctionnée de 2 milliards peut-être
qu'il faut qu'on utilise cette excellent
pour mieux accompagner les femmes qui
travaillent
très bien Monsieur Paul Christophe
oui merci ma présidente
MP que je connais bien je te rappelais
que c'est on n'a pas fonctionné la
branche famille simplement être
transférer en rapport avec des dépenses
qui relevaient de l'Assurance Maladie
voilà c'est cette différence entre
ponction et transfert mais on y arrivera
je suis sûr qu'on finira par parler la
même langage juste rappeler également à
mon notre cher Arthur de la porte que
déficit ponctuel prévu par le corps
c'est comme je suis en 2070 quoi le
ponctuel à 47 ans je trouve quand même
que la mesure mérite d'être rappelé
simplement aussi dire que oui il y a un
des petites générationnel on a décidé de
natalité d'ailleurs ça a été conforté
malheureusement dans les derniers
rapports qui ont été proposés puis chez
Arthur j'ai l'habitude de t'entendre et
de t'entendre parler donc de des
socialistes espagnoles à prendre exemple
juste rappeler que au niveau de
l'Espagne on est à 66 ans et que la
tendance c'est de ses 67 ans en 2027
très bien
oui oui non non c'est bon je crois que
les gens se sont exprimés il y a eu une
intervention par groupe ah oui très bien
si il y a eu Madame La Valette qui s'est
exprimée je suis désolé très bien donc
je passe la parole à Madame la
rapporteur vous la souhaitez non donc je
mets aux voix c'est amendement qui
reçoit la vie défavorable de Madame la
rapporteur qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant monsieur Daredevil
sur l'esplanade de l'hôpital on a décidé
de faire venir le petit-fils de
l'Ambroise Croizat pour donner le nom
d'Ambroise Croizat à cette place devant
l'hôpital comme ça bol de notre
attachement à ceux qui avant nous
avaient élaboré le terrain des utopies
et des réalités concrètes
le petit-fils d'Ambroise Croizat ne
supporte pas que les libéraux cite son
père pour détourner les propos de son
père il a d'ailleurs fait une lettre
ouverte et je le dis pour les libéraux
qui d'une certaine manière
ce gloss de vouloir citer en disant
Ambroise Croizat était pour
l'universalité c'est-à-dire la
couverture de l'ensemble de la
population du pays il était aussi pour
une gestion démocratique
élue au suffrage
direct pour trois quarts les assurés
sociaux et pour InCar le patronat
l'unité pour ceux qui ont été attisés la
gestion de l'assurance maladie et qui
ont fait la même chose pour la
protection sociale dans son ensemble ils
sont mal inspirés de pouvoir le citer il
ajoute que l'un des socles d'Ambroise
Croizat c'était la solidarité par les
mécanismes de redistribution des revenus
de tous les revenus au profit des plus
faibles et enfin il ajoute l'unité pour
le groupement de l'ensemble des risques
sociaux au sein d'un même régime et vous
permet au marcheur au libéraux de dire
voyez bien Ambroise Croizat était pour
la disparition des régimes spéciaux mais
là encore le petit-fils vous fait une
lecture originelle de la pensée de son
grand-père qui a effectivement
indiqué que l'idéal serait d'intégrer
les bénéfices des régimes spéciaux pour
élever vers le haut l'ensemble du régime
général et non pas de le faire comme
vous le proposez en tirant vers le bas
toujours un peu plus vers le bas le sort
réservé aux salariés donc je voulais
voilà vous dire ne vous référer pas à
croisa il appartient à la France mais il
appartient à ceux qui à ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui fidèles c'est-à-dire ceux
qui sont du côté de ce banc
et je rappelle que je rappelle je
rappelle que je rappelle que Olivier
Véran voulait supprimer la référence de
la sécurité sociale dans la loi et donc
vous êtes mal inspiré de pouvoir faire
référence à Ambroise Croizat aujourd'hui
très bien
avis de la rapporteur
c'est un avis défavorable très bien donc
je mets aux voix cet amendement qui a
reçu un avis défavorable qui est pour
qui contre
il est rejeté amendement suivant
monsieur Clouet oui allez-y monsieur le
député merci madame la Présidente alors
avec cet amendement vous propose de pas
toucher au régime du CESU je pense que
c'est assez clair c'est que sur 175
membres il y a 52 syndicalistes et 17
entreprises 17 représentant d'entreprise
c'est sans doute pour ça que vous voulez
toucher plus sérieusement nous avons
proposé nous de supprimer un autre
régime très spécial celui du président
de la République et ça a été jugé il
recevable président de la République qui
lui peut toucher 5500 euros brut par
mois peut siéger au Conseil
constitutionnel pour 13700 euros brut
par mois peut avoir cette collaborateurs
et deux agents de police à disposition
pendant 5 ans puis trois collaborateurs
et un agent voilà un régime bien spécial
et celui-ci malheureusement nous n'avons
pas pu y toucher je profite de ce temps
pour répondre à plusieurs personnes à
Madame Bonnivard qui a parlé tout à
l'heure du travail épanouissant
effectivement madame Bonnivard on vous
invite à aller porter des charges
lourdes payer au SMIC et vous verrez si
c'est épanouissant de se casser le dos
pour un salaire de misère répondre à nos
collègues aussi sur le travail parce que
qui est paresseux finalement et bien
sont les oui moi je l'ai fait moi oui
oui moi je l'ai fait et je peux vous
dire que les gens les gens avec qui j'ai
bossé à l'usine et ben ils étaient pas
d'accord j'aimerais bien monsieur le
député d'ailleurs ça s'adresse un petit
peu à l'ensemble
qu'on défend de les amendements
vous ne défendez pas l'amendement enfin
puisque on a parlé des paresseux et bien
je vais vous citer quelques mots d'une
chanson que vous n'aimez pas beaucoup
c'est l'international ouvrier paysan
nous sommes le grand parti des
travailleurs la terre n'appartient
qu'aux hommes l'oisif ira l'Oger
ailleurs l'oisif c'est le capitalisme
c'est celui qui fout rien et qui gagne
beaucoup d'argent sur notre dos et puis
enfin répondre à Madame La Valette aussi
oui nous n'avons pas voté votre loi sur
l'augmentation du salaire vous savez
pourquoi parce que à l'intérieur il y
avait une exonération précisément sur le
financement de la retraite il y avait
une exonération
précisément sur les maladies
professionnelles voilà pourquoi madame
La Valette il aurait fallu que le
rassemblement national votre
l'augmentation du SMIC qui permet aussi
l'augmentation des cotisations et donc
un meilleur financement des retraites
encore une fois nous sommes cohérents
très bien je passe la parole je passe la
parole à Madame la rapporteur
défavorable très bien je passe la parole
à Madame Bolivar
merci merci madame la Présidente
de subir ce mépris de classe je le dis
oui oui monsieur parce que vous ne
connaissez pas mon origine voilà non non
mais je vous le dis donc pas de leçon
pas de leçon moi je fais partie d'une
famille d'agriculteurs montagnards qui
ont quasiment rien eu pour vivre des
parents artisans commerçants un père qui
a commencé à travailler à 15 ans donc je
n'ai aucune leçon à recevoir d'aucun
d'entre vous d'aucun d'entre vous à
aucun moment je ne parte à aucun moment
je ne parlais de la pénibilité donc ne
me portez pas ne me portez pas de propos
que je n'ai pas dit j'ai député j'ai dit
que le travail faire croire aux Français
qu'il pouvait avoir le même niveau de
solidarité comme vous le faites en
travaillant toujours moins est un
mensonge et vous abîmer notre pays oui
le travail était pas nourrissant et
notre rôle est de donner les moyens et
c'était le des amendements que j'avais
porté dans ce dans ce projet de loi
c'était de donner les moyens à nos
concitoyens d'évoluer d'avoir plusieurs
carrières car tous les métiers sont
nécessaires et effectivement il convient
de reconnaître tous ceux qui sont
difficiles pour donner d'autres
opportunités à nos concitoyens mais vous
réduisez mon propos je vois que c'est un
mépris de classe tout à l'heure mon
collègue m'a apporté des propos pareil
donc voilà je souhaitais rappeler
rappeler d'où je viens et dire à
Monsieur Corbière que je suis rapporteur
du budget du tourisme que je suis très
attachée au tourisme social que je crois
que je crois au repos et et à la
retraite et au fait de pouvoir
bénéficier du fruit de son travail mais
pour avoir tout ça la base et le
fondement c'est le travail
très bien la parole la parole est à
Monsieur Benz
merci merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais réagir à l'amendement
précisément précisément puisque il
traite du régime spécial du C2 s'il vous
plaît attendez monsieur le député s'il
vous plaît on ne s'interpelle pas s'il
vous plaît et j'aimerais bien qu'on
revienne à l'amendement en question
monsieur Benz merci madame la Présidente
précisément je le disais je voudrais
réagir sur le régime spécial lié au CESU
parce qu'effectivement on s'oppose on
vous l'avez compris à cette réforme des
retraites on s'est opposé ce matin et
tout à l'heure à la suppression des
régimes spéciaux de retraite notamment
pour la RATP ou pour les retraités de
l'industrie électrique et gazières parce
qu'on considère que c'est son régime
spéciaux justifié et mérité pour ainsi
dire ce sont des missions d'intérêt
général d'intérêt national ce n'est pas
le cas du CESU un autre sens d'abord
c'est une institution très coûteuse près
de 50 millions d'euros par an je pense
pas qu'on ait besoin de trois chambres
il y a l'Assemblée le Sénat je pense que
cela est largement suffisant ensuite il
y a un véritable le problème sur le mode
de désignation à savoir des nominations
voir des cooptations on va se le dire le
CESU c'est un peu la République des
copains et évidemment ça pose problème
ce n'est une institution qui n'est pas
démocratique qui n'est pas démocratique
et qui n'est pas représentative c'est
pour ça que nous sommes pour la
suppression de ce régime spécial je
remercie très bien la parole est à
Monsieur Vigier
oui merci madame la Présidente
oui combien de dire chaque Charles de
Courson j'ai eu l'honneur et l'avantage
au sein de cette maison vous allez
contrôler le ses œufs au-dessus de la
commission des finances pendant 5 ans
donc je crois en avoir approché le
fonctionnement au quotidien tant pour
les membres choisis désigner élus que
l'ensemble des administratifs d'abord
cette institution contrairement à ce
qu'il collègue et pour moi est utile il
est important
et on peut pas d'un côté dire que la
parole on doit donner aux citoyens et à
ceux qui les représentent d'une façon ou
d'une autre et qui ne sont pas élus leur
dire terminé circulait il y a plus rien
à voir je ne suis pas d'accord avec
cette vision là c'est parce que
justement Franck le paritarisme est
sous-dimensionné parce que les citoyens
n'ont pas assez la parole que il me
semble-t-il il y a des sujets sur
lesquels il y a des crispations
importantes qui se font en revanche de
maintenir le régime spécial des membres
du 16e là me surprend de la part de ces
rédacteurs quand on connaît le
fonctionnement intime de cela je pense
qu'il n'est vraiment pas nécessaire en
plus ces membres-là quelle que soit leur
qualité qui sont souvent du grandes
qualités ont d'autres fonctions bien
souvent dans des syndicats ou dans la
vie professionnelle ou dans des
entreprises donc ça serait que l'on dit
assez superfétatoire que de vouloir
maintenir ce régime spécial donc nous
soutiendrons naturellement cette
initiative madame le rapporteur général
que de supprimer ce régime c'est pour le
CESU qui est un régime spécial très bien
monsieur Delaporte
oui merci madame la Présidente moi je
souhaiterais juste avoir un point très
rapide parce que tout à l'heure j'ai
entendu les collègues du rassemblement
national dire que le CESU était un
comité Théodule cette vision finalement
très complémentaire avec le lentille
corporatisme qui est
caractéristique du rassemblement
national nous rappelle juste que le CESU
fait un rôle important pour notre pays
et c'est pas le collègue Vigier qui dira
à l'inverse et finalement inclure le
CESU dans cette réforme c'est donner
l'impression que le sais je ne servent à
rien que ces membres sont des paresseux
ce qui n'est évidemment pas notre
position nous croyons sincèrement dans
son rôle et dans sa nécessité pour
appuyer nos décisions à l'Assemblée
nationale et faire vivre donc la
démocratie
très bien la parole est à Charles de
Courson
oui mes chers collègues moi je suis pour
la suppression de ce régime social qui
est minuscule en plus mais il pose de
problème des deux autres assemblées
c'est-à-dire du Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale alors madame la rapporteur
nous dit mais ceci relève de la loi
organique je suis en train de le
vérifier car je n'en suis pas sûr que
son argument est solide mais on pourrait
parfaitement demander au bureau puisque
c'est les bureaux qui gèrent le régime
spécial du Sénat et le régime spécial de
l'Assemblée de voter un texte de
principe en demandant que à compter de
la prochaine législature ce sont les
règles du régime général qui
s'appliquent à ce régime spécial ça ça
me paraîtrait tout à fait
bien parce qu'on peut pas demander mes
chers collègues des efforts aux autres
sans donner l'exemple soi-même
mais non mais non c'est ce qu'on vous
raconte ce n'est pas exact et vous savez
qu'au Sénat ce n'est pas exactement non
plus
et bien justement et ben justement non
non c'est ce qu'on nous a dit c'est pas
calé exactement sur le régime général
ne serait-ce que par exemple vos côtés
vous cotisez double le premier mandat
dans le nouveau système voilà et ben ça
c'est pas dans le régime général vous
voyez donc nous devrions donner un
exemple de dire que ces deux régimes ils
sont alignés sur régime général
très bien la parole est à Monsieur
Ruffin
madame Bonnivard vous nous dites on peut
on peut pas dire aux Français qui
peuvent avoir le même niveau de vie en
travaillant moins
factuellement c'est faux depuis 20 ans
en France on travaille plus pas beaucoup
plus on est passé de 1605 heures à 1609
heures donc c'est pas colossal
on travaille plus aussi parce qu'on est
moins longtemps à la retraite quand il
était à une vingtaine d'années mais
factuellement c'est une première chose
qui est fausse on travaille plus et je
dirais que c'est une inversion de
l'histoire qu'est-ce que ça a été le
sens de l'histoire l'histoire du
mouvement ouvrier ça a été à la fois la
dignité par le travail l'émancipation
par le travail la réalisation par ce
travail c'est-à-dire la fierté de dire
je gagne ma vie en travaillant c'est la
première chose mais aussi de je libère
du temps au travail c'est la fin du
travail des enfants c'est le dimanche
chômé c'est le samedi à l'anglaise ce
sont les congés payés et c'est la
retraite puis la retraite à 60 ans
qu'est-ce qui se passe depuis en fait
pourquoi l'histoire s'est inversée c'est
une histoire qui nous vient des
États-Unis on ne fait que imiter le
mouvement américain vers la
réaugmentation du temps de travail c'est
la première chose qui est fausse et la
deuxième chose qui est fausse c'est
l'espérance de vie aujourd'hui en bonne
santé depuis 20 ans elle n'augmente pas
elle stagne et le troisième point je
l'ai dit en envoyant les débats mais
c'est que le travail n'est pas plus
léger qu'il l'était il s'est au
contraire alors dit à leur dit
physiquement c'est de 12 à 34 % des
salariés qui subissent 33 contraintes
physiques mais à Lourdes psychiquement
aussi puisque c'est le 6 % à 35 % des
salariés qui subissent trois contraintes
de temps de pénibilité mentale quand on
met bout à bout tout ça quand on met
bout à bout le fait que le l'espérance
de vie en bonne santé n'augmente plus
que les Français travaillent déjà
davantage que le travail il s'est
alourdi intensifié plus que allégé
franchement on voit à quel point on a
une Contre Réforme aujourd'hui qui va à
Sens à rebours de l'histoire et de ce
qui devrait être nécessaire pour la
bonne santé et la bonne santé
psychologique des Français c'est dommage
on parle pas de l'amendement enfin bon
très peu
bon bref la preuve que je suis Aurélie
dans la marge hors sujet hors sujet hors
sujet mais bon qu'est-ce que vous voulez
je passe la parole à Madame Parmentier
le coq
oui merci madame la Présidente je
voulais quand même souligner que c'est
la deuxième fois aujourd'hui que le
rassemblement national porte un coup à
nos instances républicaines à nos
instances démocratiques il accuse les
membres du CESU d'être la République des
copains mais c'est de la diffamation
enfin je veux dire ce sont des propos
tout simplement populistes donc c'est
très grave je pense que beaucoup de
leurs membres sont aussi membres
d'organisation syndicale ou
d'association donc ils appréciront
beaucoup le coût qu'il aurait et les
accusations qui leur sont portées ici et
j'ajoute encore pour continuer
à dénoncer ses propos que précisément
nous supprimons le régime spécial du
CESU dans ce projet de loi
très bien je passe la parole à Madame la
rapporteur avant de passer au vote oui
juste de remarques pour délire un peu ce
qu'a dit Monsieur Rufin parce que on a
pas les mêmes chiffres décidément à 65
ans selon une étude de la dresse
d'octobre 2021 l'espérance de vie sans
incapacité sévère était de 83 ans pour
les femmes et de 80 ans pour les hommes
l'espérance de vie sans aucune
incapacité était de 77 ans pour les
femmes 75 ans pour les femmes pour les
hommes depuis 2008 l'espérance de vie
sans incapacité à 65 ans a augmenté de
deux ans et un mois pour les femmes et
de un an et 11 mois pour les hommes donc
elle a bien augmenté sur le régime des
parlementaires parce qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de de questions il s'agit bien
pour l'affilée au régime général d'un
changement dans le cadre de la loi
organique par contre et c'est ce que
nous avons fait en 2017 le bureau en
tant que à l'Assemblée nationale a
modifié les paramètres les règles qui
font qu'on est
équivalent au régime général mais pour
pour rentrer dans le régime général il
faut cette loi organique on avait mis en
2020 dans le cas de la loi qui n'a pas
pu être adopté
très bien je mets donc on voit cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant monsieur Monet
e si vous mi autorisez je vais également
défendre les suivants le 3816 ou 3821
le 3824 le 3827 le 3828 et le 3829
madame la Présidente
au milieu de Monsieur turquois que je me
permets pas de défendre à sa place mais
je vais défendre tous ceux qui sont
jusqu'au 3829 très bien
simplement bon vous avez compris je
crois notre position à ce texte mais je
voudrais pas que comment dire
vous n'en saisissiez pas la portée vers
si je répète ça depuis ce matin c'est
parce que je crois que l'affaire n'est
pas entendue et que vous allez devoir
renoncer et qu'il faut que cette idée
fasse son chemin
vous allez devoir renoncer à ce texte
parce que il n'a pas de majorité dans le
pays et que c'est une violence
insupportable que vous allez produire
à notre peuple si vous passez en force
donc je me permets de le répéter de
réinsister parce qu'on est ici dans un
débat qui pourrait vous laisser à penser
que finalement on est rentré dans un
processus qui va aller à son terme
tranquillement ça va pas se passer comme
ça en fait voilà donc je me permets je
me permets de vous le répéter je crois
qu'il faut il faut vraiment que vous
réfléchissiez à cette idée là parce que
elle va s'imposer à vous au bout d'un
moment et il me semble si j'en crois le
journal Le Monde de ce jour qu'un
certain nombre d'entre vous commencent à
y réfléchir et je vous les encourager
parce que je crois que c'est une bonne
une bonne chose
nous allons donc nous opposer à ce texte
qui supprime de manière assez
incohérente certains régimes spéciaux et
pas d'autres et vous avez compris
l'attachement qui peut être le nôtre à
certains un certain nombre d'entre eux
et nous avons déjà beaucoup expliqué
pourquoi
en fait un certain nombre sont beaucoup
des lieux de résistance à l'ordre
libéral et le libéralisme a beaucoup
abîmé le travail a beaucoup abîmé nos
vies depuis 30 ou 40 ans maintenant je
voudrais dire un mot de du CESU
particulièrement pour dire que les
attaques qui ont été effectivement été
portées contre lui par le rassemblement
national à plusieurs reprises à la fois
ne nous surprennent pas mais nous nous y
habituons pas parce que nous croyons
effectivement que c'est une chambre qui
regroupe un certain nombre de forces
sociales associatives qui jouent un rôle
considérable dans notre société et qui
je crois permet de porter un regard
utile sur un certain nombre d'enjeux et
de nourrir y compris nos propres travaux
et donc nous sommes nous très attachés à
cette institution démocratique voilà je
voulais signaler cela et vous dire que
donc ces amendements du coup sont
défendus très bien donc je
merci madame la Présidente je joins
monsieur Daredevil sur l'importance du
CESU et notamment du travail qui peut
être fait en région et sur les sujets
santé par exemple auquel j'ai pu pour
lesquels j'ai pu être auditionné je
trouve que le travail est vraiment de
bonne qualité et voilà donc je vous
rejoins par contre je suis complètement
défavorable à vos armements on n'est pas
effectivement du même avis mais je crois
monsieur Daredevil que c'est ce débat
que nous sommes en train de commencer
aujourd'hui et que nous allons
poursuivre pendant plusieurs semaines
qui amènera à un vote ou pas un vote et
c'est ça la démocratie
très bien alors j'ai certaines demandes
d'intervention plusieurs madame
Panossian Bouvet oui merci madame la
Présidente cette
il y a la démocratie sociale avec la
mobilisation qu'on connaît et je pense
qu'on peut tous saluer effectivement la
mobilisation qui a eu il y a quelques
quelques semaines et celle qui aura
demain parce qu'elle se fait dans une
forme de responsabilité et c'est des
choses qu'on doit pouvoir entendre aussi
mais il y a la démocratie politique qui
se joue maintenant ici dans une
configuration politique tout à fait
inédite dans la cinquième république
tout à fait inédite dans la cinquième
république vous l'avez suffisamment
rappelé depuis juin dernier et donc s'il
y a des améliorations à apporter sur les
femmes sur les carrières longues sur les
index seniors sur la pénibilité sur des
choses dont nous avons discuté et bien
c'est ici votre par vote que ça doit se
produire il faut qu'on arrête avec ce
chantage du dodo que vous indiquez comme
votre collègue qui est souvent beaucoup
mieux inspiré à aussi dit sur les
histoires de permanence c'est ICI que ça
se joue
très bien
alors je passe la parole à Monsieur de
la porte
Kim numéro 3
parce que j'ai mon collègue Paul
Christophe qui a dit d'aller regarder en
Espagne bon c'est dommage il est plus là
mais je lui aurais bien proposé un petit
voyage d'étude parce qu'il faut savoir
que cher Paul Christophe absent mais
présent par la pensée la durée de
cotisation en Espagne est très
inférieure à celle fixée en France
37,5 annuités contre 43 ans en France le
taux de remplacement net en Espagne
c'est 80% contre
74% en France combien de combien ont
augmenté les retraites sous le
gouvernement de Sanchez
8,5%. alors si vous voulez aller vous
inspirer de l'Espagne le gouvernement
espagnol à plafonné les retraites des
plus élevés à 3058 euros par mois
et alors j'ai pas le montant moyen mais
il a plafonné le montant maximum des
retraites et il propose une élévation
graduelle des cotisations hauteur de 30%
entre 2025 et 2050 pour financer les
retraites donc si vous voulez vous
inspirer des Espagnols mais je vous en
conjure allons en Espagne regardons ce
qu'ils font avant de dire des bêtises
très bien la parole est à Monsieur
ménager
merci à la présidente à Madame panot oui
nous confirmons que la question de la
natalité est totalement oubliée du débat
oui si les bébés qui naissent
aujourd'hui un panneau ce sera les
cotisants dans 20 ans donc oui nous
avons pour nous aucun autre modèle que
celui de la campagne présidentielle de
Marine Le Pen qui proposait une part
pleine dès le deuxième enfant qui
proposait un prêt pour soutenir les
familles vous vous êtes pas du tout du
côté vous n'êtes pas du côté mais oui
aussi on n'a jamais remis on n'a jamais
remis ça en cause madame madame madame
panot vous continuez dans les fake news
vous y êtes habitué je tiens juste à
vous dire je tiens juste à vous dire
qu'il y a deux visions on a deux visions
vous vous avez vu une vision qui est
celle de soutenir l'immigration massive
nous on soutient les familles nous on ne
veut pas importer de la main d'oeuvre
étrangère vous avez une vision
capitaliste vous voulez importer des
étrangers pour faire le travail des
Français et bah nous on a une version
beaucoup plus humaine on veut pas
baisser des salaires on veut soutenir
sur tous les métiers qui nécessitent des
augmentations de salaire ce que vous
avez refusé donc aujourd'hui on a deux
visions totalement opposé on a une
vision du rassemblement national qui
soutient les familles qui soutiennent la
natalité qui veut aider les femmes qui
travaillent à avoir des enfants et il y
a ceux qui veulent une chose
l'immigration à contrôler et remplacer
des cotisants les bébés de demain par
des immigrés voilà très bien monsieur
jumelles
ce qu'il faudrait pas que vous ayez
l'impression que parce qu'on a examiné
deux ou trois amendements que les choses
sont pliées nous on est pour des
allers-retours permanents entre les gens
la rue et l'hémicycle et donc ce que
vous avez pris tout à l'heure comme une
menace
je
veux je veux le transformer comme une
promesse demain il y aura du monde dans
la rue demain il y aura des électriciens
gaziers dans la rue demain il y aura des
cheminots dans la rue de mayora déjà des
agents de la rue et demain la France
sera rassemblée pour s'opposer à votre
mauvais projet public privé retraités
les jeunes vous êtes seul contre tous
avec cette mauvaise réforme et donc
faudrait arrêter de nous dire écoutez on
a été élu on fait ce qu'on veut mais non
ça marche pas comme ça on va porter
l'idée d'un référendum sur votre projet
on va vous empêcher par tous les bouts
sur votre mauvais projet et demain quand
vous allez voir la rue vous faire
trembler ça sera autre chose que ça sera
autre chose qu'une lumière allumée c'est
la rue qui va trembler et c'est la rue
qui va s'exprimer et c'est vous qui
allez retirer votre projet pas de menace
monsieur le député jumelles pas de
menace
c'est toujours des menaces non non
si vous allez trembler sous homme vous
et bien ça veut dire que vous menacez
quelque part
la promesse constitutionnelle de
manifester
vous avez la parole et seul monsieur
Bazin
alors
je décrète la pause de 10 minutes comme
ça tout le monde va s'aérer un peu
nous allons reprendre nos travaux alors
si je ne m'abuse et si j'ai une bonne
mémoire nous étions sur l'amendement
3811 et il y avait certaines personnes
qu'elle est intervenue c'est bon et donc
c'était monsieur Bazin qui devait
intervenir oui merci madame la
Présidente
nous sommes souvent interpellés sur le
régime
de retraite des députés des
parlementaires or là dans ce texte on
traite celui de la troisième chambre du
16e ça laisserait à penser qu'on
préserverait d'une certaine manière des
privilèges pour pour les députés j'ai
bien compris dans les échanges
précédents que ça ne relevait pas
forcément de la loi mais d'une loi
organique pour autant la plupart des
concitoyens que je rencontre sont
persuadés qu'on a conservés d'une
certaine manière l'ancien régime et
finalement le fait qu'on est aligné moi
je n'ai jamais connu dans ce régime mais
depuis qu'on est élu en 2017 dès 2018 il
y a eu l'alignement sur le régime des
fonctionnaires et on a 172 annuités et
on est sur l'âge légal de départ est-ce
que on pourrait madame la rapporteur
afin d'instaurer
[Musique]
réinstaurer un climat de confiance
prendre l'engagement tout en étant
conforme à la loi organique de pouvoir
s'aligner puisque on se donnerait
l'engagement à nous-mêmes puisque c'est
nous qui vaut la loi avec avec en tant
que député et de dire que si un
changement par cette réforme les députés
aligneront aussi leur régime par rapport
à ça parce que je crois que c'est
important de pas laisser prospérer
l'idée qu'on aurait des avantages
spécifiques il y a eu un travail où on a
aligné sur le droit commun je pense que
c'est important qu'on puisse garantir
que s'il y avait une réforme on ne
serait pas épargné des efforts à faire
mais qu'on aurait les mêmes efforts que
tout le monde
très bien
je vais peut-être passer la parole avant
à Madame taillée polluant
merci madame la Présidente avant la
suspension les esprits étaient un peu
échauffés et notamment en raison des
propos de Monsieur jumelles qui disaient
qui ont été pris comme des menaces mais
ce qui n'en était pas
ce qui n'en était pas pourquoi pourquoi
les gens actuellement la menace qu'il
voit planer sur eux CC ce sont les deux
années de retraite que vous allez que
vous vous apprêtez à leur voler la
menace qu'il semble planer sur eux c'est
le fait que vous êtes prêts à passer en
force sur cette réforme qui est pourtant
totalement injuste et que les Français
et les Français rejettent massivement
alors au cours de ce débat on a parlé
démocratie et Madame Beretti regrettait
de ne pas avoir pu poser des amendements
de proposition mais nous aussi nous le
regrettons ma chère collègues mais
pourquoi nous n'avons pas pu poser des
amendements de proposition c'est parce
que le véhicule législatif choisi par la
majorité relative à laquelle vous
appartenez interdit les propositions
vous avez muselé le débat museler le
débat alors que les Françaises et les
Français ils voient cette menace qui est
très précise et qui rentre en plein avec
leur réalité vécu au travail qui n'est
pas toujours
qui n'est pas toujours une promenade de
santé bien au contraire pour de très
nombreux françaises ce n'est pas une
promenade de santé c'est la pénibilité
c'est l'usure c'est les TMS c'est les
risques psychosociaux donc oui la menace
c'est vous qui la posez aux françaises
et aux Français et quand on dit il faut
pas aborder lisez qui bordélise c'est le
gouvernement qui continue à proposer
cette réforme
ensuite la parole est à
il est pas là les homos monsieur Vigier
à Monsieur Benz je suis désolé mais
votre il y a eu monsieur ménager qui
s'est déjà exprimé
la présidente simplement je voulais dire
à Thibaut Bazin que j'ai écouté avec la
plus grande des intentions sur les
régimes spéciaux des parlementaires et
en disant tout à l'heure il faudrait pas
laisser imaginer qu'on puisse se
protéger sous quelque forme que ce soit
Charles de Gauchon vient d'arriver il se
souvient que je crois que les premiers
qui avaient qui ont fait en sorte que
les parlementaires soient alignés sur le
régime général et Charles de Courson
Thierry Benoît et votre serviteur à
l'époque je vous assure que sur tous les
bancs ça avait suscité un peu d'émotion
comment imaginer qu'on puisse protéger
les parlementaires qui font la loi c'est
impossible même ça relève pas de ce
texte bien sûr en tout cas nous quoi
qu'il arrive nous souhaitons qu'on reste
à ce que l'on a pu obtenir après de
longues années de combat on peut dire
ici même dans cette maison parce que on
voit bien que les corporatives mais les
sédentarités étaient tout à fait
transpartisan à l'époque et ce dont on
pouvait imaginer qu'ils étaient là pour
certains régimes spéciaux auraient bien
aimé les garder eux-mêmes donc voilà les
parlementaires doivent pas échapper à la
règle ils doivent être traités comme
tous les salariés
très bien monsieur Léo mon
on est avant la pause vous aviez demandé
la parole mais si vous n'êtes plus
inspiré très bien Monsieur Charles de
Courson
un petit point pour l'information de
cette affaire tous ceux qui ont voté
en faveur de la précédente réforme qui
s'est arrêtée suite au 49.3 qui n'a pas
été transmis au Sénat doivent se
souvenir que sur le régime de
parlementaires dans le régime universel
il y avait une loi simple et une loi
organique
et donc c'était la position à l'époque
de l'ancienne majorité présidentielle
devenue minorité qui était de dire il
faut que les deux régimes des
parlementaires aillent au régime
universel voilà tous les nouveaux
parlementaires on mettait en extinction
le régime me permet de rappeler cela aux
membres actuels de la minorité
présidentielle et donc
vous êtes minoritaire vous êtes 250 sur
577 alors il faut le rappeler donc je
rappelle cela parce qu'il y a quand même
un problème de cohérence intellectuel
philippevilleger l'a rappelé nous on n'a
pas changé comme disait Dalida on n'a
pas changé
voilà on est pour que tout le monde
sinon faites bien attention à la montée
du populisme
il nous réforme mais il s'exonère de
tout effort
voilà et c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement à l'époque avait décidé de
faire une voix simple et il doit
organique là nous n'avons qu'une loi
simple et donc moi j'avais déposé des
amendements là-dessus on va dire
monsieur de Courson il recevable il faut
une loi organique
très bien monsieur
moi je voudrais à nouveau vous alerter
sur votre comportement sur votre
attitude
qui relève d'un extrémisme
un sondage sort là de l'Ifop qui dit
quoi qui dit 79% des Français pensent
qu'il va y avoir une explosion sociale
52% des Français souhaitent cette
explosion sociale
nous nous sommes les modérés ici
nous sommes les modérés parce que nous
faisons de notre mieux pour que le pays
soit conduit dans l'apaisement
que ça soit pas un sentiment d'injustice
qui rogne le cœur des gens
ce que vous produisez
nous sommes les modérés parce que nous
pensons que quand toutes les syndicats
sont unis contre cette réforme vous
devriez l'écouter nous pensons que quand
la CFTC vient dire que la ligne rouge et
franchie avec les 44 ans vous devriez
l'écouter nous nous pensions que quand
la CFDT vient vous dire les perdants de
la mondialisation se sont eux qui payent
le principal de la facture des retraites
vous devriez les écouter quand la CGT
vous dit jusqu'où vous êtes prêt à aller
pour 0,1 point de PIB vous devriez les
écouter quand
deux millions de Français il y a 15
jours sortent dans la rue je pense que
vous devriez les écouter quand les
millions de Français vont à nouveau
sortir dans la rue demain vous devriez
les écouter quand cette Français sur dix
sont opposés à de cette réforme vous
devriez les écouter quand lui salarié
sur 10 sont posés vous devriez les
écouter parce que vous si vous écoutez
pas tout ça si tout ça ne se passe pas
par le canal du dialogue
de la démocratie de l'échange ça se
passe pas dans ce contexte là comment ça
va se passer vous en serez les
responsables vous êtes les responsables
de la surdité à l'égard du pays et si ça
déborde ça sera de votre faute
très bien donc sur ce madame la
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais répondre déjà à Monsieur Ruffin
alors déjà dire que ça première fois que
qu'on me dit que je suis extrémiste mais
bon passons de non mais très bien très
bien est-ce que est-ce que c'est
extrémiste de travailler un texte de loi
qui a comme objectif de maintenir notre
système de retraite parti par
répartition un texte de loi qu'on avait
annoncé pendant nos campagnes
législatives nous l'avions sur notre
acte est-ce que c'est extrémiste est-ce
que c'est extrémiste d'essayer de mener
un débat dans le fond quand parfois sur
des amendements très de prétexte c'est
plutôt des appels à la manifestation
est-ce que cela encore c'est extrémiste
enfin bon je crois pas sur le régime des
députés nous nous sommes alignés notre
régime de dépité stalini sur le régime
des fonctionnaires en 2018 donc on est
aligné mais on est toujours dans un
régime spécial il faut une proposition
de loi organique qui pourrait être
adopté monsieur de Courson je suis pas
sûr qu'on ne veuille pas fermer notre
régime il y a eu plusieurs personnes de
la majorité qui ont dit justement que il
y avait pas de problème mais vous pouvez
déposer une proposition de loi organique
de la même façon
voilà mais peut-être que la question
peut aussi être posée au sénateur dont
certains sont en campagnes actuellement
qui eux n'ont pas aligné même leur
régime sur celui des fonctionnaires
comme le nôtre ou fermer leur régime
spécial donc voilà
très bien donc je vais mettre aux voix
ces amendements donc
un par un de qui ont été donc défendus
par Monsieur
d'arrêt ville alors ils ont tous reçu un
avis défavorable de Madame la rapporteur
général qui est pour le 3811 qui est
pour
qui est contre il est rejeté même avis
pour le 3816 même avis même vote même
avis même vote pour le 3821
même avis même vote pour le 38204 même
avis même vote pour le
3827 et je non ce oui monsieur je passe
la parole à Monsieur turquois
oui merci madame la Présidente c'est un
amendement que j'ai travaillé avec la
jrco tel que est rédigé le texte
on pourrait il pourrait laisser à penser
que des des professions très
particulières soient affiliées ce qui
pousse poserait un problème en termes de
en termes de d'évaluation des droits
calculés notamment par exemple des
professions type loueurs de meublé
vendeur de bien sur des plateformes type
leboncoin donc c'était un amendement de
pour
évacuer cette ce doute sur la rédaction
voilà très bien Madame la rapporteur
je vous donne le micro allez-y merci
madame la Présidente je me suis
également interrogé sur les effets des
renvois de code que vous mentionnez dans
les échanges que j'ai pu avoir avec le
gouvernement je tiens donc à vous
rassurer sur ce point c'est renvoi ne
changent pas les catégories de personnes
affiliés à la jrco l'interprétation des
conditions d'affiliation restera la même
celles qui sont mentionnées à l'article
l311-2 du code de la sécurité sociale ne
sont pas les mêmes que celles du
l311-3 du code de la sécurité sociale
dont parle votre amendement en revanche
c'est alinéa est nécessaire pour assurer
l'affiliation des nouveaux salariés
recrutés au statut de la Gérard co en
plus de leur affiliation au régime de
base de la sécurité sociale je vous
propose donc un retrait ou sinon un avis
défavorable
très bien alors j'ai monsieur Ruffin qui
demande la parole sur l'amendement
j'espère bien sûr amendement et aussi
pour expliquer à Madame la rapporteur en
quoi elle est extrémiste en quoi vous
appartenez un parti d'extrémiste
quand vous avez les dividendes qui sont
record d'après les échos de mon journal
Bernard Arnault
quand vous avez total qui fait des
dividendes Records et des profits
records quand vous avez les PDG du code
40 qui s'augmente de 52% et que pendant
ce temps-là vous ne bougez pas le petit
doigt quand pendant la première crise
covid ce sont les secteurs de
l'assurance de la grande distribution et
du numérique qui se gavent et que vous
bougez pas le petit doigt quand
maintenant dans la guerre en Ukraine
sont les secteurs de l'énergie de
l'industrie agroalimentaire des
transporteurs de conteneurs qui se
gavent et que vous bougez pas le petit
doigt quand sur tout ça vous bougez pas
le petit doigt mais que votre mesure à
ce moment-là
elle est de venir encore chercher des
petits
avantages sur le travail oui vous êtes
des extrémistes oui en faisant ça vous
mettez le feu pays à des gens qui se
sentent pas reconnus parce que ils ont
fait le boulot ils ont fait le boulot en
permanence dans les hôpitaux ils
continuent à le faire ils font le boulot
pour soigner pour enseigner ils font le
boulot pour que les bus tournent pour
que les trains tournent pour qu'il y ait
des produits dans de supermarchés pour
que
les toutes les marchandises nous soient
fournis quand il y a tout ça oui vous
voulez pas en entendre parler mais quand
il y a tout ça qui se produit et que on
leur a promis une récompense on leur a
promis qu'il y aurait une reconnaissance
et une rémunération qui a rien qui a
même pas l'indexation des salaires sur
l'inflation que tous les jours leurs
petits pouvoirs d'achat est rogné et que
vous trouvez alors que le Président de
la République lui dit même lui disait
quand on est peu qualifié quand on a une
carrière fracturée bon courage déjà pour
laver arriver à 62 ans et déjà en
passant de 60 ans à 62 ans c'était une
multiplication par 4 de seniors au RSA
vous avez opéré ça et maintenant vous
allez accentuer ça voilà pourquoi vous
êtes des extrémistes vous êtes des
extrémistes est-ce que si ça déborde
dans la rue ça sera parce que vous
ajoutez vous ajoutez de la colère à la
colère en permanence monsieur Ruffin
vous aviez dit que vous alliez
intervenir sur l'amendement mais je note
que pas du tout pas du tout donc c'est
bon Monsieur Charles de Courson vous
avez la parole
oui
notre problème notre notre collègue a
raison de poser la question du périmètre
par rapport à celui d'argile Arco parce
que vous ne parlez madame le rapporteur
dans votre réponse quand que du l311
tiret 2
mais le 311-2 renvoie aux 311-3 or dans
les catégories il y en a
il y en a 20 je sais plus combien 30 je
crois 27 28 29 30 vous avez je vous cite
quelques exemples les présidents de
société coopératives de banque les
salariés au titre des sommes ou
avantages mentionnés au première Linéa
les entrepreneurs salariés les
entrepreneurs salariés associés vous
avez les administrateurs des groupements
mutualistes les présidents et dirigeants
de société donc je pense que notre
collègue a raison est-ce que vous êtes
bien sûr que
tous les catégories il y en a plus de 30
du
311-3 sont bien
devront adhérer à l'agir Arrco si je
rappelle que l'argile Arco c'est
paritaire et que la JR Carco avait exclu
certaines catégories
alors est-ce que vous pourriez nous
éclairer sur cette question
très bien la parole est à Monsieur
sangsue
je vous donne le micro allez-y merci
madame la Présidente juste deux petites
choses sur l'agir Carco c'est un débat
intéressant puisque le président du
corps en a parlé lors de son audition
commune conjointe commission des
finances commission des affaires
sociales le 19 janvier c'est un régime
donc une caisse qui est extrêmement
excellentaire donc j'aimerais bien que
Madame la rapporteur puisse nous
expliquer un peu comment dans le cadre
de ce projet de loi de finance de la
sécurité sociale rectificatif il serait
possible avec les partenaires sociaux
qui le demandent de reverser en pension
cet excédent qui si je me rappelle
avoisine les 160 milliards je crois donc
on est on est sur des sommes
considérables donc c'est quand même
quelque chose qui serait intéressant
ensuite sur la question qui a posé
monsieur Ruffin parce que il a raison il
y a un problème aujourd'hui de comment
ça va se passer dans le pays demain
par rapport à une un projet de loi
extrêmement minoritaire moi je veux pas
je veux pas en rajouter je vais juste
vous faire parler quelqu'un que vous
connaissez bien
très bien monsieur le député c'est bien
revenons s'il vous plaît à nos boutons à
l'amendement
il me reste 40 secondes le président de
la République
et oui on est en commission et alors et
alors
le président de la République le
président de la République le 22 avril
2022 lors de son élection a bien dit que
ça l'obligeait le résultat et qu'il
savait que près d'un Français sur deux
qui avait voté pour lui n'avait pas voté
pour son programme ne l'oubliez pas ne
l'oublier jamais
bien monsieur turquois
oui merci Madame Président je voudrais
d'abord répondre sur la forme avant de
répondre sur le fond parce que
les oppositions et notamment monsieur
Ruffin tout à l'heure c'est par
l'outrans qu'il essaie de nous
convaincre
si vous la violence et nous trans
j'ai demandé ce matin et j'ai toujours
pas de réponse qu'on me montre parce que
je crois beaucoup à la valeur de
l'exemple qu'on me montre un pays qui a
un système de retraite aussi large par
répartition avec ce niveau de de
retraite par répartition et comme au
démontre que dans ce pays on part en
retraite à 62 ans si on me fait cette
démonstration alors je pourrais
peut-être revoir ma ma réflexion sur le
sujet nous nous on a une conviction
c'est que si on ne fait rien ce système
de répartition qui est une chance pour
notre pays qui est une chance pour nos
salariés il va s'écrouler de lui-même
soit il s'écroule soit ce qui est écrit
dans le rapport du corps le le niveau de
vie des retraités va s'écrouler par
rapport au niveau de vie des actifs je
crois pas que c'est ce qu'on souhaite
donc dans ce cas là montrer démontrez-le
plutôt que de crier sans juste pour
impressionner sans sans argumenter
concernant le périmètre de la JR kaco
j'entends vos arguments madame la
rapporteur j'ai des petits doutes mais
c'est très technique je partage
l'analyse de notre collègue donc je suis
d'accord je vais le retirer sur la
commission mais d'ici la séance je vais
faire expertiser ce point là pour
vérifier qu'il n'y ait pas de il y a pas
d'erreur dans les affiliations donc je
retire la maman
très bien
ensuite monsieur Benz de toute façon
l'amendement est retiré mais bon
retirez très bien non monsieur Benz
pardon je vous donne le micro pardon
monsieur le député
merci madame le Président en quelques
instants parce que j'ai pas eu
l'occasion de réagir par rapport à nos
aux propos de notre collègues Thibault
Bazin sur le CESU simplement parce
qu'ils mettaient dans le même sac
Assemblée nationale Senna et ses œufs
mais la grosse différence de fond c'est
que l'Assemblée le Sénat ce sont des
chambres élus démocratiquement ce qui
n'est pas le cas du CESU donc je pense
pas qu'on puisse les mettre sur le même
le même niveau et ensuite par rapport à
la nups parce que quand j'évoquais la
suppression du régime de retrait du CESU
parce que nous en l'occurrence on est
favorable à la suppression du CESU tout
court la nuit pesto fusquet s'offusquer
mais on en a bien vérifié et en
l'occurrence Jean-Luc Mélenchon lui-même
proposait la suppression du CESU donc en
réalité Jean-Luc Mélenchon Mélenchon est
d'accord avec nous
très bien monsieur Delaporte non très
bien Madame madame Adam puis monsieur
Bazin madame Adam vous avez la parole
madame la députée
merci madame la Présidente
j'avoue que les propos outranciers de
mon collègue qui appelle à la résistance
qui traite madame la rapporteur
d'extrémies me heurte profondément la
violence du vocabulaire employé
contribue à libérer des instincts les
plus primaires à contester la démocratie
en place en lui autant la légitimité des
urnes est-il besoin de vous rappeler que
la démocratie ne consiste pas à
invectiver sans fin vos collègues mais
bien à vous exprimer dans un cadre
républicain quelle est l'Assemblée
nationale a exprimer la défense de vos
positions de manière sereine et de
manière contradictoire en réalité et
nous le regrettons vous rêvez vous rêvez
de scènes insurrectionnelles vous rêvez
de chaos vous rêvez que l'Assemblée
nationale se transforme en ZAD et ça
c'est inacceptable vous appelez à la
domination de la voix de fait sur l'état
de droit vous rêvez ainsi
que le principe même de notre République
soit bafoué il est temps cher collègue
de cesser d'inoculer le virus de la
méfiance de surfer sur le malaise social
d'amplifier les peurs et de dramatiser
les imaginaires parlons retraite
travaillons travaillons parlons retraite
faisons le collectivement dans
l'apaisement faisons évoluer la réforme
juste et nécessaire que nous proposons
très bien Madame la Députée parlons
retraite avec Monsieur Bazin oui moi je
voudrais revenir sur sur ces alinéas 34
et 33 34 et 35 parce que se pose la
question de l'assiette de cotisation un
syndrome des métiers qui sont évoqués
d'ailleurs dans ces alinéas de l'article
l3713 ont souvent une assiette
faible pour leur cotisations ce qui
amène d'ailleurs à des problématiques de
retraite à l'issue
or dans l'exposé des motifs page 12 de
cet article 1 il est fait mention que
des travaux seront conduits en 2023 dans
la perspective du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 alors sa m'inquiète parce qu'on est
déjà à l'article 1 mais on renvoie déjà
au plfs pour 2024
donc parce que c'est les mesures
nécessiteront à terme de revoir les
circuits de financement des des circuits
financiers de financement de ces régimes
on on voit bien aujourd'hui que un
écueil dans le projet qui nous est
présenté c'est que sur l'assiette de
cotisation notamment des indépendants ça
a pas été codifié est-ce que Madame la
rapporteur alors que vous êtes la
rapporteur général du PLFSS qui a déjà
eu des travaux il y a 3 ans sur le sujet
est-ce que on pourra d'ici la séance
avoir une codification sur l'assiette de
cotisation de manière à y voir un peu
plus clair parce que un certain nombre
de ses professions qui sont visées à cet
article qui ne serait donc pas concerné
par le transfert pour autant vu qu'elle
bosse beaucoup et certaines comptes pas
leurs heures elles bossent beaucoup plus
que 35 heures par semaine mais ont des
petites retraites on puisse répondre à
cette ambition de leur donner au moins
85 % du SMIC net et je crois que c'est
quand même très important aujourd'hui de
réussir cet objectif si on veut
valoriser le travail faut aussi
valoriser ceux qui ont travaillé toute
leur vie et là on a un trou dans la
raquette qui nous faut travailler
très bien la parole est à Madame
Rousseau
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
répondre à Monsieur turquois tout à
l'heure qui disait mais dans quel pays
on peut travailler à 62 ans j'ai envie
de lui dire la France et
précisément le système de retraite dans
lequel nous sommes et viable et ça a été
dit puisqu'il n'y a pas de problème de
dépenses il y a juste un problème de
recettes et il suffirait d'augmenter je
le rappelle d'important les cotisations
patronales pour arriver à l'équilibre où
il suffirait de prendre 10% des aides
aux entreprises dont tous les
économistes s'accordent pour dire que la
moitié de ces aides sont absolument
inutiles elles atteignent quand même 157
milliards d'euros par an soit un tiers
du budget de l'État donc en fait là la
question c'est juste de préserver nos
acquis ça n'est même pas encore d'aller
au-delà de ce que nous avons mais déjà
de préserver nos acquis et encore une
fois nous sommes le pays dans lequel la
retraite à 62 ans existe et viable
soyons en fiers
très bien donc je l'amendement est
retiré donc je le mets pas au voile non
tout le monde s'est exprimé donc on
avait décidé que c'était un par oui oui
tout à fait monsieur Ruffin s'est
exprimé longuement d'ailleurs hors sujet
mais il s'est exprimé alors la parole
est à Monsieur Monet ou à Monsieur
[Musique]
donc je le mets
s'il a été défendu si si il a été
défendu monsieur jumelles donc il a été
défendu et la vie de Madame la
rapporteur sur était défavorable donc je
mets aux voiles les amandes
à son silence mais c'était déjà fait
dans la discussion qu'on a eu tout à
l'heure je mets on voit l'amendement
3828 qui est pour qui est contre il est
rejeté je mets aux voiles amendement
suivant qui est pour qui est contre il
est rejeté nous arrivons à trois
amendements pouvant être soumis à une
discussion commune monsieur Guedj vous
avez la parole pour le 886
oui madame la Présidente
nous avons essayé de vous convaincre du
caractère inopportun de la fermeture de
ces régimes spéciaux nous vous proposons
avec cet amendement
de
décider que la date de fermeture de
l'ensemble de ces régimes spéciaux ne
soient pas fixé de manière arbitraire
comme vous le faites au premier
septembre 2023 mais qu'elle puisse être
prise à l'issue d'une concertation avec
les organisations syndicales et
patronales et ce faisant nous essayons
de faire vivre ce que vous piétinez la
démocratie sociale tout à l'heure nous
avons eu un échange intéressant c'est
souvent le cas avec notre collègue
Astrid Panossian Bouvet qui nous disait
c'est la démocratie politique qui prime
tout en saluant je l'en remercie
l'ampleur du mouvement social qui
s'était exprimé le 19 janvier et qui
sera j'en suis convaincu encore un peu
plus important beaucoup plus importante
demain mais voyez-vous dans l'histoire
singulière de notre pays il y a la
démocratie politique évidemment et la
légitimité de celles et ceux qui
exercent le mandat parlementaire mais il
y a aussi la force du mouvement social
la force de la démocratie sociale et de
une association des organisations
syndicales vous nous martelez que vous
avez la légitimité démocratique parce
que le Président de la République aurait
été élu avec dans son programme cette
réforme des retraites vous savez que ce
n'est pas vrai que son élection ne
procède pas de la validation de son de
son programme et puis ce que vous voulez
ignorer l'importance du lien entre la
démocratie sociale et la démocratie
politique moi je vais vous citer un
responsable politique qui a su faire la
jonction entre les deux c'est Léon Blum
dans l'échelle dans à l'échelle humaine
il fait cette synthèse la démocratie
politique ne sera pas viable si elle ne
s'épanouit pas en démocratie sociale et
la démocratie sociale ne serait être ni
réel ni stable si elle ne se fondait pas
sur une démocratie politique cet
amendement vous propose au moins de
corriger votre rouleau compresseur de la
pseudo légitimité uniquement
démocratique en associant aussi le
mouvement social très bien Madame la
rapporteur
votre avis sur cet amendement 886 qui
recule la date d'entrée en vigueur comme
les différents amendements sur chacun
des régimes spéciaux que nous avons
discuté et pour lesquels on était
défavorable et Monsieur Guedj nous avons
en tant que parlementaire une légitimité
aussi
démocratique législatives
très bien vous avez fini madame la
rapporteur général oui donc j'ai deux
demandes de parole monsieur jumelles et
Monsieur Delaporte et Monsieur Rufin et
Monsieur ménager oui tout à l'heure vous
avez souri j'allais dire bêtement c'est
pas gentil vous avez souri rapidement
lorsque mon collègue Ruffin
s'est présenté comme un modéré
face à l'extrême violence de votre
réforme mais je veux réinsister
là-dessus mon inquiétude c'est que vous
disposiez des outils juridiques pour
passer en force avec cette mauvaise
réforme pour l'imposer seul contre tous
au peuple français
si vous faites cela vous allez nourrir
une colère noire une colère sombre une
humiliation qui vous reviendra à la
figure comme un boomerang nous vous
proposons un autre chemin celui non pas
seulement d'écouter le peuple français
mais de l'entendre et nous le faisons
alors des fois vous devez me trouver un
peu trop raide un peu trop rude un peu
trop cash mais à côté de la colère des
habitants que je représente c'est rien
c'est rien du tout je vous assure ils
ont pris comme une violence extrême
votre réforme qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
les gens ils sont allés sur le
simulateur
de votre mauvaise réforme l'aide à
domicile la décortiqueuse de coquille la
trieuse de verre chez moi Le Verrier au
bouchot le charisme et puis ils se sont
dit à quelle sauce je vais manger et je
vous assure que passer le simulateur la
violence qui était la leur la colère qui
était à l'heure c'est rien à côté des
mots polis et policiers que nous prenons
sont dans cette commission ce n'est rien
alors nous pensons que notre
responsabilité c'est de porter cette
colère ici nous pensons que il est
légitime et juste que les organisations
syndicales puissent traduire cette
colère dans la rue si vous n'entendez
aucune des deux ni la nôtre ici en
commission ni celle des organisations
syndicales dans la rue alors vous prenez
une vraie responsabilité
d'une république émiettée d'une
république éclatée d'une république qui
perd son sens parce qu'elle n'incarne
plus un état qui prend soin un état qui
protège et un état qui rassemble
merci madame la Présidente c'est
amendement il a justement le mérite de
lutter contre ce que Pierre Cernat
appelle l'intolérance avec ce qui ne
cadre pas avec le juste milieu
arbitrairement proclamé vous savez c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'extrême centre
l'extrême centre c'est finalement une
manière de décréter que il y aurait une
bonne réforme dans l'absolu et nous ce
que nous disons et ce que nous défendons
c'est la vertu de la démocratie sociale
la démocratie sociale c'est finalement
ce qui fonde notre système social et
notamment le paritarisme et cet
amendement il vise juste parce que on
considère que c'est important de
discuter à concerter avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
et non pas ce que disait madame la
rapporteur a reporté il vise à concerter
mais si même la concertation vous fait
peur
si même le principe du paritarisme vous
fait peur alors la démocratie vous fait
peur et c'est bien cela le sujet la
démocratie c'est la voix du peuple la
voix du peuple elle peut s'exprimer de
différentes manières dans l'entreprise
dans la rue ou à l'Assemblée à chaque
fois elle est légitime et je vous
demande de l'entendre
monsieur
puis madame la Présidente c'est
simplement pour répondre à notre
collègue Adam tout à l'heure qui nous a
dit vous souhaitez l'insurrection je
voudrais préciser ce que nous souhaitons
mon collègue Ruffin tout à l'heure vous
a dit que 52% des Français souhaitaient
qu'il y ait une explosion sociale il
faut prendre ça avec avec calme et il
faut regarder ce qui se passe dans le
pays il y a beaucoup de colère une
colère qui vient à la fois de la réforme
des retraites que vous voulez imposer
mais une colère qui est aussi due au
fait que désormais la situation sociale
est extrêmement compliquée que les
factures d'électricité de gaz augmentent
que des gens sont dans l'incapacité de
payer les factures de gaz et
d'électricité et que les salaires eux
n'augmentent pas et il y a l'impression
partagée par une large partie du peuple
français que face à cela et bien pour
les riches il y a toujours de l'argent
vous leur avez encore fait 8 milliards
d'euros de cadeaux fiscaux avec un 49-3
et donc cette situation là provoque de
la colère et nous ce que nous faisons
c'est vous alerter sur la colère qui
existe dans le peuple français et sur le
risque que cela se transforme en une
explosion sociale mais il ne faut jamais
avoir de mépris néanmoins pour la
volonté populaire collègue enfin vous
siégé dans cette assemblée et nous sions
dans cette assemblée du fait
d'insurrection peut-être l'oubliez-vous
mais trois de nos République sont nés
d'insurrection la première la deuxième
et d'une certaine manière la quatrième
avec la libération de la ville de Paris
qui était le fait d'une insurrection et
quand vous dites cela quand vous refusez
de voir que la colère populaire peut
s'exprimer au bout d'un moment d'une
manière qui sort des cadres qui sont
ceux que nous avons créé avec l'histoire
précisément pour régler les problèmes
qui sont ceux de notre pays et bien vous
êtes à côté de la plaque à mon avis et
n'oubliez jamais la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen de 1793
qui disait à son article 35 quand le
gouvernement viole les droits du peuple
l'insurrection est pour le peuple est
pour chaque portion du peuple le plus
sacré des droits et le plus
indispensable des devoirs notre peuple à
la mémoire longue de cette histoire là
ne l'oubliez pas et nous ce que nous
faisons c'est vous dire de faire très
attention parce que précisément il y a
de la tension dans le peuple français la
parole est à Monsieur ménager
merci madame la Présidente je souhaitais
répondre juste à Monsieur turquois alors
je vais pas dire vous avez menti mais on
va dire vous vous utilisez une
contre-vérité depuis des semaines sur
pour essayer de convaincre les Français
de soutient ça très fort en disant si on
ne fait rien les pensions vont baisser
mais vous prenez souvent exemple sur des
modèles étrangers on prend le modèle
suédois dans le modèle suédois et c'est
le directeur général de sécurité sociale
qui vous l'a indiqué
92% des pensions des femmes ont baissé
avec le report de l'âge légal
72% des pensions des hommes ont elles
aussi baissé donc à un moment vous
pouvez pas répéter 40 fois un mensonge
et ça va pas en faire une vérité donc
arrêtez avec cela parce que en fait
c'est c'est simple en fait n'importe
quel enfant pourrait le comprendre
c'est-à-dire qu'il y en a un certain
nombre puisqu'il y a déjà un Français
sur deux qui n'arrivera pas à l'âge de
la retraite qui n'arrive pas à l'âge de
la retraite au travail aujourd'hui
il y en aura un grand nombre qui
n'auront pas leur retraite à taux plein
auront une retraite des côtés il y en
aura aussi qui auront plus la surcotte
dont il bénéficier aujourd'hui donc
arrêtez à un moment parce que déjà ça ne
marche plus encore là à l'instant un
sondage prouve avec un sondage à risque
qui vient de tomber monte une hausse de
l'opposition à cette réforme donc à un
moment les Français ne sont pas idiots
vous ne pouvez pas les prendre pour des
ions en répétant continuellement des
mensonges il se rendent bien compte
c'est simple ils ont fait le calcul ils
ont regardé ils sont allés sur les sur
les comparateurs voilà ils ont été sur
sur internet ils se sont bien rendus
compte qu'au final ça ne préservera
absolument pas leur pension au contraire
ils vont avoir une baisse assez
importante de leur pension et puis c'est
quand même être totalement hors-sol pour
imaginer que des maçons des Carreleurs
des couvreurs mon père et couvre je le
sais pertinemment il est déjà usé à 59
ans il a les genoux qui doublent de
volume le soir à un moment il pourra pas
aller jusqu'à 64 ans donc à un moment
stop stop aller sur le terrain allez
vous rendre compte moi je m'en fiche
totalement pour moi moi j'ai fait des
études j'ai commencé assez tard sur le
marché du travail pareil ça changera
rien du tout pour moi c'est très fort
mais à un moment aller sur le terrain
allez voir ceux qui souffrent et vous
vous rendrez compte qu'ils n'arriveront
pas à 64 ans et vous vous rendrez compte
que leur proportions baisseront
très bien donc je donne la parole à
Monsieur Éric allouzet
oui le plus simplement possible
finalement c'est assez logique que nous
concitoyens se réjouissent pas à l'idée
qu'on leur annonce qu'il va falloir
faire un effort supplémentaire et
travailler quelques mois peut-être un an
pour peut-être deux pour certains pas
pour 40% des Français qui resteront à
l'âge de 62 ans du fait des critères de
pénibilité et au fond d'eux au fond
d'eux les Français même s'ils sont 75% à
ne pas vouloir de cette réforme 50%
d'entre eux savent qu'il faut une
réforme et au fond d'eux et au fond de
vous-même même ceux de l'opposition ici
vous savez très bien qu'il faut faire
cette cette réforme quand les mirages
que vous présentez ce seront dissipés
des fausses solutions que vous donnez
aux Français et que vous retombez sur
terre et que vous ouvrez les yeux vous
le savez très bien aucun pays en Europe
n'a pu échapper à l'augmentation de
l'âge de la retraite
certains pays n'a pu échapper à
simplement l'allongement du nombre de
trimestres comme la réforme Touraine que
les socialistes s'assument j'espère mais
même ça ça ne suffit pas et voilà c'est
ça la réalité et vous savez que le corps
dans ses prévisions y compris avec les
déficits a déjà intégré les 64 ans dans
les prévisions du corps il y a les 64
ans de la réforme Touraine et puis pour
conclure je vais vous livrer quand même
une réflexion je pense qu'il faut lire
il faut relire Michel Rocard
il faut relire Michel Rocard en 1999
donc 18 ans 18 ans après la réforme de
1981 déclarait dans l'événement le 25
novembre 1999 je vais vous confier un
petit secret j'ai été l'un des rares à
déclaré en conseil des ministres que
c'était une folie que c'était une folie
lui la dit qu'une fois moi je le répète
je savais je savais que ce serait une
conquête temporaire temporaire et
dangereuse si vous ouvrez les yeux vous
le savez au fond de vous et beaucoup de
Français qui sont pas contents je le
constate le savent très bien eux-mêmes
très bien la parole est à Monsieur la
parole est à Monsieur Isaac Sibille
s'il vous plaît monsieur Corbière vous
n'avez pas la parole on a rappelé merci
merci
s'il vous plaît seul monsieur le député
Isaac Sibyl à la parole merci
on a évoqué le modèle suédois il y a
quelques secondes le modèle suédois
c'est un double un modèle qui est par
répartition et par capitalisation et
c'est pour ça que ce modèle suédois a
été un échec ce que nous proposons aux
Français ce n'est pas un système par
capitalisation contrairement suédois
c'est un système c'est un système pour
sauver le système par répartition je ne
vous comprends pas monsieur Ruffin
comment pouvez-vous jouer sur les peurs
à la parole s'il vous plaît ne jouez pas
sur les peurs la vraie problématique
c'est la survie de notre système par
répartition
actuellement notre système par
interdiction est des visiteurs de 30
milliards tous les ans il en a été
convenu entre les l'assurance vieillesse
et l'État ce n'est plus supportable dans
le sens où ces 30 milliards qu'est-ce
qu'il est finance c'est la dette assez
30 milliards vous voulez rajouter 15
milliards ce système n'est pas
supportable donc ça n'a rien à voir
système suédois nous ce qu'on souhaite
c'est sauver le régime par répartition
et je suis étonné que vous ne souhaitez
pas sauver ce système
très bien Madame tailler paulian
merci madame la Présidente mais monsieur
le député mes deux collègues précédents
qui sont exprimés avant moi je tiens à
leur dire que les gens s'ils ne sont pas
d'accord c'est pas parce qu'ils sont
égoïstes et qui ne penseraient qu'à leur
qu'à leur vie ils auraient raison
d'ailleurs ça suffirait
mais c'est parce qu'ils en ont
ras-le-bol ras-le-bol qu'on leur dise
qu'il faut payer votre politique et que
c'est à eux de la payer ras-le-bol qu'on
leur dise que les tags sur les super
profits c'est pas possible ras-le-bol de
savoir que pour régler les déficits
conjoncturels du régime des retraites 2%
de la fortune des 40 les plus riches
suffirait ras-le-bol de voir que vous
refusez vous refusez de partager les
richesses et en fait vous dites que vous
voulez sauver le système des retraites
mais c'est faux ce que vous voulez
sauver c'est la fortune des plus riches
et pourquoi pourquoi vous voulez faire
ça
il y a pas les gentils et les méchants
c'est parce que vous pensez vous pensez
que que les riches ça ruissell mais
c'est faux c'est faux tous les
économistes le savent et les Françaises
et les Français aussi donc non ils ne
sont pas d'accord ils ne sont pas
d'accord encore une fois non pas par
égoïsme même s'il devrait peut-être et
que cela suffirait quand il voit leurs
parents brisés par le travail quand il
voit les chômeurs de longue durée plus
de 55 ans qui ne retrouve pas et se
retrouver RSA ça suffirait mais aussi ce
qui motive cette colère c'est ce
sentiment d'injustice qui est telle
enfin vous le savez vous l'entendez
alors revenez à la raison
très bien donc sur ce madame la
rapporteur vous souhaitez intervenir
juste un point rapidement parce que
Monsieur ménager a dit qu'il n'y avait
pas de diminution des pensions mais le
corps le rapport du corps le dit qui a
une diminution des pensions à terme
d'autre part les pensions avec cette
réforme vont augmenter notamment chez
les femmes puisque vous avez interpellé
sur les femmes puisque la génération 72
verra une augmentation de pension à plus
de 2% 2,2 exactement
et bien donc je mets aux voix cet
amendement qui est reçu Navi défavorable
qui est pour qui est contre il est
rejeté je mets aux voix mes chers
collègues nous en arrivons à la fin donc
de l'examen de cet article premier et
donc je mets aux voix l'article premier
ainsi modifié qui est pour
très bien qui est contre
il est non il est adopté pardon
l'article premier est adopté alors mes
chers collègues on en arrive tout à
l'heure le sujet a été évoqué sur
l'emploi des seniors avec la création
d'un index senior article 2 et enfin on
va aborder un autre sujet j'espère que
vous allez examiner les amendements et
ne pas faire de hors sujet et on
commence avec un amendement des
amendements de suppression de l'article
2 et je passe la parole à Monsieur
dareville
oui merci madame la Présidente alors
pourquoi avons-nous droit à cet article
dans la loi pourquoi avons-nous droit à
cette index des seniors parce que lors
de du débat précédent sur les retraites
ou déjà il y avait une première
tentative de la macronie de d'abîmer
notre droit à la retraite et bien un des
arguments qui avait fait capoter la
chose c'est que il y a un peu moins
d'une personne sur deux qui liquide sa
pension qui n'est déjà plus
dans l'emploi et donc il paraissait
évident que vouloir allonger la durée de
travail à les conduire à ce que ce
nombre grossisse et donc c'est
évidemment un écueil considérable dans
le dispositif que vous que vous prévoyez
donc depuis quelques mois maintenant on
entend le gouvernement faire vraiment
une priorité de l'emploi des seniors
après avoir je le rappelle quand même
des tricoter le droit du travail et
précariser avec les ordonnances après
avoir pris un certain nombre de mesures
qui fragilisait évidemment celles et
ceux qui travaillent donc cette index de
quoi s'agit-il en fait il s'agit d'une
mesure d'affichage
il s'agit d'une mesure d'affichage qui
n'aura aucun effet concret sur les
conditions d'emploi des des salariés
seniors et donc avec aucune obligation
au bout du compte autre que celle de
rendre l'index public donc franchement
bon c'est beaucoup de bruit pour rien
cette affaire là et évidemment
évidemment je crois qu'il faudrait
regarder de plus près cette réalité
sociale qui fait que d'abord il n'est
pas normal qu'un certain nombre de
salariés au bout de leur carrière soit
mis dehors alors qu'ils peuvent
continuer à travailler mais aussi qu'un
certain d'entre eux qui ne le peuvent
pas se retrouvent dans une situation
d'entre-deux qui n'est pas prise en
compte et que vous allez aggraver avec
votre réforme en décalant l'âge de
départ parce qu'un plus grand nombre
d'entre eux risque de se retrouver dans
dans cette situation et d'en souffrir
très bien monsieur le député monsieur
Petavy
merci madame la Présidente
ce projet de loi en temps misé sur
l'emploi des seniors par le biais de
l'unique et seul outil de l'index senior
un index qui n'oblige même pas les
entreprises à avoir des résultats
satisfaisants il suffit juste de le
publier pour échapper à la menthe ce
projet de loi c'est donc contenter
d'imiter au rabais l'index égalité
professionnelle qui a pourtant prouvé
son incapacité à lutter contre les
pratiques discriminantes des entreprises
ce qu'on en commun ces deux index c'est
bien l'impression et le flou quand à la
définition des indicateurs qui a permis
aux entreprises pour l'index-égalité
professionnelle d'obtenir des notes très
élevées pourtant parfois bien éloignées
de la réalité
l'index d'égalité professionnelle avait
au moins le mérite d'établir des
sanctions en cas de résultat
insuffisants aussi faible soit-elle dans
le cas de l'index senior que vous
proposez il suffira aux entreprises de
publier l'index pour échapper aux
sanctions même avec une note de 2 sur 20
cette index senior en l'état actuel ce
cantonnera à faire office de faire
valoir pour des entreprises peu
scrupuleuses qui considère les seniors
comme des salariés jetables le grand
plan pour l'emploi des seniors du
gouvernement se résume donc à une
coquille vide
alors que l'urgence est là et les
discriminations agissent sont criante
63% des salariés
âgés de 44 à 55 ans en recherche
d'emploi n'ont pas été sollicités par
des recruteurs au cours des 6 derniers
mois le groupe écologiste appelle donc à
la suppression de ce dispositif qui
comme l'index égalité professionnelle
sera lui aussi des tournées par des
entreprises qui ne bénéficieront
d'aucune sanction financière nous
appelons donc à la mise en place d'une
politique réellement ambitieuse aussi
bien pour un travail digne que pour un
repos digne pour les seniors
très bien je vais passer la parole à
présent à Madame Rousseau
merci madame la Présidente alors l'index
est présenté comme la seule et unique
mesure qui s'adresse aux entreprises en
réalité toute la contrainte porte sur
les salariés aucune sur les entreprises
c'est bien un des défauts majeurs de
cette réforme et il est présenté comme
uniquement incitatif c'est à dire pas
contraignant sans sanction et à la fin
c'est comme vous savez dans les
restaurants cette ces assiettes où il y
a une feuille de salade pour décorer
mais en fait c'est c'est index et la
feuille de salade de la réforme des
retraites si Hassan n'a aucune espèce
d'utilité et de et aucune espèce
d'impact transformant pour les
entreprises c'est uniquement de la
décoration si on voulait vraiment
s'attaquer à l'emploi des seniors alors
on ferait quelque chose de différent et
certainement pas un indice à un index
comme celui-ci qui ira totalement sa
cible puisque rien a priori ne sera sur
le déroulé des carrières rien sur les
horaires de travail rien sur la
pénibilité la France est un les pays qui
se distinguent des autres pays européens
par l'ampleur des troubles
musculo-squelettiques par des conditions
de travail plus difficiles qu'ailleurs
et par des taux d'incapacité et
d'invalidité lui aussi supérieur à la
moyenne européenne donc alors voilà
finalement une feuille de salade dans un
plat dans un plat de restaurant ça sert
pas à grand chose on vous propose de
l'enlever et de véritablement travailler
sur le travail
très bien la parole est à Monsieur cloué
c'est vous allez-y madame oui c'est
Madame Oziol du cookie le défend
non alors cet article 2 est un bel
exemple d'application de la feuille de
route du Medef qui impose aux personnes
de plus de 60 ans la triple peine
première peine le gouvernement s'apprête
à imposer aux gens de plus de 60 ans de
travailler jusqu'à 63 64 67 ans cette
idée même n'est jamais remise en
question on parle de travail des seniors
comme s'il s'agissait d'un fait naturel
qui va de soi qui coule de source on
parle pour résumer d'aide-soignante
d'éboueurs de charisme de prof qui vont
bosser jusqu'à 64 ans deuxième peine il
sera impossible de toucher quoi que ce
soit si on souhaite partir avant celles
et ceux qui partent aujourd'hui à 62 ans
à la retraite devront cotiser deux ans
supplémentaires sous peine de tomber
dans le sas de précarité qui pour info
concernée en 2021 la moitié des 61 ans
c'est à dire que la moitié des gens qui
ont dépassé 60 ans ne sont ni en emploi
ni en retraite ils sont au RSA dans la
validité au chômage dans ce sas de
précarité et alors la cerise sur le
gâteau la troisième peine le
gouvernement a reculé en supprimant de
son texte l'introduction de pénalité si
une entreprise ne recrute pas de
personnes dites seniors donc en
envisageant même pas une seule forme de
sanction Emmanuel Macron entend faire
peser le poids de leur non-emploi au
seniors or on sait bien ce que valent
les demandes exprimées par le
gouvernement on a vu Bruno Le Maire
demander aux fournisseur d'énergie de
faire un effort s'ils le veulent bien
tout cela autour d'une galette des rois
tremble puyanée et bien ici c'est pareil
la seule mesure prévu concerne la
publication d'indicateurs quel
indicateurs et sur quoi on ne sait pas
donc ce qui est proposé ce que vous
proposez c'est une désorganisation
généralisée qui n'aura pas pour autre
effet que l'usure des corps des esprits
des personnes sans aucun contrôle donc
effectivement nous ne partageons pas
votre vision de la société dans laquelle
le travail et le l'horizon jusqu'au bout
de la vie en attendant que ce projet
soit abandonné nous proposons de
supprimer cet article
très bien la parole est à Madame Garin
merci madame la Présidente donc avec cet
article vous nous proposez la mise en
place d'un index pour relatif au taux
d'emploi des salariés de plus de 55 ans
j'aimerais bien rappeler que le taux
d'emploi des 55 64 ans en France il est
en deçà de la moyenne européenne et il y
a rien strictement rien dans l'étude
d'impact mené par le gouvernement qui
nous permet de penser que l'index
permettrait ne serait-ce qu'un peu
d'améliorer ce taux d'emploi c'est aussi
l'occasion de rappeler que parmi les
retraités nés en 1950 il y a un tiers
qui n'est plus en emploi l'année
précédant la retraite c'est le cas de
37% des femmes et de 28% des hommes et
le recul de l'âge de la retraite ne va
faire qu'accentuer cet effet les fameux
les fameuses personnes qui sont mis en
emploi ni en retraite et qui sont dans
un espèce de sas de précarité que vous
n'allez faire que gonfler je rappellerai
que c'est le président de la République
lui-même qui en 2019 avait dit que tant
qu'on n'avait pas réglé le problème du
chômage dans notre pays ce serait
hypocrite de décaler l'âge légal
ici vous nous proposez finalement
quelque chose qui est incitatif c'est
juste de l'affichage il y a aucune
contrainte stricte on voit déjà que avec
l'index égalité ça a eu très peu
d'effets sur l'égalité en entreprise les
seuls améliorations qu'on a ce sont des
améliorations structurelles qui sont
mécaniques sur le temps long donc on a
aucune raison de croire que ça pourrait
changer quelque chose avec un index
Seigneur et donc aucune raison de le
soutenir donc nous en demandons la
suppression
très bien Madame la rapporteur votre
avis sur ses amendements merci merci
madame la Présidente alors l'article 2
n'est ni une feuille de salade ni la
feuille de route du Medef qui je le
rappelle est contre il s'agit de la
présentation d'un outil qui sera utile
pour les employeurs comme pour les
salariés pour introduire un véritable
changement culturel dont la France a
besoin puisque nous sommes en retard sur
le taux d'emploi des seniors nous avons
besoin de savoir comment dans chaque
entreprise nous pouvons améliorer les
choses aller plus loin en matière
d'intégration des salariés âgés pour
cela on a besoin de cet indicateur vous
souhaitez supprimer aussi les
négociations obligatoires dans vos
amendements raison pour lequel je serai
défavorable
très bien donc j'ai plusieurs demandes
de prise de parole madame Bonivard
merci madame la Présidente le travail
des seniors devrait être en fait le cœur
de ce de ce projet de loi et je regrette
vraiment que les amendements que nous
avons déposés avec le groupe les
républicains et quelques-uns des miens
étaient jugés et recevables c'est le
problème d'avoir choisi le plfs comme
comme véhicule ça nous prive d'un vrai
débat qui est la contrepartie acceptable
à mon avis le travail des seniors à
l'effort supplémentaire qu'on demande
aux Français on avait proposé des
amendements sur le droit à l'aménagement
du temps de travail à temps partiel de
manière choisie la baisse des
cotisations patronales à partir de 60
ans le déplafonnement du CPF à partir de
50 ans pour avoir de vrais formations
pour les seniors et des idées sur la
valorisation du mentorat et du tutorat
en entreprise pour que les personnes qui
travailleront jusqu'à 64 ans est un sens
à leur activité et qu'elle puisse le
faire de la meilleure manière possible
pour l'entreprise et pour la société je
rappelle effectivement que le Medef en
outre est insatisfait de cette index
puisque on va comparer des entreprises
de typologie très différentes donc voilà
c'est un regret et un vrai manque et
j'espère qu'on pourra avoir un vrai
débat dans l'hémicycle sur l'emploi des
seniors parce que c'est une lacune nous
devons la combler si nous souhaitons
avancer très bien Madame pannoucian
Bouvet vous avez la parole
pas une réponse suffisante et nous
sommes ici et c'est d'ailleurs été dit
par la première ministre l'index senior
est une première réponse mais ce n'est
clairement pas une réponse suffisante
c'est une première réponse pour nous
permettre à tous entreprises et branche
professionnelle pour prendre enfin
conscience de ses pratiques qui sont
acculturés dans la tête des des chefs
d'entreprise comme des salariés depuis
50 ans mais ce n'est pas suffisant et je
pense que la Finlande a montré que
c'était pas une fatalité elle a démarré
avec un taux d'activité qui était plus
bas que le nôtre au début des années
2000 pour les seniors et les maintenant
à des tours records autour de 70% pour
les seniors de 61 64 ans et ça passe par
aussi des sujets qui ont va falloir
traiter aussi dans la loi travail et
France travail qui sera proposé par
notre ministre du Travail qui sont
autour de la formation professionnelle
parce qu'on allait aussi ce deuxième
paradoxe c'est qu'on a une formation
professionnelle qui s'occupe plus des
cadres que des ouvriers des employés et
des travailleurs de plus de 50 ans il y
a également un autre un sujet sur les
retraites progressives qui va aussi
permettre de pouvoir entamer cette
dernière partie de carrière en
transition ce sont des très bonnes
avancées dans ce texte donc salut on les
indexes seniors pour ce que c'est c'est
nécessaire mais pas suffisant très bien
Madame la Députée Monsieur Charles de
Courson
mes chers collègues en préliminaires je
voudrais dire que cet article 2 est un
cavalier il n'a rien à voir avec la
réforme
et je vous parie que si ce texte allait
à son terme il sera cet article sera
censuré par le Conseil constitutionnel
nous vous rend bien première remarque
deuxième remarque le cœur de l'avenir de
nos retraites c'est notre capacité à
augmenter par voie volontaire le taux
d'emploi des travailleurs
âgés
âgés disant entre 55 et 65 or dans ce
texte dans ce projet de loi franchement
il n'y a pratiquement rien il n'y a
qu'une petite mesure qui est sur le
cumul emploi retraite puisque on cotise
au régime de retraite mais actuellement
ça n'ouvre pas de droit et dans le
projet gouvernemental ça ça va dans la
bonne direction ça ouvrira des droits
mais ce qui manque c'est
on avait d'ailleurs dit aux premières à
la première ministre 5 pistes pourquoi
est-ce qu'on module pas les cotisations
patronales en fonction de l'âge on l'a
fait pour les jeunes c'est d'ailleurs
une proposition de la CGPME par exemple
et d'autres donc c'est pas simplement
une proposition si vous voulez
de
nez de tel ou tel courant politique
deuxièmement la négociation obligatoire
des entreprises sur la qualité de
l'emploi des seniors c'est à dire
négociation obligatoire et de faire le
point de voir quelle mesure on peut
prendre pour éviter l'effet d'éviction
soulever par plusieurs collègues
améliorer le recours à la retraite
progressive parce que on l'a étendu au
régime public mais le vrai problème
c'est pas le régime public c'est dans le
secteur privé et d'améliorer cela
l'abondement du compte professionnel de
formation ou de mettre en place un
cliquet pour éviter que on investisse
beaucoup moins dans la formation des 35
et surtout sur les 55 60
c'est tout ça ce qu'il faudrait une
vraie politique de l'emploi des seniors
qui n'existent pas dans ce texte et
c'est pas l'index qui
améliorera en quoi que ce soit
donc tout ça pour dire favorable pour
éviter une annulation par le Conseil
constitutionnel qui serait quand même
désagréable
avec cet article 2 on est censé aborder
les mesures dites positives de cette
réforme des retraites mais franchement
et sans jeux de mots c'est index c'est
une fumisterie majeure c'est à dire que
vous venez
mettre l'accent sur un problème qui est
le problème central tout le monde est
d'accord pour le dire qui est que la
réforme des retraites d'une certaine
manière la réforme en tous les cas
l'équilibre du système des retraites
pourrait être réglé si le taux d'emploi
des seniors était sensiblement amélioré
dans le pays et là où tous les efforts
devraient converger sur cette priorité
là et il y a plusieurs pistes qui ont
été évoqués y compris par la CGPME qui
peuvent être intéressantes au lieu de se
concentrer sur comment de manière
efficace on va augmenter le taux
d'emploi des seniors vous vous agitez à
un hochet c'est un petit os à ronger qui
est donné en disant ah bah regardez on a
fait quelque chose pour l'emploi seniors
mais qui est totalement dévitalisé à
peine un quart des salariés seront
concernés par cette index vous avez des
sanctions qui restent très virtuelles
puisque ce sont des sanctions uniquement
à l'absence de publication et pas un
objet actifié d'emploi d'emploi des
seniors et donc vous voulez d'une
certaine manière équilibrée une réforme
qui ne l'est pas du tout avec une mesure
dont le président de la République est
n'oublions jamais ça parce que vous
citez en permanence Emmanuel Macron nous
on va le faire aussi de temps en temps
il y a trois ans et demi à peine que
disait-il de différents au moment de la
Réforme dites systémique sur le système
à points il disait on ne peut pas
repousser l'âge tant qu'on n'a pas
augmenté significativement le taux
d'emploi des seniors ce ne serait pas
compris le taux d'emploi des seniors n'a
pas augmenté de manière significative
depuis 2019-2020 et vous vous décidez de
repousser l'âge légal sans vous attaquer
au cœur du problème donc s'il y avait
une seule chose à faire qui pourrait
faire consensus qui pourrait faire
consensus c'est de dire faisons une loi
uniquement sur l'emploi des seniors et
voyons dans quatre ans
donc moi je demande qu'être convaincu de
cet article pour le voter bien entendu
vous si j'ai bien compris en demandant
aux entreprises de produire un index
seniors cela va régler le problème de
l'emploi des seniors
si j'ai bien compris ben c'est un peu ça
qui a marqué donc moi j'aimerais savoir
comment comment le gouvernement donc
comment vous députez qui allait voter
qui avait proposé ce cet amendement cet
article notamment comment vous allez
faire pour obliger sans sanction
financière les entreprises à embaucher
ou à garder les seniors et j'aimerais
vraiment être avoir une vraie vraie
réponse à cette question parce que je
pense que tout le monde attend et tout
le monde aimerait comprendre comment
vous allez gérer la question et l'emploi
des seniors
très bien Madame tailler Pollion merci
madame la Présidente oui effectivement
cette mesure en fait c'est le
l'hypocrisie qu'annonçait finalement
Emmanuel Macron il y a deux ans et demi
quand il disait ce serait hypocrite de
vouloir allonger la durée de travail
alors qu'on a toujours pas réglé le
problème de l'emploi des seniors et là
on sait bien qu'on l'a pas réglé donc on
prend une mesure hypocrite on essaye de
dire ah bah si on va faire un truc mais
c'est ridicule la portée en est ridicule
par rapport aux enjeux comme ça a été
dit c'est que les entreprises de plus de
300 salariés mais je crois que dans
notre pays la grande majorité des
salariés enfin en tout cas au moins près
de 50% travail dans une entreprise qui
fait moins de 300 salariés donc déjà on
a sorti de cette index qui n'est
finalement qu'une photographie la moitié
des salariés de ce pays donc on va bien
ça ne sert à rien et après on va
demander à nos inspecteurs du travail
qui sont déjà bien peu nombreux et qui
ont bien d'autres chats fouetter
notamment sur la prévention des risques
professionnels et pour éviter des
accidents du travail y compris parfois
mortels
dans les entreprises alors qu'on sait
que ça va rien changer mais là vous nous
faites des leçons sans arrêt sur
l'efficacité et l'efficience des deniers
publics mais alors pardon alors là c'est
toute catégorie franchement vous savez
très bien que ça n'aura aucun aucun
aucune espèce d'effet sur le réel et
vous mettez ça pour faire semblant voilà
c'est un article pour faire semblant ben
nous on n'a pas envie de donner caution
à cette à cette disposition qui fait
semblant d'aborder le problème de
l'emploi des salariés expérimentés donc
voilà la raison pour laquelle nous ne
pouvons nous ne pouvons que vous
proposer de la supprimer mais par contre
un vrai travail sur l'emploi des seniors
que nous réclamons depuis tant de temps
devrait être engagé et ça nécessiterait
du sérieux du temps et nous serions
évidemment à ce moment là tout à fait
prêt à engager ce travail très bien la
parole est à Monsieur sangsue merci
madame la Présidente cet article 2 il
est quand même étrange parce que c'est
un index c'est-à-dire que c'est un index
et les entreprises sont sont chargées de
produire un index de le rendre public
mais par contre ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut améliorer l'emploi des seniors ça
veut juste dire qu'il faut faire un
indicateur voilà donc c'est quand même
un peu étrange je rappelle quand même
qu'il y a une dizaine d'années il y
avait ce qu'on appelait le contrat de
génération qui était un contrat qui
était entre les dans les entreprises
avec les organisations syndicales qui
permettaient justement de regarder
comment on faisait les sorties
progressives et les entrées progressives
au sein de l'entreprise ensuite c'est
index n'empêche nullement la catastrophe
qui vient c'est à dire que tous ces
seniors qui sont virés à 57 58 59 ans
parce que on en connaît tous et qui ne
retrouve pas de boulot pour plein de
raisons d'abord parce que ils partent
avec un niveau de salaire qui est celui
d'une personne qui a travaillé pendant
des dizaines d'années il partent avec
des contraintes de mobilité bien plus
fortes que quand on a 20 ans et donc
tout ce qu'on leur propose est souvent
très en dessous de ce à quoi ils peuvent
prétendre et donc où ils se retrouvent
pour beaucoup d'entre eux ni en emploi
ni en emploi ni en retraite c'est-à-dire
au chômage en invalidité voire au RSA et
dernière chose quand même qui est
surprenante c'est qu'on a une étude
d'impact qui ne donne rien vous voyez
dans la page 23 de l'étude d'impact
impact socio sur les jeunes sans objet
c'est à dire qu'on explique qu'on
explique que l'entrée des seniors
l'augmentation de l'âge le décalage de
l'âge de la retraite n'aura aucun impact
sur les jeunes je vous rappelle que le
président du corps a eu un petit sourire
pour ne pas dire plus quand on lui a
expliqué qu'il ne fallait plus prendre
le modèle mésange qui était celui le
modèle régulièrement appliqué pour
prendre un modèle qui s'appelle approche
comptable qui permet comme par hasard
chaque fois qu'on crée un emploi senior
on crée deux emplois déjà voilà
merci madame la Présidente
d'abord je constate que nous avons tous
cette préoccupation de l'emploi de
l'employabilité des Seigneur et donc
c'est une préoccupation qui nous est
commune
l'intérêt de cet article c'est quand
même une avancée une avancée pour plus
de transparence
si on veut modifier les comportements il
faut d'abord avoir des indicateurs et
c'est un deck sera l'indicateur
qui peut être puissant
tout à l'heure on parlait de négociation
entre partenaires sociaux comment
négocier entre partenaires sociaux si on
n'a pas d'indicateur si on ne sait pas
quel est le taux d'emploi des seigneurs
de notre entreprise
donc je pense que cet indicateur ne
résoudra pas le problème de la
planabilité mais permettra de au moins
de savoir ce qu'il en est et permettra
d'améliorer
de permettre de meilleur négation entre
partenaires sociaux et en fait il
pourrait aussi avoir un rôle
d'exemplarité pour les entreprises merci
bien très bien monsieur ménager
alors on connaissait le greenwashing
c'est le French washing le gouvernement
peut-être sous les conseils de McKinsey
avant que le hall washing ça doit être
si c'est une nouveauté parce que
clairement c'est que ça c'est de la
cosmétique désolé pour l'anglicisme mais
c'est que de la cosmétique on est tous
d'accord là on va parler de ce mécanisme
alors ça coûte ça coûte pas grand chose
mais clairement ça va pas régler le
problème ça va pas régler le problème
donc on le sait moi je me vois pas
revenir sur mon territoire je vais être
honnête pour dire aux fans de 55 ans qui
viennent me voir dans ma permanence
qu'on a réglé leurs problèmes qu'on a
trouver une solution à leur chômage avec
cette index donc clairement on voit bien
que c'est du cosmétique c'est une
volonté pour le gouvernement de répondre
un petit peu à l'argument du président
de la République qui disait que c'était
hypocrite ça a été dit à plusieurs
reprises de repousser l'âge de départ à
la retraite sans avoir réglé au
préalable l'employabilité des seniors on
aurait pu pourtant faire des choses mais
c'est vrai que dans le cadre du véhicule
législatif qui nous est proposé on peut
pas proposer mais il y avait des choses
à faire sur la formation quand on sait
que un senior sur 10 seulement de plus
de 55 ans utilise son CPF il y avait des
choses à faire ce qui est triste c'est
qu'en fait excepté faire de la
communication avec cette index senior
vous donnez pas la possibilité de régler
réellement les problèmes des Français et
de régler réellement ce qui aurait pu
participer aussi à redonner confiance
notamment aux femmes moi je le sais sur
mon territoire qu'on a l'impression à 55
ans d'être totalement périmé parce que
en fait le système actuel que vous
défendez considère que ces femmes ne
sont plus en capacité de travailler on
aurait pu faire des choses pour les
accompagner pour accompagner les
entreprises aussi à les garder
malheureusement on ne pourra pas le
faire parce que un plfssr ne nous permet
pas c'est vraiment dommage madame
[Musique]
génération évoquée par Monsieur sangsue
notamment qui était cette aide aux
entreprises qui embaucha un jeune et qui
gardait un seigneur dans le même temps
la Cour des comptes avait montré son
inédit
inefficacité et donc ça c'est vrai le
dispositif a été supprimé en 2017 sur
les chiffres dont Monsieur Gad a parlé
mais d'autres aussi c'est pas un quart
des salariés qui seront concernés dans
ces entreprises de plus de 3 ans mais
bien 55% des salariés c'est des données
de l'INSEE qui se retrouvent dans les
entreprises de plus de oui mais ça fait
encore plus du coup
ce texte fait quand même
trois choses d'une part il améliore
l'information la transparence avec cette
index mais et ça n'a pas été beaucoup
discuté ici je trouve alors que ça me
paraît très important dans ce texte il y
a une obligation de négociation des
branches sur ce sujet de l'emploi des
seniors et il me semble que c'est une
mesure forte de cet article et puis
ensuite nous verrons plus tard l'article
13 sur la transition en plein retraite
enfin ma collègue Astrid panotion il a
très bien dit cet indicateur il est
nécessaire il est pas suffisant tout le
monde s'accorde à le dire mais on avait
commencé ce matin nos débats suite à un
amendement des républicains sur la mise
en perspective de l'ensemble des mesures
sur le travail et c'est évidemment aussi
pour le cadre de l'emploi des seniors
avec notamment des textes un texte à
venir sur le plein emploi et où nous
pourrons construire encore des mesures
sur
cet emploi des seniors
très bien Madame la rapporteur général
donc je mets aux voix tous ces
amendements
qui ont reçu un avis défavorable de
Madame la rapporteur qui est pour
qui est contre ils sont rejetés
amendement suivant monsieur Bazin le
7243 oui c'est un amendement
rédactionnel la présidente mais je
reprends le début de l'exposé des motifs
de cet article 2 afin de faire de
l'emploi des seniors une priorité des
entreprises j'allais dire c'est pas que
des entreprises c'est du pays pour le
coup et on voit bien aujourd'hui
tel que ça a été imaginé c'est un deck
ne va pas être la solution unique pour
favoriser le taux d'emploi des seniors
d'ailleurs tel que tel qu'il est rédigé
actuellement cet article 2 il va
peut-être poser plus de soucis qui va en
régler je pense notamment sur le secteur
sportif professionnel
l'index semble pas du tout adapté on a
un certain nombre d'équipes d'ailleurs
je on a eu une belle épopée des
handballeurs malheureusement ils ont
perdu en finale mais ça y contribué et
on le voit bien dans ses équipes
professionnelles appliquées
tel index n'aurait pas de sens et je
pense que c'est important qu'on puisse
affiner sur ce sujet là
je pense qu'il faudrait élargir la
réflexion à un véritable plan de
formation avec un parcours pour
permettre des reconversions parce qu'il
y a certains métiers c'est sûr qu'avec
l'âge c'est compliqué or on voit bien en
termes de prévention et de parcours on
n'a pas été au rendez-vous
c'est un vrai élément le deuxième
élément c'est le choc fiscal
d'incitation à l'embauche le troisième
élément c'est par rapport à la liaison
maladie professionnelle et les
cotisations que les entreprises payent
si elles recrute quelqu'un qui tout d'un
coup il y a une maladie professionnelle
qui qui apparaît c'est qu'il se retrouve
pas pénalisé sur son propre taux alors
peut-être que c'est dû à des entreprises
précédentes or là on voit bien qu'il y a
du calage et ça dépend aussi de la
branche accident du travail mardi
professionnelle et puis la retraite
progressive j'ai entendu mes collègues
tout à l'heure en parler mais en réalité
ce qui est prévu dans le projet de loi
et bien insuffisant ça a pas assez loin
puisque en fait la retraite progressive
avec l'âge qui avance il faudrait
permettre des constructions de fin de
carrière beaucoup plus souple beaucoup
plus adapté y compris en termes de
rythme et là on le voit le dispositif
sur deux ans et pas adapté on a des
comptes épargne temps parfois qui sont
très importants et qu'on pourrait
mobiliser mais c'est surtout le rapport
à nos seniors alors d'ailleurs salariés
on sait pas à quoi ça correspond
d'ailleurs ça peut poser un problème
d'intelligibilité on y reviendra tout à
l'heure mais il y a des pays où on
valorise ceux qui sont expérimentés et
il y a des pays où c'est ils apportent
de l'expérience ils pourraient
transmettre du savoir on voit bien sur
la formation à la nouvelle génération
qui arrive il y a des talents des
compétences
et je crois que c'est un vrai un
véritable élément de pouvoir donner du
sens sur ces sur cette génération qui
peut transmettre votre avis sur cet
amendement alors cet amendement vous
voulez renommer l'indicateur relatif à
l'emploi des salariés en index seniors
je vais vous demander un retrait un
retrait en faveur d'amendement dont nous
allons avoir la discussion juste après
sur la renomination des des salariés
âgés en
donc retrait
pour avancer rapidement sur le je
vous recommande mon pouvoir
être pas défendu
la pas défendu monsieur Viry il n'est
pas là
c'est vous qui voilà monsieur
c'est un amendement de mon collègue
Stéphane Viry qui est retenu dans une
autre réunion par ailleurs qui
maintenant est de le défendre il propose
de remplacer le terme salarial âgé par
un terme juridiquement plus clair et
peut-être moins péjoratif à l'égard des
personnes visées par la disposition on
est tous âgé à un moment de la vie mais
je trouverais plus plus adapté
d'utiliser cette terminologie
très bien Madame la rapporteur votre
avis non non pardon attendez on finit la
discussion commune alors amendement
suivant monsieur turquois
monsieur Vigier monsieur Isaac Sibille
qui le défend
amendement 7205
monsieur Cyril Isa pas de problème
très bien donc défendu
très bien l'amendement suivant monsieur
Bazin oui alors c'est une autre
proposition c'est de remplacer le mot
âgé par expérimenter je trouve que
d'ailleurs c'est plus valorisant de
pouvoir valoriser cette expérience et
on cherche quoi rapporteur sur le PLFSS
vous qui êtes je vous qui avez été sur
la branche ATMP par le passé je
trouverais important en matière de
transmission des commandes valoriser
l'expérience c'est pas parce qu'on est
âgé que voilà on est plutôt expérimenté
les entreprises et il y a un vrai apport
du tutorat du mentorat
très bien amendement suivant monsieur
Fuchs monsieur turquois qui le défend le
défendu
très bien amendement suivant monsieur
Bazin il est identique défendu c'est de
plus de 55 ans très bien amendement
suivant monsieur Bazin oui alors c'est
une vraie question d'ailleurs quand vous
pensez à salarié agile vous pensez à
quel âge c'est souvent d'ailleurs on se
pose la question aux enfants ils disent
c'est une personne
j'ai dit mais c'est quel âge âgé est-ce
que pour vous c'est 55 est-ce que c'est
que 57 parce que il va falloir une mise
en cohérence parce que quand on dit à un
moment qu'on est âgé les dispositifs
retraites progressif par exemple c'est
sur les deux dernières années or si on
on amène à 64 et qu'on est âgé est-ce
qu'on est âgé qu'à 62 vous rigolez
madame la Présidente mais mais c'est
important parce que on voit bien que
à mi carrière avec les rendez-vous de
prévention on pourrait en profiter aussi
pour envisager j'allais dire au-delà de
la prévention des reconversions
professionnelles sur des métiers plus
adaptés ou l'expérience pourrait être
transmise
très bien non mais c'est parce qu'à un
moment donné monsieur le député je vous
réponds c'est que pour certaines stats
on était âgés à partir de 46 ans donc
pour beaucoup on est déjà concernés par
le voilà c'est pour ça mais là on
progresse quoi là maintenant c'est 55 57
60 voyez mais à un moment donné c'était
46 ou 45 voilà
voilà alors amendement suivant pas
défendu
amendement suivant
non plus madame la rapporteur votre avis
sur tous ces amendements
alors il va y avoir un avis favorable à
l'amendement de Monsieur Viry un s2350
qui
remplace salarié
âgé par salarié seniors donc un avis
défavorable sur les autres par mesure de
clarté et nous allons avoir le débat
dans la suite sur l'âge les différents
âges liés liés à seniors à la définition
très bien alors Monsieur Ferracci vous
souhaitiez intervenir non c'est bon mais
monsieur Coulommiers Coulommiers
ceci est un amendement esthétique
cosmétique en quelque sorte on a
l'impression qu'il a été rédigé par une
main CSP plus tenue par le MEDEF la
réalité c'est qu'il faut garder les mots
dans leur dans leur crudité
c'est pas la peine de d'aller les
emballer avec du senior des trucs jolis
comme ça non la réalité c'est que pour
un grand nombre de salariés
âgés et finalement le minimum 10 ans
mais on pourrait même dire casser brisé
alors aller trouver des des littles des
des
enjolivements avec des termes comme
senior tout ça non il y a un certain
nombre de professions qui ne sont pas
celles des CSP+ ou arriver à 60 ans on
est plus seniors on est brisé cassé usé
voilà donc si on avait dû déposer un
amendement dans ce sens on l'aurait
plutôt fait dans cette direction là
bien monsieur Bazin oui je trouve
dommage parce que c'était enfin on peut
généraliser la réalité c'est que le taux
d'emploi des seniors et est très mauvais
dans notre pays et la question qu'on
peut se poser c'est comme qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour améliorer cela de ce que
je comprends vous voulez pas du tout qui
est d'emploi des seniors puisque
finalement on peut être à l'oisiveté la
paresse etc moi je rencontre des seniors
qui me disent j'aimerais qu'on puisse
construire des parcours pour que je
puisse continuer à travailler peut-être
pas autant qu'avant peut-être pas sur le
même métier mais j'ai plutôt des seniors
qui me disent moi j'aimerais travailler
même certains ils veulent aller au-delà
avec accumulant par retraite souvent
d'ailleurs sur des petites retraites ils
sont pénalisés parce qu'on leur dit vous
pouvez travailler que pour 300 euros
maximum par mois et souvent ça a été des
carrières hachées où ils ont été
pénalisés je pense qu'il bien sûr il y a
des personnes qui ont été brisées comme
vous le dites et il faut être
extrêmement sensible et et en matière de
prévention on a énormément à faire mais
pour autant on a aussi d'autres parcours
et pas que sur des CSP+ dans notre pays
il y a pas que des CSP+ on a on a une
diversité de métier et il faut pouvoir
accompagner sur l'ensemble de ces
métiers je suis pas sûr que l'index soit
l'alpha
Omega d'une politique pour favoriser le
taux d'employé seniors en réalité il
manque beaucoup d'autres éléments de ce
que j'ai compris c'est pas le lieu d'un
PLFSS rectificatif ce qui est un peu
dommage c'est qu'on n'est pas eu tous
les textes qui amènent la politique
cohérente sur l'ensemble de manière à
favoriser parce que sinon c'est double
peine on dit vous devez travailler plus
longtemps mais en fait ils sont plus
dans l'emploi et on n'a pas créé les
conditions à la fois fiscales à la fois
en termes de formation mais non mais
c'est c'est triple Pen si mais
objectivement je pense que on doit
prendre en compte l'ensemble des
parcours et accompagner chaque personne
selon son parcours
très bien Madame Rousseau
c'est pour défendre le fait qu'on qu'on
mette en effet les bons mots sur les
bonnes choses et en l'occurrence le
terme d'Agen nous permet de prendre en
compte les maladies professionnelles et
l'usure des corps puisque vous parlez
d'usure professionnelle et bien
précisément le terme senior a moins de
riz la difficulté dans laquelle sont
certaines personnes et c'est vrai que au
fond pourquoi ne pas dire les mots oui
ce sont des salariés âgés et oui pour
ces raisons-là ils ont besoin notamment
d'aménagement du travail de conditions
de travail d'interrogations sur leur
carrière leur formation etc et que un
index senior et bien ça ne dit pas la
réalité de ce que c'est
très bien Madame Parmentier Lecoq
oui merci madame la Présidente
simplement dire que effectivement
l'index senior n'est pas l'alpha et le
méga et on le présente pas comme ça
c'est pas la seule réponse qu'on apporte
au chômage des signaux d'abord la
première des réponses c'est de faire
reculer le chômage dans sa globalité et
c'est ce recul du chômage qui amène
aussi les employeurs avoir un regard
différent sur sur les seniors je pense
que ça n'aide pas beaucoup non plus les
propos qui sont tenus par la nupèce sur
les seniors qui serait tout se cassé
brisé ça n'aide pas non plus à valoriser
l'emploi des seniors et à favoriser que
les employeurs se tournent vers eux il
faut pas tout mélanger il faut pas non
plus laisser dire que notre réforme ne
prend pas en compte les personnes qui
sont usées par le travail toutes les
dispositions sont bien prévues pour leur
permettre un départ anticipé et même
justement pour éviter qu'elle soit
cassée en arrivant à l'âge de seniors
avec toute la prévention qui a été
évoquée auparavant
très bien donc je vais mettre au voile
amendement donc
2350 qui a été défendu par Monsieur
Bazin qui a reçu un avis favorable qui
est pour
qui est contre il est adopté et de facto
les autres amendements tombent monsieur
Petavy vous avez la parole monsieur le
député pour le 3797
madame la Présidente je vais vous
présenter plusieurs amendements
présentant certains seuils d'entreprises
différentes sanctions certains crieront
à l'obstruction mais moi je demande le
débat sur ce sujet le taux d'emploi des
60 64 ans n'est que de 3 33% seulement
33% face à ce chiffre alarmant Olivier
dussobe disait qu'il nous fallait gagner
la bataille de l'emploi des seniors mais
force est de constater que nous n'y
sommes pas du tout force de constater
que l'index senior en l'état actuel
ressemble davantage à une coquille vide
qui ne froissera pas trop le patronat
qu'un véritable plan de bataille pour
l'emploi des seniors par cet amendement
de réécriture nous vous proposons de
faire de l'index seniors un outil
réellement ambitieux de lutte contre
l'agisme structurel qui gangrène le
monde du travail nous proposons que les
sanctions et lieu non seulement en cas
de non publication mais également en cas
de résultat insuffisant
de fait un index qui aura réellement un
impact sur les pratiques des entreprises
passe nécessairement par une définition
claire et précise des indicateurs nous
proposons une sanction financière
suffisamment élevée et adapté à la
taille des entreprises soit 3% de la
masse salariale pour les PME 7% pour les
entreprises de taille intermédiaires et
10% pour les grandes entreprises c'est
pour nous le strict minimum pour espérer
voir un changement il est aussi crucial
d'aller vers une mise en application
moins tardive du dispositif moins
tardive car dans ce contexte de menace
sur nos retraites nous devons nous
donner les moyens pour donner au seniors
une fin de carrière digne nous le devons
au millier de seniors victimes de
discrimination à l'embauche et victime
de l'acharnement d'un gouvernement qui
lui-même discrimine au quotidien les
seniors en ayant durci davantage les
conditions d'accès à l'assurance chômage
on discute ici de la vie des gens
alors combien de temps faudra-t-il pour
mettre en place un index senior combien
de temps pour pouvoir faire des
négociations derrière combien de temps
on a bien entendu je demande tout de
suite la vie de Madame la rapporteur sur
cet amendement
alors
nous on propose dans cet article de
faire confiance aux branches pour
négocier sur ces indicateurs ça nous
paraît important et d'autre part il y a
une date de mise en place des crites
puisque c'est à l'automne 2023 pour les
entreprises de plus de 1000 salariés et
en mars 2024 pour les plus de 300
ce taux d'emploi il a également chuté de
manière extrêmement spectaculaire entre
1980 et 1986 après que là je rigole soit
passé de 65 à 60 ans
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que le levier le plus efficace
pour augmenter et maintenir les
seigneurs dans l'emploi et bien c'est de
jouer sur l'âge légal il faut quand même
le dire et le rappeler
cette réforme elle va accroître le
nombre de seigneurs qui travaillent pour
une raison assez simple c'est que
lorsque les employeurs leurs salariés
décident du moment où le salarié va
quitter l'entreprise avec un plan de
départ volontaire avec une rupture
conventionnelle et bien il regarde cette
borne qui est l'âge légal
ensuite vous dire que certes c'est un
levier puissant mais ça n'est pas le
seul levier sur lequel nous voulons agir
ça a été dit
le cumul emploi retraite qui aujourd'hui
ne permet pas d'obtenir des droits à la
retraite et en permettra demain si cette
réforme est adoptée permettra également
d'augmenter le taux d'emploi des seniors
la modification des règles de
l'assurance chômage au profit des
personnes qui travaillent ou qui
souhaitent travailler avec une prime
associée à la reprise d'emploi plus
forte pour les seniors que pour les
autres est également dans les annonces
qui ont été faites par le gouvernement
enfin sur l'index je veux terminer ici
l'index ne sert pas uniquement à
responsabiliser les entreprises et je
vous invite chers collègues à discuter
avec des gens de 50 ou 55 ans qui
cherchent un emploi ils envoient des
dizaines des centaines parfois des
milliers de CV à des entreprises qui
n'ont pas prévu d'embaucher des seniors
même s'ils ne le disent pas le fait de
mettre un dan Alex leur donnera cette
information quelles sont les films les
entreprises qui jouent le jeu de
l'emploi des seniors leur permettra de
cibler leur recherche d'emploi d’éviter
le découragement discuter avec elle
discuter avec eux discuter avec les
conseillers de Pôle emploi et vous
verrez que améliorer la manière dont les
gens cherchent un emploi c'est aussi une
fonction de cet index
monsieur Vigier oui merci on a la
présidente
avec ce sujet de l'emploi des seniors
donc on voit bien que je pense qu'il est
dans toutes les têtes et tente les
progrès que l'on a accompli la marque à
l'instant le seigneurs des 654 ans
extrêmement faible moi j'ai lu j'invite
les collègues à le faire une étude qui a
été faite par des chercheurs sur
l'évolution et la comparaison justement
de savoir ce que vous faites de partir
plus tard à la retraite poser un
problème de tôle emploi des seniors moi
j'étais parti avec des idées préconçues
en imaginant que si on partait tôt on
réglé le problème pas du tout je vous
invite à lire ces documents là qui sont
tout à fait accessibles à chacun et qui
montre que lorsqu'on décale l'âge de
départ à la retraite on améliore ton
emploi des seniors la seconde chose
quelqu'un disait non je suis prêt à vous
donner les documents écoutez moi je suis
pas arrivé avec des idées préconçues
j'ai voulu lire et comprendre la
deuxième chose cent mille seigneurs qui
travaillent en plus
c'est un milliard de recettes en plus ne
l'oublions pas parce que tout à l'heure
on était dans les sujets des
financements troisièmement sur les index
là je me tourne dans le rapporteur
général j'ai bien entendu madame la
rapporteur général que sur les seniors
il y aurait des index qui sortiraient
dans les boîtes de plus de 1000 salariés
et 300 salariés
pourquoi ne pas descendre plus bas
jusqu'à 5 ans comment on fait échapper
les petites entreprises j'entends bien
que ce soit pas facile et le ministre en
charge du porte-parole du gouvernement
disait l'autre jour qu'il envisageait
peut-être des sanctions financières
qu'en est-il à ce stade de la réflexion
merci
très bien la parole est à Madame
châtelain
merci madame la Présidente c'est un
texte senior finalement c'est la
démonstration d'une politique qui est
toujours la même c'est-à-dire une
politique qui est dure avec les salariés
parce que je vous le rappelle il y a
quelques mois à peine dans votre réforme
de l'attirance chômage vous avez réduit
la durée d'indemnisation des seniors de
manière drastique mais qui est
extrêmement faible avec les grandes
entreprises puisque finalement vous ne
les pénalisez pas
et c'est une manque de vision
extrêmement forte sur la politique de
l'emploi finalement votre manque de
politique de l'emploi qu'est-ce que ça
va faire conjuguer à cette case du
système social que ça soit de
l'assurance chômage ou des retraites et
bien ça va faire augmenter le nombre de
personnes qui ne sont ni en emploi ni en
retraite et aujourd'hui on sait d'où
viennent les revenus de cette personne
et une partie qui sont chômage 26 %,
mais il y a 23% d'entre eux aujourd'hui
qui n'ont pas de revenus qui n'ont pas
de revenus c'est-à-dire qu'elles
dépendent soit de leur famille soit de
leur conjoint je sais pas si vous avez
imaginez ce que ça veut dire va
retravailler toute sa vie pour dépendre
de quelqu'un d'autre dans ses revenus
c'est énorme et sinon elles sont à la
hache en invalidité ou RSA c'est ça
aujourd'hui vous allez créer une trappe
à pauvreté extrêmement forte pour des
personnes qui ont travaillé toute leur
vie et peut-être que bientôt grâce à
votre expérimentation sur le RSA c'est à
dire le fait de devoir travailler pour
pouvoir toucher son RSA et bien ceux qui
auraient dû partir à la retraite auront
la chance de pouvoir être en activité
pour pouvoir toucher
après ça et j'imagine que cela ne
comptera pas non plus dans leur retraite
vraiment le monde que vous nous
promettez et un monde de précarité de
pauvreté à tout âge
très bien monsieur Boyard
j'ai une question parce que du coup j'ai
entendu et vous avez fait preuve
d'honnêteté qu'il y a un problème sur
l'emploi des seniors monsieur Ferracci
vous avez détaillé ce que le
gouvernement prétend mettre en place
pour voilà favoriser l'emploi des
seniors nous nous contestons le fait que
soit une véritable aide mais même vous
vous pouvez convenir que face à la
montagne du problème ce ne sont pas des
mesures qui sont suffisantes ce qui veut
dire que vous admettez d'une certaine
manière que vous décalez l'âge de départ
à la retraite alors qu'on a une
situation qui demande de prendre des
grandes mesures grandes mesures que vous
n'avez pas encore pris et pour le moment
le peu que vous donnez c'est de dire on
va faire un index des seniors qui va
permettre un changement des mentalités
des pratiques culturelles qui
permettront de régler le problème vous
en conviendrez que ce n'est pas la
solution miracle madame Amrani a posé
une question en demandant quels sont les
grandes mesures que vous allez prendre
pour éviter que des personnes se
retrouvent davantage dans la situation
dans laquelle se retrouve beaucoup de
seniors alors que vous décalez l'âge de
départ à la retraite parce que j'ai peur
que vous nous fassiez un petit peu ce
que vous avez fait avec parcours c'est à
dire de dire oui on va faire la
sélection mais on va donner des
solutions par rapport aux problèmes
d'orientation doublement des professeurs
principaux visitent dans les universités
résultat vous avez fait la sélection
mais le doublement des professeurs
principaux ça n'a pas été fait le les
visites université ça n'a pas été fait
et donc du coup les petites cacahuètes
du bonheur qui sont censés faire avaler
la réforme n'existe pas et du coup on se
retrouve avec une montagne de problèmes
donc Madame la rapporteur je vous repose
la question qui a posé madame Amrani au
vu de la montagne de problèmes quels
sont vos grandes mesures pour pallier
aux difficultés que va poser le décalage
de départ à la retraite
très bien Madame La Valette vous avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente en
fait effectivement cet index ça mange
pas de pain mais mais imaginez que cette
index va changer les choses c'est ne pas
avoir croisé un DRH de sa vie on le sait
repousser l'âge de de la retraite n'aura
aucun impact sur l'emploi des seniors et
vous parliez tout à l'heure vous parliez
tout à l'heure des des sanctions mais je
vous rappelle mes chers collègues que
dans certaines entreprises vous le savez
il faut embaucher des personnes
porteuses de handicap sous peine de deux
sanctions certaines entreprises
préfèrent payer les sanctions donc on
voit bien que si on fait la même chose
sur l'emploi des seniors on aura
probablement les mêmes effets donc en
fait quand vous n'avez rien à proposer
vous proposez soit un numéro vert soit
un index
sur ce après cette discussion je vais
mettre aux voix donc cet amendement qui
a reçu un avis défavorable de Madame la
rapporteur général qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant
défendu par Monsieur jumelles non pardon
mais attendez
monsieur califer
s'il vous plaît mes
[Musique]
entre 42 ans avec Mitterrand 87 ans avec
Léon Blum voyage
on a un souci manifestement avec l'index
qui ne
va pas aborder plus que les autres
mesures que nous avons prises on a la
qualité de vie au travail c'est un
fiasco employé aussi des personnes
handicapées on vient le dire c'est
encore quelque chose pour les
administrations et là on a un index qui
est vide qui est mise en index et
l'amendement qu'on propose là c'est de
rédiger autrement l'année à 4 et
d'imposer quand même
une certaine qualité de prise en charge
de la bouche par le patron avant 50 ans
mais après 50 ans dans la mesure où on a
voté l'autre jour une visite médicale à
45 ans il faut qu'il y ait un continuum
dans ce que nous votons et pas
simplement faire des mesures sans
cohérence et que les entreprises ont
beaucoup de peine à appliquer à
respecter
très très bien Madame la rapporteur
votre avis oui c'est un avis défavorable
d'ailleurs le président du corps a
abordé lors de l'audition cette question
en rappelant que les deux c'est à dire
l'embauche d'un seigneur et d'un jeune
ne s'opposait pas les états d'ailleurs
qui ont le plus fort taux d'emploi des
seniors ont aussi le plus fort taux
d'emplois des plus jeunes c'est un avis
défavorable très bien monsieur Clouet
merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement nous paraît de bon sens pour
trois raisons d'abord parce qu'il
remplace un objectif proclamé par une
prescription deuxièmement parce qu'il
apporte une définition technique de
l'âge donc améliore le texte et enfin
parce qu'il est plus opérationnel de la
mesure où l'objectif qui est affiché
dans le document original est ici
rapporté à une action effective d'une
mesure de non discrimination qui est
particulièrement importante on le sait
chez les travailleurs
âgés ou expérimentés ou seniors quel que
soit le terme qu'on veut prendre en
matière de salaire de formation ou tout
simplement de mise au placard
ayant dit ça ça permet de continuer la
discussion générale sur la question de
l'emploi des personnes concernées par le
report de l'âge de départ à la retraite
puisque des études ont été citées on va
s'y mettre c'est le moment 19h30 on site
des études je voudrais m'appuyer sur ce
qui a été récemment enfin pas récemment
ce qui a été publié par Simon rabatté
Julie rochu à Paris School of Economics
qui a étudié les effets de la réforme de
que se passe-t-il lorsqu'on reporte de
deux ans l'âge de départ à la retraite
et bien ce qu'on voit c'est que parmi
les personnes concernées vous avez 33%
qui sont au chômage 17% en invalidité
maladie 10% qui sont inactifs donc vous
avez 60% d'échecs dans la dans la
politique en matière d'accès à l'emploi
donc ça ne fonctionne pas là je démarre
à la retraite et ça ne permet pas de
maintenir les personnes sur le marché du
travail alors je suis parieur ravi que
les chakras sont ouverts j'entends
presque aucun bruit c'est vraiment
extrêmement agréable et ça me permet de
reprendre du coup la question de poser
par par mes deux collègues précédemment
étant donné que vous attendez un effet
extrêmement faible voire négligeable de
l'index senior sur l'emploi des seniors
que voulez-vous faire pour l'emploi des
seniors
très bien la parole est à Monsieur dit
Philippot merci madame la Présidente je
rejoins les travaux de la commission
j'en profite pour m’étonner un peu de la
manière dont certains amendements ont
été traités parce qu'ils ont été
acceptés dans d'autres commissions comme
la commission des finances par ailleurs
et là ils ont subi les fourches codes de
lirecevabilité donc notamment sur le
cumul emploi retraite donc je voulais
juste très de manière très sympathique
vous faire part de mon étonnement
j'espère qu'en séance c'est bien sûr des
sujets importants nous pourrons porter
tous nos arguments j'en profite j'en
profite pour le pour le dire sur ce
sujet de l'emploi des seniors la
rédaction de cet amendement me pose
certaines questions bien entendu
aujourd'hui le taux de chômage des 50
ans en plus et le plus bas il n'est qu'à
5 et 5% et demi dans notre pays donc il
faut qu'on fasse très très très
attention quand on fait des comparatifs
malgré tout imposer des choses par la
loi aujourd'hui dans ce domaine me
paraît excessivement compliqué le
travail à se faire au niveau des
branches professionnelles parce que bien
entendu dans des grandes entreprises
vous pouvez avoir certains postes qui
sont réservés en fin de carrière à des
profils qui ne peuvent plus évoluer qui
ont des pathologies sans port de charge
sans travail de nuit ou je ne sais pas
les exemples pourraient être multiples
mais vraiment ce travail-là si on veut
avoir des résultats réels je voulais
juste dire que il faudra le faire en
bonne intelligence avec chaque branche
professionnelle dans son domaine et ne
pas multiplier les contraintes
législatives qui bloqueront tout autre
travail qui pourra être fait par
ailleurs
très bien monsieur
pour dire préciser et compléter ce qu'on
évoquait tout à l'heure sur sur le sur
l'impact de l'âge légal sur le taux
d'emploi
il y a aussi des études qui établissent
une relation de causalité entre le
départ de l'âge légal et l'emploi alors
vous dites que
et bien une partie des personnes dans le
taux d'activité augmente vont en
inactivité vont en inaptitude et c'est
vrai et c'est vrai parce que quand le
taux d'activité augmente et bien
forcément quand on est actif on peut
être en emploi ne pas être en emploi
mais il y a un impact sur le taux
d'emploi or ici l'objectif de cette
index c'est bien de favoriser l'emploi
pour les gens qui ne sont pas en
capacité d'exercer un emploi parce que
là je légale exerce également une
contrainte cette réforme porte vous le
savez nous aurons l'occasion d'en
discuter beaucoup de mesures beaucoup de
mesures pour protéger les personnes qui
sont en situation d'incapacité
d'inaptitude et leur permettre de partir
plus tôt à 61 à 62 ans beaucoup de
mesures pour permettre aux personnes qui
ont subi des métiers pénibles et en
particulier je ne peux pas faire ou
refaire le débat sur les critères de
pénibilité mais les trois critères dont
nous avons discuté tout à l'heure port
de charge lourdes postures pénible
vibration mécanique son des critères qui
sont traités dans cette réforme
ce sont des critères qui une fois que
les branches professionnelles auront
identifié les métiers qui les concernent
et bien permettront aux salariés soit de
partir plus tôt grâce à la visite
médicale à 61 ans
soit d'obtenir un congé de reconversion
soit d'obtenir un accompagnement en
termes de prévention de leur pratique
professionnelle donc un moment ou un
autre il faut voir ce que va rapporter
du point de vue du taux d'emploi mais
aussi du point de vue des finances
publiques et pas simplement la
cotisation retraite l'élévation du taux
d'emploi des seniors que permettra de
report de l'âge légal et il faut voir la
cohérence globale de cette réforme qui
est d'accompagner les gens et d'éviter
encore une fois que ceux qui ne peuvent
pas partir plus tard
partent effectivement plus tard
très bien Madame la rapporteur vous
souhaitiez intervenir
site et qui disent dans l'ordre des
journées dans le cadre des journées du
corps je lis cette combinaison de
réformes a eu un impact indéniable au
cours des derniers 20 années l'emploi
des travailleurs âgés a augmenté
régulièrement et significativement avec
une forte accélération au cours des
dernières années un moment donné quand
l'ensemble des économies sont aussi en
accord avec ça on a beaucoup de sujets
sur lesquels on n'est pas d'accord et
qu'on peut discuter mais là chacune des
réformes qui a décalé l'âge a montré un
effet positif sur l'emploi des seniors
très bien donc s'il vous plaît mes chers
collègues
allez encore un petit effort avant la
pose dîner
donc je vais mettre au voie cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant monsieur Monet monsieur jumelles
monsieur jumelles
bon index Seigneur index seniors
pourquoi pas un numéro vert pendant
qu'on y est vous avez quand même été
vous avez quand même été habitué à plus
d'un génosité et plus de le caractère
inopérant le caractère inopérant de
l'index n'est pas à démontrer le taux
d'employabilité des seigneurs
contrairement à ce que vous dites madame
le rapporteur y compris à cause des
réformes qui ont déjà abîmé l'âge de
départ à la retraite c'est aggravé et
votre réforme rien ne démonte qu'elle
aura un caractère automatique sur
l'employabilité des seigneurs par contre
tout démontre qu'elle aura un impact de
transfert de charges sur l'assurance
chômage et même sur les budgets du
département puisque on multipliera par 4
le nombre de seniors au RSA avec votre
mauvaise réforme
deuxième remarque
000 seigneurs ou travailleurs
expérimentés sont obligés de cumuler une
retraite de misère avec un emploi de
misère c'est à dire qu'il est vrai que
des gens qui ont des retraites de misère
sont contraints
alors que les corps
souffrent de cumuler avec leur retraite
de misère un emploi de misère votre
réforme ne répond évidemment pas à la
troisième remarque
quelles sont les freins de l'emploi des
seniors quels sont les freins quand on
prend le temps de discuter avec avec les
spécialistes de la question 1 la nature
des contrats proposés
la plupart des contrats proposés au
Seigneur qui sont dans les charrettes de
licenciement des plans sociaux des
boîtes ce sont des contrats précaires
deuxièmement le salaire proposé il est
dans la majeure partie des cas
évidemment nettement inférieur que celui
qu'ils avaient dans la boîte qui les a
viré comme un kleenex troisième élément
les éléments de formation La formation
pour adopter pour adapter un nouveau
boulot rien dans votre réforme ne règle
cette question la formation troisième
élément la mobilité vous ne répondez pas
à la question des caractères éloignés de
la République des territoires ruraux ou
la dynamiques d'emploi y compris pour
l'emploi des seigneurs ne sont pas au
niveau et je fais l'impasse sur les
DOM-TOM ou l'emploi des seigneurs est
unifie
de faire ça mais je savais pas
complètement terminé
j'allais terminer ma phrase en disant
que l'employabilité des seigneurs dans
les territoires ultramarins ou le taux
de chômage déjà alors bas des records
extraordinaires comment s'applique votre
effort
sur l'emploi des seniors en Outremer ça
intéresse les membres ultramarins de
notre groupe de savoir comment ils vont
avoir la double peine la triple pleine
avec votre mauvaise réforme sur la
manière dont vous envisagez alors le
collègue Ferracci nous dit
la réforme chômage est cohérente parce
que elle oblige les gens à retrouver du
boulot évidemment on supprime les
indemnités chômage donc il y a
effectivement je vous reconnais une
cohérence sur la manière dont vous allez
conduire les gens à retrouver du boulot
coûte que coûte avec cette réforme
très bien Madame kéké
pour quel index améliore correctement
les conditions d'emploi des salariés
âgés il convient que l'employeur ne se
contente pas de prendre en compte un
objectif mais qu'il atteigne
j'ai mes collègues qui vous ont posé des
questions madame la rapporteuse mais
jusqu'à là vous n'avez pas répondu et je
reviens encore sur cette même question
comment vous allez faire sur l'emploi
des seniors
quand même répondez nous c'est on attend
une réponse s'il vous plaît merci
monsieur
jumelles moi je suis pour le débat j'ai
pas de problème avec le fait d'être mis
en cause de manière personnelle mais au
moins qu'on détourne pas mes propos ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure vous l'avez
peut-être mal écouté c'est que ce qui a
été annoncé dans le cadre de cette
réforme et qui sera mise en oeuvre parce
que ça a été annoncé qu'en général quand
on annonce quelque chose on le fait
c'est une aide pour les seniors à
retrouver un emploi à travers un
complément de salaire
c'est un petit peu différent de ce que
vous avez présenté donc moi je vous dis
simplement que le débat je l'accepte
et pas avec des arguments mensongers et
qui détournent les propos
très bien monsieur jumelles oui c'est
votre amendement je m'excuse je pensais
que vous parliez de la manière dont vous
aviez motivé la réforme de l'assurance
chômage en raccourcissant les délais
d'indemnisation et donc on pénalisant
tous ceux qui sont au chômage y compris
les seigneurs alors là en gros vous nous
dites si vous êtes gentil si vous votez
la réforme il y aura des mesures pour
favoriser l'emploi des seigneurs avec
des primes d'accompagnement j'entends je
n'avais pas entendu votre phrase
jusqu'au bout mais moi ce que je sais
que c'est que la réforme d'assurance
chômage que vous avez défendu sur
laquelle je crois vous avez même
rapporté
va pénaliser ceux qui vont se retrouver
au chômage parce que souvent dans les
charrettes de licenciement on retrouve
des travailleurs expérimentés qui
coûtent cher dont la productivité est
montrée du doigt par certains employeurs
je pense qu'ils ont tort de faire de
faire cela et que donc vous avez je vous
reconnais une forme de cohérence d'un
côté vous tapez sur les chômeurs et de
l'autre l'autre côté vous repoussez
l'âge de départ en retraite et vous
renforcer le chômage des seniors donc il
y a une forme de cohérence dans tout ça
très bien Madame
Lara et merci j'aurais répondu à Madame
keke alors j'ai déjà répondu mais je le
redis dans ce texte il y a trois grands
chapitres sur l'emploi des seniors avec
cette index senior et l'information la
transparence l'obligation de négocier
dans les branches qui est une mesure je
le redis là aussi assez forte et
importante bien sûr c'est index est une
des briques que nous pouvons envisager
dans le travail qui va se poursuivre
avec un texte qui arrive dans les
semaines qui viennent sur le plein
emploi et enfin pour finir sur les
contraintes elles n'aurait pas
d'efficacité et en raison de différence
dans les entreprises et c'est pour ça
que nous remettons ce travail avec les
branches et les organisations syndicales
très bien Madame la rapporteur général
donc je mets aux voix cet amendement qui
a reçu un avis défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
pouvant être mis en discussion commune
et je passe la parole à Monsieur Bazin
mais un président de vous motorisez à
défendre les quatre amants pour qu'on
puisse avoir avec bonheur même
je donc ces amendements déposés par
notre collègue Stéphane Viry vise et
c'est cohérent par rapport aux amandes
que nous avons défendu sur les années
précédent à ne pas parler de salariés
âgés on a vu que ça pouvait poser
question mais de parler de seniors ou
2354 d'expérimenter au 2355 et on vient
sur des alternatives sur l'âge 57 au
2357 et de plus de 55 ans pour le 2356
et alors j'ai compris si on veut être
logique avec le sort des premiers
amendements que vous préférez madame la
rapporteur l'utilisation du mot senior
vous préférez l'utilisation du mot
senior
alors je vous propose de retirer les
trois amendements au profit pour nous
faire gagner du temps
du 23 54
même la Présidente je vous rends pas
très bien Madame la rapporteur votre nom
ils sont il y en a d'autres
ah oui ah oui j'ai pas vu pardon je les
ai pris il y a également monsieur de
Courson peut-être c'est monsieur qui va
défendre
signataires madame la Présidente oui
tout à fait ce qui me frappe dans cet
article c'est qu'on ne sait pas ce que
c'est qu'un senior voilà c'est bizarre
que la loi ne définisse pas alors comme
nous voulons aider à une meilleure
réglementation nous proposons de définir
ça comme les personnes
âgées de plus de 50 ans de 50 ans et
plus pour être précis voilà
c'est très curieux qui rien à voir avec
madame le rapporteur
nous éclairs mais il faut qu'on mette
quelque chose qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
travailleur un senior très bien
l'amendement suivant
oui comme souvent monsieur de Courson il
met le doigt là où ça fait mal et nos
amendements sont convergents parce que
vous créez un index senior et on sait
pas ce qu'elle est index parce que vous
renvoyez à plus tard la définition
exactement des critères sur la base
desquels on va pouvoir objectiver
l'emploi des seniors et on aura
l'occasion de préciser un petit peu plus
loin et on ne sait pas ce qui est un
senior donc ce qui est simple peut
s'énoncer clairement on vous fait la
proposition de définir en effet à 50 ans
là j'appartiens duquel on est considéré
comme un senior dans l'entreprise ça
n'exonère pas des efforts qui peuvent
être fait avant en matière de formation
en matière de déroulement de carrière de
mentorat etc qui peuvent se faire dans
leur dans l'entreprise mais c'est quand
même bizarre que de créer et de
d'afficher cette index seniors comme
étant le parangon de vos mesures même si
j'ai bien entendu vous êtes plusieurs
Stéphanie Rist à Astrid Panossian à nous
dire ce n'est pas suffisant voilà donc
c'est une première étape on vous dit
depuis le début que ce qui aurait été
essentiel c'est de mettre toute notre
énergie et l'odeur de débat et de
co-construction à travailler au
renforcement de l'emploi des seniors et
là je redis ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure vous auriez été réellement dans
la coproduction dans la co-construction
de la véritable réforme des retraites
celle qui répond aux besoins des
salariés et qui en même temps assure
l'équilibre financier qui était
d'augmenter de 10 à 12 points le taux
d'emploi des seniors parce que Stéphanie
iris peut nous dire ça s'améliore mais
la lenteur avec laquelle s'améliore le
taux d'emploi des seniors fait que de
toute façon vous continuerez à courir
derrière ce qui est au cœur de ce que de
de des difficultés des inégalités de
notre de notre système donc
au moins précisé l'âge à partir duquel
se trait timide est timoré et
insuffisant pour reprendre vos propres
termes index seniors commencent à
s'appliquer et on aura y compris
d'autres mesures qu'on soutiendra comme
celle de Philippe Vigier pour abaisser
le seuil de 300 salariés à 50 salariés
pour qu'on puisse concerner plus de
monde parce que je persiste à dire
Madame la rapportrice que c'est à peine
25 à 30% des salariés de France qui sont
concernés peuvent être index
donc sur l'emploi des seniors j'aimerais
me dire à Monsieur Guedj quand même que
nous sommes toutes et tous sensibles sur
ce sujet de l'emploi des seniors déjà
lors de la précédente mandature où il y
avait eu une mission là-dessus qui avait
été dont le rapporteur était Monsieur
Didier Martin et je crois Stéphane Viry
donc on est tous concernés par ce sujet
et on comprend effectivement
l'inquiétude donc il y a des
propositions aujourd'hui il y en aura
encore dans les débats et les textes à
venir madame la rapporteur votre avis
sur ces amendements
alors ça va être un avis favorable sur
le terme salarié senor quand salarié âgé
que l'on change par le terme senior du
amendement 23-54 c'est un avis favorable
il me semble pour répondre et je crois
monsieur de Courson monsieur Gad il est
indispensable de préserver une
flexibilité les études de la DARES ont
montré par exemple qu'on pouvait être
discriminés à partir de 40 45 ans sur
l'âge et que les entreprises ont une
activité d'emploi des seigneurs très
très différentes entre le tertiaire ou
la sylviculture ou encore l'industrie et
la construction donc c'est pour cette
raison qu'il nous semble pas favorable
d'inscrire dans la loi un âge parce que
en fonction de l'entreprise cette page
pourrait être pas appropriée donc des
avis défavorables sur les autres
très bien donc j'ai des demandes de
parole monsieur Clouet
comme résultat enfin vous proposez de
effectivement regarder le taux d'emploi
et je pense qu'il faut le regarder de
manière un peu plus fine il faut le
regarder par catégorie
socioprofessionnelle qu'a-t-on vu durant
la réforme de 2010 que du côté des
cadres il y a une très légère hausse de
du maintien en emploi parce qu'on parle
de maintien et non pas d'accès les gens
sont déjà en emploi donc en fait on se
réjouit qu'il soit pas licencié super
donc les cadres ont eu un maintien en
emploi tandis que les ouvriers et les
employés eux ont connu une hausse du
chômage beaucoup plus forte que la
hausse de l'emploi trois fois plus forte
donc dès lors vous avez ici une machine
à précariser et la question qui nous est
posée qui est morale c'est est-ce qu'un
emploi vaut un chômeur est-ce qu'un
emploi vaut une personne dans la
pauvreté moi je pense que non vous
pensez oui
la parole est à Monsieur Charles de
Courson
je suis un peu étonné de votre position
puisque l'amendement de notre collègue
Viry c'est de remplacer personne âgées
par senior
ça résout pas le problème alors vous ne
dites vous nous dites que les
négociations par branche définissent que
c'est qu'un senior chez eux je suis pas
insensible votre argument dans
l'aéronautique à 40 ans aux et de Dieu
40-45 ans vous êtes vieux dans les
services d'études etc bon il y a
d'autres activités plus stables dans
lesquelles à 50 ans mais il faut qu'on
fixe il faut qu'on fixe une
date madame un rapporteur et donc moi je
suis pas d'accord pour voter
l'amendement de votre ami viri puisque
il ne résout pas le problème
c'est un problème de qu'on appelle ça
personne âgées ou seniors Seigneur c'est
mieux que personne âgées mais il faut
qu'on fixe et d'ailleurs nos amendements
sont compatibles
on peut dire les seniors c'est voilà
seniors c'est comme on parle plus des
personnes âgées on parle du troisième
âge vous voyez bon c'est plus c'est plus
fun comme on dit bon alors
parce que certains d'entre nous on y est
déjà alors
[Rires]
merci Madame
je crois que on nage un peu dans le flou
et on se fait un peu plaisir parfois en
évitant en prenant le chemin de la
sémantique et parfois on habille les
mots et voilà que après avoir enlevé
personne âgées ou tout salariés
maintenant est-ce que c'est le Seigneur
de l'aviation est-ce que c'est le
Seigneur qui est dans qui dans qui maçon
et ce seigneur qui dans l'entreprise une
petite entreprise aussi pourquoi c'est
une entreprise de 300 personnes et si
nous voulons développer le travail des
aînés et le maintien je dis encore il
faut car il faut avant un travail en
amont qui permettra aussi de rester le
Seigneur c'est quoi c'est quand il
travaille que les conditions ne sont pas
acceptables ils préfèrent s'en aller ou
se mettre en congé de maladie il
trouvera toujours médecin bouleverse là
et ça pèse sur l'entreprise et si nous
voulons véritablement
agir sur tout cela sur l'emploi il y a
regardé ça sans sans comment dire
dogmatisme parce qu'on est en train de
se faire plaisir là et je veux dire
aussi il faut qu'on définisse et refuser
de de fixer un écart et bien on a
débattu pendant quelques quarts d'heure
un peu gratuitement et le salarié on
peut lui imposer quelque chose
mais madame rapporter vous dites que on
veut pas imposer on peut pas imposer au
patron je n'ai pas de souci avec patron
moi j'ai pas de problème avec ça mais
quand même certains moments il faut que
la loi puisse venir cadrer des choses
pour permettre quand même à la au
capital humain de respirer et de vivre
c'est ça ce que nous cherchons pas
simplement agir sur les retraites
très bien Madame Parmentier le coq
je vous donne le micro allez-y
oui merci Madame la présente nos
oppositions nous disent que on ne fait
rien pour pour l'emploi des seniors et
que c'est index des seniors n'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga n'est pas une
solution mais même la rapporteur a bien
rappelé que c'est une mesure parmi
d'autres c'est un éventail de mesure il
y a les obligations de négociation dans
les branches qui vont amener à
encourager les employeurs à embaucher la
retraite progressive je pense qu'on en a
pas beaucoup parlé mais ça aussi c'est
un bon outil de maintien dans l'emploi
qui va être soutenu on va évidemment
continuer nos actions pour faire reculer
le chômage et la prochaine loi sur
France travail va permettre là encore de
renforcer l'accompagnement des seniors
et la formation et par contre que nous
propose la nups et que nous propose le
rassemblement national la nupes depuis
le départ des débats nous propose
simplement d'augmenter les cotisations
d'augmenter les taxes d'augmenter les
impôts est-ce que vous pensez que
vraiment ça ça va améliorer l'emploi des
seniors est-ce que vous ne croyez pas
que ça ça va venir casser de l'emploi
d'autant plus donc voilà la solution de
la Muppet pour répondre à un problème
démographique ça va être de casser de
l'emploi et le rassemblement national
qu'est-ce qui propose que le
rassemblement national nous dit vous
proposez qu'un numéro vert ou un index
mais vous proposez quoi vous proposez
quoi au rassemblement national depuis le
début des débats la seule chose qu'on a
entendu c'est vous voulez booster la
politique nataliste mais c'est bien mais
on fait quoi là pendant 20 ans donc un
moment donné il faut il faut savoir être
un peu réaliste avoir un discours de
vérité dire que les choses ne sont pas
faciles mais conscient emploi à trouver
des solutions
très bien monsieur Bazin
merci Madame la présente Madame
l'important je pense que cet article 2
n'est pas abouti à ce stade et qu'il
faudra le mettre en cohérence avec
l'ensemble des politiques publiques en
faveur de l'emploi des seniors qui ne
relève pas d'Impel effetss rectificatif
et en fonction des
âges auxquels on appliquera des
rendez-vous de prévention par rapport
aux carrières
il faudra qu'on puisse ajuster la
définition du public cible notamment sur
l'index parce que aujourd'hui il y a un
flou et quand il y a un flou il y a
parfois un loup
bah oui elle nous a fait du mal sur le
travail
très bien donc sur ce je vais mettre au
vote l'amendement 23 54 qui a reçu un
avis favorable de Madame la rapporteur
qui est pour
qui est contre il est adopté amendement
suivant qui a reçu un avis défavorable
qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant qui a reçu aussi un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur qui
est pour
qui est le 837 qui est pour
non qui est contre il est rejeté on a le
temps d'aborder un autre amendement non
vous me dites NON bon bah alors
bon appétit et à 21h c'est pas 21h30
c'est 21h à tout à l'heure